GOOD MORNING THIS WILL BEGIN TODAY
SUB ONE HEARING ON MAY
NINETEENTH TWENTY TWENTY. I
FIRST WANT TO START. GIVEN
THESE UNPRECEDENTED TIMES AND
LOGISTICAL HURDLES JUST TO SAY
A FEW THANK YOUS AND WANTS TO
APPRECIATE THE SPEAKER STAFF AS
WELL AS THE BUDGET STAFF THE
ASSEMBLY SERGEANTS AS WELL AS
THE LEGISLATIVE DATA CENTER FOR
THEIR HARD WORK IN FIGURING AND
PRODUCING THAT THAT WE CAN.
HALF OF THE PUBLIC BUT BUT OUR
PRIORITY TODAY IS TO RECEIVE
THAT PUBLIC COMMENT RECOGNIZING
THAT THIS MAY BE OUR ONLY
OPPORTUNITY FOR PUBLIC INPUT IN
A PUBLIC SETTING. FIRST WE WILL
HEARFROM THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE AND THEN FROM
THE ADMINISTRATION WHICH WILL
BRIEFLY PRESENT ON THE OVERALL
CONTENT AND FRAMING OF THEIR
MAY REVISION PROPOSAL. THIS
WILL BE FOLLOWED BY LIMITED
TIME FOR QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS
FROM MEMBERS OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE AND THEN WE WILL
MOVE TO EXTENDED PUBLIC COMMENT
THE PROCESS WHICH I WILL
OUTLINE. I WILL NOW READ SOME
DIRECTIONS REGARDING PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION IN TODAY'S
HEARING TO HELP US TO ENSURE
THAT EVERYONE WHO IS HERE
TODAY. CAN BE HEARD WHILE ALSO
ALLOWING FULL PUBLIC ACCESS TO
THIS DISCUSSION. NOW FOR THE
PUBLIC WHO IS IN THE ROOM WE
ARE IN CAPITAL ROOM FOR THIRTY
SEVEN. AND WE ARE HAVING A
PHYSICALLY DISTANT IN PERSON
HEARING. THERE ARE STRICT
PHYSICAL DISTANCING PROTOCOLS
FOR THE PUBLIC TO ENTER AND
EXIT THE CAPITAL. AND FOR THOSE
WHO ARE HERE TODAY TO MAKE
PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. FOR THOSE OF
YOU WHO ARE REMOTE AT THE
MOMENT. WE WILL BE USING A
MODERATED TELEPHONE SERVICE FOR
MOST OF THE PUBLIC COMMENT
PORTION OF TODAY'S AGENDA. THIS
PHONE NUMBER WAS MADE AVAILABLE
WHEN THE AGENDA WAS POSTED ON
OUR WEBSITE LAST FRIDAY. AND
SAID ALSO APPEAR ON THE LIVE
STREAM SCREEN DURING PUBLIC
COMMENTS. ARE CALL IN NUMBER
TODAY IS. ONE EIGHT SEVEN SIX
NINE TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN.
AND THE ACCESS CODE IS TWO
EIGHT THREE FOUR THREE EIGHT.
PLEASE THAT YOU ONLY NEED TO
TYPE IN ONE AND ZERO ONCE
REENTERING THOSE TWO DIGITS
WILL TAKE YOU OUT OF CUES SO
PLEASE AVOID DOING THAT. FOR
OUR PANELISTS ALL OF OUR
PANELISTS TODAY ARE APPEARING
REMOTELY FROM THE WITNESS VIDEO
ROOM OR OTHER REMOTE LOCATION
WITH STAFF ASSISTING SO THAT
THE PANEL CAN CONVERSE WITH THE
MEMBERS. WHO ARE HERE IN THE
ROOM. SHOULD WE EXPERIENCE ANY
TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES WE ASK
THAT YOU PLEASE BE PATIENT WITH
US. NOW I WOULD LIKE TO ASK OUR
COMMITTEE CONSULTANT TO PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. WHEN WE HAVE A
QUORUM AND SINCE WE HAVEN'T
ESTABLISHED IT YET- ACTUALLY
MOVE ON TO A FEW OF MY BRIEF
REMARKS. LAST THURSDAY MAY
FOURTEENTH WE RECEIVED THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISION. NOW
THIS MAY REVISION IS UNLIKE ANY
OTHER CALIFORNIA HAS EVER
EXPERIENCED IN MODERN TIMES. IT
WILL LEAD TO A BUDGET THAT THE
LEGISLATURE WILL ADOPT ON OR
BEFORE JUNE FIFTEENTH. THAT NOT
ONLY COPES WITH THE PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISIS. BUT ALSO
RESPONDS TO AN ABRUPT ECONOMIC
RECESSION INFLICTED BY THE
COVERT NINETEEN CRISIS. THERE
ARE MANY CHANGES PROPOSED IN
THE MAY REVISION ACROSS HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES THE PURPOSE
OF TODAY'S HEARING IS TO
PROVIDE THE VENUE. FOR THE
INDISPENSABLE ROLE OF LISTENING
TO THE PEOPLE IN THIS THANK
ABOUT WHAT HAS BEEN PROPOSED.
OUR GOAL IS CLEAR TO HEAR YOUR
VALUABLE FEEDBACK AND ADVICE ON
WHAT COURSE THE LEGISLATURE AND
INNER COULD ULTIMATELY TAKE
TOWARDS A BUDGET AGREEMENT. WE
WANT TO LISTEN AND TO ABSORB
WHAT THE COMMUNITY HAS TO SAY
IN REACTION TO THE PROPOSALS
AND TO TAKE UNDER SERIOUS
WAITED AND HEART. CONSIDERATION
AS WE CRAFT OUR AND OUR PATH
TOWARDS A TWENTY TWENTY ONE
BUDGET. WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO
ASK IF ANY OF MY COLLEAGUES
HERE ON THE SUBCOMMITTEE WOULD
LIKE TO OFFER ANY OPENING
REMARKS. SEEING NONE I WILL NOW
ASK IF WE CAN ESTABLISH CORN.
ARAMBULA HERE FRAZIER YOUR
MATHIS PATTERSON RAMOS REVIEW
THERE WOULD. NOW WE WILL MOVE
ON TO OUR FIRST PANEL AND I'M
GOING TO ASK FOR ALL THREE OF
OUR PANELISTS TO SPEAK
SEQUENTIALLY AND WE WILL HOLD
OFF WITH ANY QUESTIONS AFTER
THREE PRESENT. WAIT THEN ASK OF
THE ARE ANY FOR THE PANELISTS
THERE WILL ALSO BE LIMITED
NUMBER OF STATE OFFICIALS
AVAILABLE IN THE WITNESS VIDEO
ROOM. TO ANSWER QUESTIONS SO I
ASK THAT EVERYONE PLEASE BE
PATIENT AS THE VARIOUS
PANELISTS ANOTHER
REPRESENTATIVES RESPONSE TO
QUESTIONS. WITH THAT I WANT TO
ASK OUR FIRST SPEAKER MARK
NEWTON DEPUTY LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. TO PLEASE
BEGIN WITH AN OVERVIEW OF THE
HEALTH PROPOSALS IN THE MAY
REVISION. MISTER NEWTON IS
JOINING US REMOTELY VIA
TELECONFERENCE THE LA- HAS
PROVIDED A HANDOUT WHICH IS
POSTED ON THE SUB COMMITTEES
WEBSITE. AND WITH MISTER NOONAN
WILL REFERENCE AS WE GO THROUGH
THE PRESENTATION THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US MR IN PLEASE BEGIN
YOU ARE READY. MISTER CHIR YOU
CAN ASK YEAH I NEED TO CALL
FROM THE DEVICE. MR NOON I
BELIEVE YOU'RE ON MUTE. IS THAT
THE GOOD MISTER CHAIR THAT'S
PERFECT. GOOD OF PAUL TRIES FOR
THAT- SO AGAIN MARK KNEW DIDN'T
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
WE'VE BEEN ASKED TO PRESENT AN
OVERVIEW OF THE MAJOR HEALTH
PROPOSALS IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET UP MAY REVISION BUDGET
AND I'LL BE FOLLOWING THE
PRESENTATION AT THE HEAD OF
TATIAN THAT THE CHAIR REFERENCE.
SO IN TWO TO PAGE ONE OF THE
HEAD OF THIS GIVES THE MEMBERS
A BIG. OF THE GENERAL FUND
HEALTH BUDGET BETWEEN JANUARY
AND MAY AND AS YOU'LL SEE IT'S
A IT'S A ROUGHLY THREE BILLION
DOLLAR REDUCTION IN THE GENERAL
FUND BUDGET BETWEEN JANUARY AND
MAY ALMOST AND CONCENTRATED- IN
IN MEDI CAL ASSISTANCE. THIS IS
A TEN PERCENT- REDUCTION WHICH
IS FAIRLY OF THE GENERAL
REDUCTIONS ACROSS VARIOUS SET
STATE POLICY AREAS. BUT IF WE
TURN TO PAGE TWO- AND THIS IS
QUITE RELEVANT IN LOOKING AT
THE BIG PICTURE IN TERMS OF
TOTAL FUNDING FOR HELP
PROGRAMS. TO REIMAGINE TOTAL
FUNDING WE'RE INCLUDING- THE
GENERAL FUND OBVIOUSLY BUT
FEDERAL FUNDS AND SPECIAL
FUNDS. AND WHEN YOU CONSIDER-
FINDS THAT THE BUDGET ACTUALLY
THE HEALTH BUT IT ACTUALLY DOES
INCREASE BETWEEN JANUARY AND
MAY. BY ABOUT EIGHT POINT SEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS AND THAT'S
ROUGHLY AN 8% 28% IN. THAT
INCREASE VERY MUCH REFLECTS.
ENHANCED FEDERAL FUNDING AND
THAT IN THE ENHANCE FEDERAL
FUNDING IS COMING FROM A FEW
PLACES AND I AGAIN LARGELY
CONCENTRATED IN THE- MEDI CAL.
ASSISTANCE THE PROGRAM. IT WAS
ENHANCE FEDERAL FUNDING FOR
MEDI CAL IN THE FAMILIES FOR
CORONA- REALLY RUN A VIRUS
RELIEF ACT- THAT PROVIDES A SIX
POINT TWO PERCENTAGE POINT.
INCREASE IN IN EFFECT
PARTICIPATION IN MEDI CAL
DURING THE TERM OF THE PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY. BUT ANOTHER
KEY- REASON WHY THE FEDERAL
FUNDS ARE GOING UP IS BECAUSE
OF THE RECENT FEDERAL APPROVAL
THE MAN CARE ORGANIZED ATTACKS
THE LEGISLATURE APPROVED. AND
AT MS TOP DOES PROVIDE GENERAL
FUND RELIEF BUT ALSO GENTLY.
FEDERAL IS. KEEP I WOULD LIKE
MAKE ABOUT FUNDS IS AS YOU SEE
IT'S THAT THE THAT THE BUDGET
TO IS ABLE TO BALANCE TO A
LARGE DEGREE BECAUSE OF THE
INCREASED FEDERAL FUNDING BUT
THE FEDERAL FUNDING DOES NOT
LAST THE FEDERAL FUNDING TO
LAST FOREVER. AND IF I BACK TO
THE TO THE TO THE GREAT
RECESSION- THERE WAS ALSO
ENHANCE FEDERAL FUNDING- AS A
RESULT OF THE ARE OF
LEGISLATION THE FEDERAL
ECONOMIC STIMULUS LEGISLATION
THAT ACTUALLY WHY TO. ABOUT
ELEVEN POINT 6%PERCENTAGE
POINT INCREASE IN THE FEDERAL
PARTICIPATION CAL NOT LASTED
FOR. TWO AND A HALF YEARS AND
THAT AFTER THE FUNDING. ON THE
WAS ACTUALLY A FAIRLY BIG GUY
IN THE MEDI CAL ANOTHER BUDGETS
AND NOT HAVE TO BE. ADDRESSED
BY FOR SOME FAIRLY MAJOR BUDGET
QUESTIONS SO THE POINT HERE IS
THAT- WHAT THE FEDERAL FUNDING
CERTAINLY. TODAY IT WILL LAST
FOREVER AND NOT SEE IT IS VERY
IMPORTANT FOR THE LEGISLATURE
TO CONSIDER SORT OF ON GOING
BUDGET SOLUTIONS- THAT WILL
HELP TO MITIGATE A BIG FUNDING
DROP IN THE FEDERAL FUNDS WHEN
MANY ENHANCE FIVE. BEING THE
WAY. BRING TO PAGE. HANDOUT I'D
LIKE TO JUST GIVE THE MEMBERS A
BRIEF OVERVIEW CROSSED WALKING
THE MEDI CAL BUDGET FROM
JANUARY TO MAY. BECAUSE WHEN
YOU LOOK. AT AT THE FIRST PAGE
AND YOU'LL SEE- A COUPLE
MILLION TO OUR- LOOK BILLION
DOLLARS TO REDUCTION IN THAT
HOUSE- IN THE GENERAL FUND. DOT
NET IT'S A WHOLE COMPLEX SET OF
CHANGES THAT ARE HAPPENING
BETWEEN MAY AND RESTRICT BRAND
MAY. AND MANY OF THOSE CHANGES-
REP ADDED COSTS. ARE INTEREST
OTHER OFFSET PAGE ROAD LIKE TO
CROSS MEMBERS PROVIDE THE
PROCESS. MEMBERS FOR YOU SEE
WHAT I KNOW ON AND ON. SOME
IMPORT POINT OF STE CHANGES.
CHANGES IN OTHER SERVE ON
ANTICIPATED COST SO ALL OR
JUST- GO THROUGH THAT QUICKLY
FOR THE MEMBERS SO THE JANUARY
MEDI CAL BUDGET STARTS AT
ROUGHLY JUST OF THE WONDER
TWELVE THE SIX BILLION DOLLARS
AND TO PROJECT TO MAY THE FIRST
THING THAT YOU'LL SEE IS THAT.
THIS A DISCRETION. WAS WERE
REMOVED THE- ADMINISTRATION
I'LL TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
SOME OF THESE LATER BUT YOU'LL
SEE THAT TOTALS A LITTLE OVER
FOUR HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
THE VERY ONE THE DELAY OF THE
COW AND PROPOSAL THAT WAS
PROPOSED IN. IN YOU KNOW OF
VERY STE. AND SERVE AT COSTS.
AND THE FIRST ADDED COST IS
HIGHER PROJECTED CASELOAD- IN
MEDI CAL WHICH YOU'LL SEE IS
CLOSE TO. CLOSE TO THREE THREE
BILLION DOLLARS ON WHICH IS
VERY SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT IN THAT
CASE LOAD IS THAT REFLECT. THE
COVERT NINETEEN. DID IMPACT ON
ON CASELOAD. I JUST LIKE TO
POINT OUT HERE AND IT'S
SOMETHING OUR OFFICE IS
CERTAINLY A VALUE WAITING- IN
AN IN DEPTH WAY IS. ARE THE
GOVERNOR'S CASE LOW PROJECTIONS
FOR FROM CAL AND OUR POOL AREA
ANALYSIS FINDS THAT WE ARE IN
GENERAL AGREEMENT WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION IN TERMS OF THE
NUMBER OF NEW. ARE MEDIC ROWLY
THAT WILL COME ON BOARD AS A
RESULT OF THE OF THE PANDEMIC
BUT WE'RE DIFFERS DEFINITELY IS
IN THE COST OF THAT NEW
CASELOAD AND- WE'RE NOT
EVALUATING WITH MINISTRATIONS.
ASSUMPTIONS AND DO THINK IT IS
THAT HAS BEEN HAVE BEEN RE UP
OVER. AND RISING JUST LOOK FOR
ALL. HAVE SOME RIGHT COSTA.
WORD NOT FRONT. CAN YOU SEE IS
THE TO AND NOT IS A REPAIR OF-
TO THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT OF
CLAIMING FOR MEDICAL SERVICES
THAT THAT APPEAR TO BE SERVE
IMPROPERLY CLAIMED AS A RESULT
OF. THE A CLICK CLAIMS NOT HAVE
ELIGIBILITY FOR THE MEDICAL
SERVICES THAT'S ONE POINT FOUR
BILLION DOLLAR ADJUSTMENT. AND
IT REFLECTS THE WE FIVE TO
SEVEN YEARS OF THIS IT CLAIMING
BUT ALSO AS A PERSPECTIVE.
ELEMENT TO THIS AS WELL AND
THEY BUDGET GOING FORWARD
REFLECTS A JUDGE ADJUSTMENTS TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE- THE CLIP IS
PROPER. THEN MOVING ON TO SOME
OF THE SAVINGS TIED YOU'LL SEE.
SOME OF THE BIG TICKET ITEMS OF
THE ENHANCE FEDERAL FUNDING IN
THE ROLE THAT THAT PLAYS THE
ROLE THAT HE- MCO TAX PLAYS IN
TERMS OF REDUCING THE GENERAL
FUND- AND THEN YOU'LL SEE
NUMBER OF THE BUDGET SOLUTIONS.
THAT WERE PROPOSED BY THE
GOVERNOR. OKAY ABOUT LATER AND
WHEN YOU SOME ALL THIS OP
YOU'LL SEE THE- THE MEDI CAL
GENERAL FUND BUDGET AT THAT
JUST A LITTLE OVER TWENTY THREE
BILLION DOLLARS IN. IN MAY SO A
LOT OF COMPLEXITIES- SERVE ON
THE PLUS THE NEGATIVE SIDE BUT
THIS PROVIDE USER THE GENERAL-
OVERVIEW OF THE- THE GENERAL
FUND BUDGET CHANGES IN MEDICARE
ALL. SO TURN EACH FIVE ALL LIKE
TO JUST GIVE A BRIEF OVERVIEW
OF WHAT HAPPENED WITH THE WITH
THE MAJOR JANUARY PROPOSALS.
ARE IN MAY- ACROSS HEALTH
PROGRAMS AND FOR THE MOST PART
BE THE DISCRETIONARY THE BIG
DISCRETIONARY PROPOSALS IN IN
JANUARY WERE HAVE BEEN
WITHDRAWN AT THAT- AT MAY. NOT
LIKE TO JUST START ABOUT WHAT
WAS RETAIN AT AT NAY. AND THE
CHART HIGHLIGHTS THE- ON PAGE
FIVE THE MAJOR PROPOSALS THAT
WERE RETAINED AT MAY REVISION-
THERE THERE ARE OTHERS I SHOULD
NOTE AND- A LOT OF SMALL LITTLE
PROPOSALS THAT. HAVE BEEN
RETAINED SO PROBABLY THE TOTAL
AMOUNT THAT'S RETAIN CERTAIN IS
OVER SIX MILLION OR SO BUT THIS
LESS THE MAJOR. WE WILL SEE
THEIR THEY'RE FAIRLY SMALL IN-
IN IN SIZE. TURNING TO- PAGE
SIX OF THE THEY HAND OUT YOU'LL
SEE THE PROPOSALS THAT HAVE
BEEN WITHDRAWN BY THE GOVERNOR
I'D SAT AT AT MAY REVISION-
TOTALING JUST A LITTLE UNDER
HALF A BILLION DOLLARS- FOCUS
VERY MUCH MEDI CAL AND- THE
INDEFINITE DELAY OF THE
CALENDAR PROPOSAL IS THE BIG
TICKET ITEM- BUT ALSO VERY
SIGNIFICANT IS THE WITHDRAWAL
OF THE GENERATOR PROPOSED
GOVERNOR. TO FULL SCOPE MEDIC.
AND YOU'LL SEE A SELECTION OF
OTHER BUT RELATIVELY SMALLER AT
PROPOSALS THAT WERE ALSO
WITHDRAWN ACCESS AT ME REVISION.
SO THEN OF TURNING TO- PAGE SIX
HERE- SKEWS ME. PAGE. GIVING
SURF PAGE SEVEN OF THE OF THE
HANDOUT EXCUSE ME OF THERE WERE
A NUMBER OF PROPOSALS THAT WERE
MODIFIED AS WELL AT AT AT MAY
REVISION SO RETAIN TO SOME
DEGREE BUT BUT TO THE THAT THE
SAVINGS OR SAVINGS WERE CREATED
BY REDUCING THE SIZE OF THE
PROPOSALS ARE SO THESE ARE
SIMPLY A MODEST ACROSS THE
STATE BUDGET- C. AS AGAIN
TOTALING ABOUT SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS. SO PROBABLY OF
MOST INTEREST IS ARE THE BUDGET
SOLUTIONS THAT ARE PROPOSED- BY
THE GOVERNOR IT MAY REVISION.
WHICH IS THE- THE SUMMARY CHART
ON PAGE EIGHT OF THE HANDOUT
YOU SEE THIS TOTALS TWO POINT
FOUR BILLION DOLLARS OF AS SOON
GENERAL FUND SAVINGS. AND THE
BULK OF THESE ARE SUBJECT TO
THE- THE TRIGGER OFF IF FEDERAL
FUNDS ARE RECEIVED TO. TO
ACCOMMODATE THE FRONT OR THE
PROGRAM ATTICA REDUCTION BEING
RESTORED. JUST BRIEFLY
SUMMARIZING THE MEDI CAL LOCAL
ASSISTANCE ITEMS THE- A FEW BIG
TICKET ITEMS THE LARGEST IS THE
ELIMINATION- REDUCTION OF MOST
NOT ALL PROPOSITION THE SIX
FUNDED SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENT. OF
IN THIS. THAT IS ASSUMING ARE.
AT THE GOVERNOR SOON AS A-
GENERAL FUND SAVINGS ABOUT ONE
POINT TWO BILLION DOLLARS FROM
THAT- THE REASON WHY THIS IS ON
A GENERAL FUND SAVINGS CHART IS
THAT SET. OF FUNDING THE
SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENTS WITH-
PROP FIFTY SIX OUT NOT FUNDING
EXCUSE ME SIR PROVIDES A THAN A
GENERAL FUND BENEFIT BECAUSE
THE TOP OF IT PROPOSITION FIFTY
SIX FUNDING THEN CAN BE USED TO
JUST OFFSET THE NATURAL GROWTH.
IT YET CAL PROGRAMS WHICH
ATTRACT OFFSET TO HAVE A
GENERAL SORT OF THE MEDI CAL
THE MEDI CAL BUDGET. THE VERY
FUND TRANSFERS IN AND A FEW
NEWS OR REVENUE SOURCES
TOTALING ABOUT HALF A BILLION
DOLLARS- SOME ADJUSTMENTS
CAPTIVITY RATE ADJUSTMENTS IN
THE MANAGED CARE WORLD- THE
ELIMINATION OF OPTIONAL
BENEFITS. AND IN VARIOUS OTHER-
THROUGH SMALLER A SMALLER
REDUCTIONS BUT THE BIG TICKET
ITEMS. THE ONES THAT- JUST
MENTIONED IN THE MEDIC HOW THE
MEDICARE PROGRAM. CAN AND JUST
TURNING BRIEFLY TO PAGE NINE
THE MAY REVISION DOES INCLUDE A
FEW NEW OCT AUGMENTATIONS- AND
FOR THE MOST PART THESE
AUGMENTATIONS IN THE HEALTH
WORLD ARE ARE TARGETED GENERAL
FUND AUGMENTATIONS THAT RELATE
TO THE- POPULAR AIMED AT
RESPONDING TO THE COVERT
NINETEEN- CRISIS- IN MOST THESE
AUGMENTATIONS ALSO TO LEVERAGE
A FEDERAL MATCHING FUNDS SO IN
THE MATTER HOW WORLD WE HAVE
JUST FOR NINETEEN CASTING.
COVERAGE FOR THE ON AND-
TEMPORARY INCREASE THE LONG
TERM CARE FACILITY RATES- AN
INCREASE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
PAYMENTS AND- AND EXPANSION OF
HOSPITAL- PRESUMPTIVE
ELIGIBILITY. IN THE PUBLIC
HEALTH WORLD WE HAVE A- ROUGHLY
A SIX MILLION DOLLAR GENERAL
FUND AUGMENTATION- TO INCREASE
THE LABORATORY- CAPACITY AND
EMERGENCY RESPONSE CAPACITY IN
THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
SO TURNING TO THE FINAL SECTION
OF THE OF THE HAND ARE JUST
LIKE TO TALK FOR A MINUTE OR
TWO FOR THAT TO THE MEMBERS OF
A KEY CONSIDERATIONS.
EVALUATING THROUGH THE HEALTH
BUDGET SOLUTIONS PROPOSED BY
THE GOVERNOR- THIS SAID
COMMENTARY HERE IS SOMEWHAT
SIMILAR TO WHAT YOU'VE HEARD
FROM MY COLLEAGUE GET GINNY
BALLOT YESTERDAY AND ON THE
HUMAN SERVICES SIDE. SOLDIERS
HIGHLIGHT TO SORT OF A- A FEW
THINGS HERE THE FIRST IS JUST
ON THE CASELOAD ESTIMATE SIDE
THIS IS A VERY VERY IMPORTANT-
CONSIDERATION FOR THE FOR THE
LEGISLATURE BECAUSE- THE MEDI
CAL CASELOAD IN THE HEALTH-
ROUND IS. WHICH FOR THE MOST
SECOND EVER OF INK INC COSTS.
IN HEALTH PROGRAM COSTS IN THE
BUDGET YEAR. SO UNDERSTANDING
THE ADMINISTRATION'S
ASSUMPTIONS ASSOCIATED WITH
BUILDING THE CASE SO THAT'S
MEANT WILL BE VERY KEY. AND AS
I MENTIONED THE- OUR OFFICE
WILL BE- ADVISING THE- THE
LEGISLATURE ON THE
MINISTRATIONS ESTIMATES AND-
IN. PROPS THE RECOMMENDING I
HAVE A REVISED A REVISION TO
THAT ESTIMATE. SO WE HAVE A
NUMBER OF PROPOSALS THAT THE
GOVERNOR IS MAKING CLEARLY
IMPORTANT TO CONSIDER THAT THE
TRADE OFFS OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSALS- A KEY QUESTION TO
ASK IN TERMS OF ALL PROPOSALS
IS IT WHAT IS THE IMPACT. OF
THE PROPOSAL SORT OF ON A
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS AND THAT
AND ALSO ON- AN INDIVIDUAL'S
PERSONAL PERSONAL ECONOMIC
SITUATION. AND IN THE MAJOR
POINT HERE IS THAT WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE PROPOSAL'S
ARE NOT WORKING AT CROSS
PURPOSES. WITH THE PANDEMIC
RESPONSE THE- AND- JUST TO GIVE
JUST ONE PROPS SERVE SMALL
EXAMPLE BUT IMPORTANT EXAMPLE
OF THIS- THAT THE GOVERNOR IS
PROPOSING A REDUCTION TO THE
BLACK- INFANT HEALTH PROGRAM
NOT A TOTAL ELIMINATION. BUT
BUT IT BUT A SIGNIFICANT TO A
SIGNIFICANT REDUCTION. POINT
HERE BUT THE BLOCKING HEALTH
PROGRAM IS A PRO THAT IS SIGNED
ARE. AND. AND WITH THE COVERT
NINETEEN CRISIS THERE'S QUITE-
A LOT OF- IN ALICE'S THAT
POINTS TO DISPARITIES
INCREASING WITH THE PANDEMIC-
AND THUS. IMPORTANT FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER WHETHER
THIS IS A PROGRAM THAT THAT
WOULD BE APPROPRIATE TO- TO AS.
IT DOES APPEAR TO RUN COUNTER
TO EFFORTS TO REDUCE
DISPARITIES. ANOTHER ISSUE IS-
I'D LIKE TO POINT WHAT IS THE
LIKELIHOOD OF ACHIEVING THE
SAVINGS OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSALS AND I DO POINT TO
IMPORTANT ISSUE IN TERMS OF THE
LEGISLATURE WANTING TO ENSURE.
THAT ANY SAVINGS PROPOSAL BY
THE ADMINISTRATION DOES NOT PUT
AT RISK- JEOPARDIZE TO THE LOSS
OF FEDERAL FUNDING. AND OUR
OFFICE IS CURRENTLY- EVALUATING
ISSUE IN THE CONTEXT OF SOME OF
THE PROPOSED MEDI CAL
REDUCTIONS IN TERMS OF NATIONAL
OPTIONAL BENEFIT IN SOME ALRP
BUILD. IF ARE IS THAT WOULD BE
A BIG PRICE TAG IF. IT IF A LOT
OF FEDERAL FUNDS ARE ARE
JEFFREY I NOTE THAT THERE A
CONTROL SECTION IN THE BUDGET
THT THE COUPLE HAS PROPOSED
WOULD- SET ASIDE CERTAIN
PROPOSED REDUCTIONS IF A
FEDERAL FUNDING IT IS
JEOPARDIZED. AND THAT CONCLUDES
MY PRESENTATION I LOOK FOR TO
BE AVAILABLE TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS FOR THE MEMBERS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
NEWTON NOW I'D LIKE TO ASK FOR
THE REPRESENTATIVE FROM HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY.
MICHELLE BOSS THE
UNDERSECRETARY OF THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY PLEASE PROVIDE
US WITH THE GOVERNOR'S FRAMING
AND PERSPECTIVE. MRS BOSS IS
JOINING US IN THIS VIDEO ROOM
MISS BOSS PLEASE BEGIN WHEN YOU
ARE READY. GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR. AND MEMBERS OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE. MY NAME IS
MICHELLE BOSTON I'M THE
UNDERSECRETARY THE CALIFORNIA
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCY WITH ME TODAY I HAVE DR
BRADLEY GILBERT THE DIRECTOR OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES DO YOU THINK UBER THE
CHIEF THE DIRECTOR AT DH S.
DOCTORS ANGEL THE DIRECTOR OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
AND SEASON FINALE THE CHIEF
DEPUTY DIRECTOR AT PUBLIC
HEALTH AND STEPHANIE CLINTON
AND THE DIRECTOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF STATE HOSPITALS.
THIS IS VERY DIFFICULT MAY
REVIEW. AND SO DIFFERENT FROM
WHERE WE WERE IN JANUARY. ARE
JANUARY PLANTS TO MAKE BOLD
INVESTMENTS TO ADVANCE KEY
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
PRIORITIES INCLUDING QUALITY
AND AFFORDABLE HEALTH CARE.
REGARDLESS OF YOUR AGE YOUR
INCOME. TRANSFORMING BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH SERVICES AND GIVING A
HAD UP TO THOSE WHO STRUGGLE
WITH HOMELESSNESS HAVE BEEN PUT
ON HOLD. HOWEVER WE ARE STILL
GUIDED BY THE VALUES. EVEN
THOUGH WE FACE A VERY DIFFICULT
ECONOMIC SITUATION. THE EFFECTS
OF KOBE NINETEEN PANDEMIC ARE
UNPRECEDENTED IN MODERN TIMES.
IT'S CAUSED ENORMOUS HARDSHIP
FOR FAMILIES BUSINESSES AND
GOVERNMENTS ACROSS THE WORLD
THE UNITED STATES AND HERE AT
HOME IN CALIFORNIA. FOR THE
STATE COVERED NINETEEN HAS
SWIFTLY BROUGHT ON AN ECONOMIC
RECESSION I DECLINE IN TAX
REVENUES RAPIDLY RISING HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES CASE LOADS
AND BILLIONS IN ADDITIONAL
COSTS TO COMBAT THE SPREAD OF
THE VIRUS. THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE PROJECT IT SHORTFALL OF
FIFTY SIX BILLION DOLLARS. MR
DIDN'T DID A THOROUGH JOB
REVIEWING OR DETAIL ARE
PROPOSALS IN DETAIL I'D LIKE TO
SPEAK QUICKLY TO OUR APPROACH
IN DEVELOPING THE MAYOR VISION
TO ADDRESS THE SHORTFALL. AND
THE PRINCES WILL THREE USED TO
GUIDE THE THESE PROPOSALS. OUR
PRIMARY GOAL WAS TO PROTECT
ELBIT ELIGIBILITY FOR PROGRAMS
WE MAINTAIN MEDICAL PROGRAM
ELIGIBILITY INCLUDING THE
OPTIONAL ADULT AFFORDABLE CARE
ACT EXPANSION. AND EXPANSION
UNDOCUMENTED CHILDREN AND YOUTH
IN A MEDI CAL WE ALSO MAINTAIN
CAL WORKS ELIGIBILITY. ANOTHER
PRINCIPLE. TO ORDER BILL IF
THAT WERE PROPOSED AT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. OF THE WE'VE
DELAYED THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
CAL AIMED WE PUT ALSO DEFERRED
OUR OFFICE OF HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABLE AFFORDABILITY AND
THE REFORM OF THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ACT. WE'VE ALSO-
CANCELLED THE CREATION OF A NEW
COMMUNITY BASED MODEL TO TREAT
INCOMPETENT TO STAND TRIAL
INDIVIDUALS ARE COMMUNITY CARE
COLLABORATIVE PROJECT. WE'VE
ALSO AT CANCEL TO REDUCE
SPENDING THAT WAS ADDED IN THE
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN BUDGET.
BOTTOM LINE OUR GUIDE THE BILL
WAS TO SERVE MORE PEOPLE EVEN
WITH LIKE WITH EVEN LESS
REVISED BENEFITS BUT STILL
MAINTAINING ELIGIBILITY. MEDI
CAL ENROLLMENT IS PROTECTED
PROJECTED TO BE FOURTEEN POINT
FIVE MILLION UP TO MILLION FROM
OUR ESTIMATE IN JANUARY. THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE
HERE TODAY WE LOOKFORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU TO PASS A
BUDGET DURING HIS VERY
DIFFICULT DIFFICULT ECONOMIC
TIMES. THANK YOU MRS BOSS. NOW
I'D LIKE A REPRESENTATIVE FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ADAM
DORSEY WHO'S JOINING US FROM
THE WITNESS VIDEO ROOM. TO
PLEASE PROVIDE US WITH THE
FRAMING AND PERSPECTIVE OF THE
MAY REVISION. MISTER DORSEY IS
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCES
PROGRAM BUDGET MANAGER FOR
HEALTH. AND HUMAN SERVICES.
MISTER DORSEY PLEASE BEGIN WHEN
YOU ARE READY. YEAH OVER.
YESTERDAY I. THE WOULD COME ALL
THE WAY HOLD ON ONE SECOND
MISTER DORSEY WE APPEAR TO HAVE
SOME TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES.
CAN WE HAVE YOU SAY TEST ONE
TWO THREE FOUR MISTER DORSEY.
ONE NUMBER FIVE ONE. FIVE SO I
THINK GIVEN THE HAVE OVERVIEW
WITH THAT I PROVIDED THE
COMMITTEE YESTERDAY- THE
OVERVIEW THAT WAS JUST PROVIDED
BY THE HEALTH SERVICES AGENCY
AND BY THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE OF KEEP MY
COMMENTS VERY BRIEF. IF WE
MENTIONED THIS IS AN EXTREMELY
DIFFICULT MAY REVISION. OF WITH
SOME VERY DIFFICULT DECISIONS
AND THE AND THE- REALLY UNIQUE
AND CHALLENGING SITUATION THAT
WE FIND OURSELVES IN IS A STATE
AS A COUNTRY. AND THE I'LL MAKE
MYSELF AVAILABLE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS THAT THE COMMITTEE
MIGHT HAVE. THANK YOU MISTER
DORSEY IN WITH THAT I WOULD
LIKE TO NOW IT UP OPEN IT UP TO
COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO ASK
QUESTIONS- I AM GOING TO ASK
YOU. CAN TO TRY TO DIRECTOR
QUESTIONS AND LIMIT THEM ONLY
SO THAT WE MAY. ENCOURAGE AS
MUCH PUBLIC PARTICIPATION AS WE
CAN. WITH THAT I WOULD LIKE TO
SEE IF ANY MEMBERS WOULD WANT
TO START. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND- I WASN'T ABLE TO BE
ATTACHED THE EARLY PARTY
HEARING YESTERDAY SORRY IT'S
THE IF IT'S OKAY I'D LIKE TO
MAKE A COUPLE COMMENTS ABOUT
SOMETHING SOMETHING THAT
HAPPENED YESTERDAY. OUR I GUESS
SO. OBVIOUSLY WE ALL WERE
LIVING IN REALLY REALLY-
DIFFICULT TIMES AND I DON'T
HAVE TO SAY I WAS PRETTY
SHOCKED BY SOME OF THE THINGS
I'VE SEEN IN THE BUDGET- AND
CONCERNED AND SO I'M HOPING
THIS WILL HAVE SOME QUESTIONS
ANSWERED OF THE CERTAINLY ON
THE HEALTH SIDE TODAY BECAUSE I
FIND MYSELF SCRATCHING MY HEAD
ON SOME THINGS ARE. BUT I WANT
TO DO I DO WANT TO SAY JUST ONE
CATEGORY- AND THERE WERE SO
MANY THAT WE HEARD OF YESTERDAY
AND PUBLIC COMMENT THAT I WAS
ABLE TO GET INTO LATE. OF
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS BUT RIGHT
NOW OF OUR OUR SENIOR
POPULATION AND JUST TO USE AS
AN EXAMPLE FOR SO MANY OTHERS
ABOUT BUT LET ABOUT THIS IN THE
IN THE TIME. THE I. P. THAT WE
HARD. NAY THE M. S. S. P. AND
ESSENTIALLY THE SEA BASS
PROGRAM. AT A TIME WHEN IT'S
CLEAR THAT IT'S NOT REALLY SAFE
TO BE IN A NURSING HOME OR NOT
ASSERT SAFE AS WE'D LIKE IT TO
BE IS REALLY REALLY TROUBLING-
THE M. S. S. P. PROGRAM WHICH I
HAPPEN TO KNOW MORE ABOUT THAN
SEA BASS. THEY TAKE A PROVIDE
SERVICES FOR. ABOUT TWELVE
THOUSAND LESS THAN TWELVE
THOUSAND ARE FRAGILE MEDICALLY
FRAGILE SENIORS. IN THE IDEA
BEHIND THIS PROGRAM. IS TO KEEP
THEM FROM HAVING TO GO INTO A
NURSING HOME. AND RIGHT NOW OUR
NURSING HOMES ARE HAVING A HARD
TIME DEALING WITH THIS CRISIS.
IT'S THE ABSOLUTE WRONG TIME TO
CREATE MORE A BIGGER POTENTIAL
POPULATION TO GOING TO NURSING
HOMES. AT THE SAME TIME WE'RE
ALSO REDUCING SENIOR NUTRITION
SO NOW YOU HAVE- AN MS AS P.
PROGRAM THIS REDUCING SERVICES
AND WE'RE GONNA CUT SENIOR
NUTRITION DOWN. AND SOME OF
THAT- I BELIEVE IF I'M NOT
MISTAKEN IS RELATED TO MEALS ON
WHEELS AND SO WE HAVE A WHOLE
SENIOR POPULATION THAT HELPS
DELIVER MEALS ON WHEELS.
VOLUNTEERS MANIC THE FOOD.
REMEMBER THIS OF FRAT
POPULATION WHO OFTEN DOESN'T
HAVE A SUPPORT MECHANISM AT
HOME NOW THEY MIGHT END UP IN A
IN A SKILLED NURSING FACILITY.
AND THEY WON'T HAVE MUCH IN THE
WAY ADVOCACY- LESTER CAN HAVE
LESSEN ADVOCACY BECAUSE WE'RE
GONNA CUT THE OMBUDSMAN PROGRAM.
THE PEOPLE THAT ARE THERE
MOSTLY AS VOLUNTEERS TO HELP
LOOK OUT FOR THIS FOR THESE
PEOPLE. WE'RE SENDING THE WRONG
MESSAGE TO OUR SENIOR
POPULATION AND IT'S REALLY
REALLY TROUBLING- SO I JUST I
JUST SCRATCH MY HEAD ON ON
THAT- I NOT LOOKING AT A MASTER
PLAN IN AGING AND I THINK
THAT'S STILL GOING FORWARD-
THIS IS A GOOD START. I FRANKLY
I HOPE THIS ISN'T REFLECT WITH
THE WERE GOING IN THE FUTURE SO
SORRY I'M A LITTLE WOUND UP
HERE THIS MORNING BUT- BUT I
WANT TO GET A LITTLE BIT ABOUT.
CONCERNS ABOUT SOME OF THE IS
WITHIN THE I TEND TO CUTS WITH
ENOUGH THE HEALTH PART OF THE
BUDGET- AND THEN I IT'S
PROBABLY IT FEELS VERY MUCH
LIKE WE'VE- TAKEN. THIS PLAN
OFF THE SHELF FROM THE GREAT
SESSION DUST IT OFF AND NOT
LEARN FROM THE MISTAKES WE THE
LAST TIME WE WE'RE GONNA REPEAT
SOME OF THE SAME THAT WE DID
THE LAST TIME OH. WOW I'VE THE
UNDER MARY SAID THIS IS A-
WHICH WERE FOCUSED ON
MAINTAINING. THE SAME TIME
WE'RE GOING TO REDUCE ACCESS SO
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE MORE PEOPLE
ELIGIBLE. BUT LESS SERVICES AND
LESS PLACES FOR THEM TO GO AND
THAT DOESN'T THAT FEELS WRONG
ON ON MANY MANY LEVELS SO LET'S
TALK ABOUT- SOME THE OPTIONAL
SERVICES. ADULT DENTAL FOR
EXAMPLE- THAT'S IT THAT'S
THAT'S A TOUGH ONE- YOU KNOW
NIGHT YOU I'M NOT. I'M NOT ONE
WHO'S CONSTANTLY ADVOCATING
ABOUT DENTISTRY- BUT THIS IS A
HUGE MISTAKE WE MADE IN THE
LAST RECESSION. AND IT FEELS
LIKE WE'RE DOOMED TO REPEAT IT
AGAIN- PEOPLE WHO HAVE THESE
COMPLEX DENTAL PROBLEMS ARE
GONNA END UP IN EMERGENCY
ROOMS. AND THAT'S NOT
NECESSARILY WHERE WE WANT THEM
WHEN YOU COULD ACT WE SAW SOME
OF THEIR PROBLEMS. AFFECT THE
FACT THAT THERE CONSIDER
OPTIONAL IS ALSO FRUSTRATING
IT. SEE EVERITT COOP IN THE
YEAR TWO THOUSAND FINALLY YOU
KNOW MADE THE CORRELATION THE
MATH IS A PART OF THE HUMAN
BODY. BUT IT FEELS LIKE. RIGHT
NOW THE MATH DOESN'T MATTER TOO
MUCH. AND THEN ALSO WE'RE GOING
TO WE'RE GOING TO ELIMINATE PUT
PUT THE AFFECTS SERVICES. SO I
GUESS FEET DON'T MATTER ANYMORE
EITHER AND WHEN USE AND THEN
WE'RE GONNA ELIMINATE THE
DIABETES PREVENTION PROGRAM WE
HAVE. FOUR MILLION PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA TAKING INSULIN. AND
THOSE DIABETIC BUT THE DIABETES
PREVENTION PROGRAM HASN'T
REALLY GOTTEN OFF THE GROUND
YET 50% OF OUR OUR PUBLIC S-
PRE DIABETIC WE'RE GOING TO
SPEND MONEY ON TREATMENT WE'RE
NOT GONNA SPEND MONEY ON
PREVENTION. AND WE'RE GOING TO
SPEND MONEY ON PREVENTION FROM
A DENTAL PERSPECTIVE WE SEE A
LOT OF DIABETICS HAVE DENTAL
PROBLEMS. WE SEE A LOT OF
DIABETICS WHO HAVE FOOT
PROBLEMS. WOUND CARE IS A BIG
PART OF WHAT A LOT OF DIE BET A
LOT OF PRIDE. PODIATRIST DO FOR
SOME OF THEIR PATIENTS. THREE
ELIMINATE THAT- SO THAT ALLOW
THAT TO HAPPEN IN ANOTHER
SETTING BUT WE'RE BASICALLY
SAYING THAT WE'RE NOT GONNA LET
THIS PROVIDERS DO IT. AND THEN.
FINALLY A NURSE ANESTHETISTS.
GONNA LAMINATE THAT PART TO.
NURSE ANESTHETIST PROVIDE A LOT
OF ANESTHESIA IN RURAL
CALIFORNIA. BUT WE'RE WE'RE NOT
GONNA LET THEM BE CONSIDERED
OPTIONAL BENEFIT IF YOUR
EMPLOYED BY SOMEBODY THAT'S A
DIFFERENT STORY BUT WE'RE- IT
JUST FEELS LIKE THE WHOLE
SERIES WHY WERE MAINTAINING
ELIGIBILITY ORGAN SAY WERE
ELIGIBLE WE'RE REDUCING ACCESS
ON THE OTHER SIDE AND WE'RE AND
WE'RE DOING THAT- IN WAYS THAT
IS REALLY. REALLY REALLY
TRADING. AND I KNOW WE CAN HAVE
A WHOLE DISCUSSION ABOUT PROP
FIFTY SIX- YOU KNOW IT FEELS
THAT- THAN THIS ADMINISTRATION
CARRIES ON WHAT THE BROWN
ADMINISTRATION DOES AND- AND
REMEMBER. THE REASON PROP FIFTY
SIX EVEN CAME TO BE. IS BECAUSE
A GROUP OF PEOPLE SAID WE'RE
FRUSTRATED AND SAID WE NEED THE
MONEY FOR TO PROTECT OUR
PROVIDER NETWORK. WE'RE JUST
GETTING TO THE POINT WERE RE RE
RE BUILDING THIS PROVIDER
NETWORK TO PROVIDE SERVICES TO
PEOPLE AND NOW WE'RE GONNA
LITERALLY PULL THE RUG OUT FROM
UNDER THAT. AND WE'RE GOING TO
DECIMATE OUR PROVIDER NETWORK
AND MAYBE. MAYBE THAT'S- HOW I
DON'T KNOW I HOPE THAT'S NOT
THE PLAN BUT THAT'S- THAT'S
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN IF WE DO
THAT SO. DO I AM CURE- AND I
HOPE THAT YOU KNOW MAYBE THE
LA- CAN. AS A DIVE INTO THIS-
AS WE LOOK AT THE- AS AT THE
NUMBERS A DISPARITY BETWEEN THE
LA OWES PROJECTIONS AND THE
GOVERNOR'S PROJECTIONS. ARE ARE
ARE CAUSING A LOT OF CONFUSION
AND I HOPE THAT WE CAN GET THE
ANSWER THERE. SOME OF THE-
QUESTIONS ABOUT. HOW MUCH OF
THE POPULATION OF THE MEDICARE
POPULATION IS GOING TO BE AT
THE FIFTY PERCENT.
REIMBURSEMENT FROM THE FEDS AND
HOW MUCH IS GOING TO BE AT THE
90% REIMBURSEMENT WE DON'T
REALLY KNOW THAT. AND MAYBE
THAT'S MAYBE THERE'S SOMETHING
THERE THAT THAT'S LEADING TO.
THE DISPARITY BETWEEN THE TWO.
BETWEEN THE TWO. A PROJECTIONS.
SO I COULD GO ON I'M I'M SORRY
I'M A LITTLE I'M A LITTLE BIT
ON A ROLL BUT. BUT I JUST YOU
KNOW I THINK- GEORGE SKELTON
HAVE A COLUMN IN THE LA TIMES
YESTERDAY AND SAID YOU KNOW. IF
YOU'RE OLD. YOU'RE AGED NEAR
DISABLED. THIS BUDGET REALLY
HAMMERS HAMMERS YOU HARD AND
THAT SEEMS TO BE WHAT WE DO AND
IN TIMES OF CRISIS WE HAMEL WE
HAVE WE HAMMER THOSE WHO CAN
LEAST AFFORD IT. WHO CAN LEAST
PROTECT THEMSELVES. AND HAVE
THE SMALL AND HAVE THE SMALLEST
VOICES IN OUR SOCIETY AND I
PREFER ONE THINK THAT'S
ABSOLUTELY WRONG. AND I'M I'M
VERY DISAPPOINTED. THANK YOU MR
TRUMP. THANK YOU DOCTOR WHEN.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER. IN MY
WORLD AND- THE WAY I WAS RAISED
WE RESPECT OUR ELDERS. WE'RE
HERE BECAUSE OF OUR ELDERS OUR
ELDERS WERE. OUR BENEFACTOR ONE
TIME AND SO WE PUT THEM ON A
SHELF AS MISTER WHAT IS SAID.
AND. BALANCE THE BUDGET ON
THEIR BACKS ALSO. I HAVE AN
EXPECTATION WHEN I BECOME. IN
THAT POSITION THAT SOCIETY WILL
HONOR WHAT I'VE DONE. AND
RESPECT ME AND TAKE CARE OF ME
WE TAKE CARE OF OUR OWN. SUSAN
DOING HALF. THIS IS TAKING A
POPULATION AND MINIMIZING THEM.
THIS IS WRONG. WE'VE GOT TO BE
ABLE TO. COME TO A CONCLUSION
JUST LIKE MR TING SAID
YESTERDAY'S HEARING. ON THE-
ANTICIPATED FELL WORKS. THE
POSSIBILITY OF STAGNATING
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IS
REPREHENSIBLE. WE HAVE TO LOOK
AT AND I KNOW WHAT'S MORE ART
THAN SCIENCE WHEN YOU LOOK AT
ASSUMPTIONS. BUT WE NEED TO BE
ABLE TO. BE A BUSINESS LIKE BUT
ALSO IN DURING TO THE PEOPLE
THAT WE HOLD. IN OUR HEARTS. SO
WHAT I WANT TO I WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THESE ASSUMPTIONS.
OUR OWN A EITHER. A LIMITED
AMOUNT OF MONIES HELD THE SIDE.
WERE AND CONTINUE TO FUND THESE
POPULATIONS AS EXPECTED THE
LEGISLATURE THE WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE. BUT THAT NAY CALPERS
THING RELIEVED AFTER THAT WAS
BROUGHT TO MY ATTENTION REALLY
BUGS ME. HAD A REALLY REALLY.
WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO DO IT
LIKE A BUSINESS EVERY MONTH
EVERYBODY HAS AN EXPECTATION
BEING PAID IF THERE IS. AN
OCCURRENCE THE PEOPLE ARE ON
NOTICE TO BE ABLE TO. OF BATON
DOWN THE HATCHES. BUT OTHER
POSSIBILITIES STAGNATION OF
DOLLARS TO ME IS HIS ABSOLUTELY
THE WRONG THING TO DO AND YOU
KNOW I APPRECIATE MISTER WOULD
COMING FORWARD BUT- OUR WHOLE
PURPOSE IN THE LEGISLATURE'S TO
DO NO HARM. TO BE HELPFUL. BUT
MY CULTURE MY NATIVE AMERICANS
FOR HIS HIS RESPECT URAL
RESPECT YOUR ELDERS.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MATHIS THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. I ABSOLUTELY
APPRECIATE AND AGREE WITH MY
COLLEAGUES MISTER FRAZIER
MISTER BOYD- AS WE DO LOOK AT
THIS BUDGET. YOU KNOW THE IDEA
OF GETTING RID OF EVERYTHING WE
FOUGHT FOR OVER THE LAST DECADE.
TO PROVIDE PREVENTIVE CARE AND
PREVENTIVE TREATMENT ALL THE
LESSONS THAT WE'VE LEARNED. TO
THROW THAT'LL WAY. I THINK ONLY
LEADS US INTO A BIGGER PROBLEM.
TO THROW AWAY LESSONS LEARNED.
ESPECIALLY ON THE HEALTHCARE
SIDE. IS ONLY GOING TO MAKE
THINGS WORSE. WE KNOW THAT
PREVENTIVE CARE AND TREATMENT
WORK. WE KNOW THAT TAKING CARE
OF OUR ELDERLY AS MISTER
FRAZIER SAID. THESE ARE THE
ONES THAT TOOK CARE OF US WE
HAVE AN OBLIGATION. TO TAKE
CARE OF THEM NOT ONLY THAT BUT
AS LEGISLATORS. WHO OPERATE THE
GOVERNMENT WE HAVE AN
OBLIGATION TO ENSURE THAT THE
PROMISES OUR GOVERNMENT HAS
MADE TO ITS CITIZENS. OUR CAT.
AND YOU KNOW I'M NOT SPEAKING
OFF ANY WRITTEN NOTES OR
ANYTHING LIKE THAT BUT- WE HAVE
TO ENSURE THOSE PROMISES ARE
KEPT. AND QUITE FRANKLY I FEEL
LIKE WE SHOULD TELL GOVERNOR HE
CAN KICK ROCKS WITH HIS BUDGET
AND CUTTING OUR HEALTH SIDE.
BECAUSE YOU'RE SAYING DURING A
HEALTH PANDEMIC. YOU'RE GOING
TO CUT HEALTH. THE MAKES ZERO
SENSE. THERE ARE OTHER PLACES
THAT CAN TAKE CUTS MUCH BETTER
THAT AREN'T GOING TO PUT OUR
PEOPLE EVEN MORE AT RISK. ARE
ELDERLY OR PEOPLE WITH THIS.
OUR CHILDREN TO CUT THESE
PROGRAMS IT'S ONLY GONNA COST
US MORE MONEY IN THE LONG RUN
IN WE ALREADY KNOW THAT. SO
COLLEAGUES AYE AYE ASH YOU TO.
HELP REJECT THIS. AND LOOK FOR
BETTER WAYS. FOR OUR STATE TO
MOVE FORWARD I KNOW THIS IS
KIND OF A SOAPBOX. BLOOD WE ALL
KNOW BETTER AND- AS MIGHT TELL
MY CHILDREN IF YOU KNOW BETTER
DO BETTER. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND- FOR THOSE ON THE WITNESS
VIDEO ROOM WE WILL HAVE
QUESTIONS THEY ARE COMING HAND
SO WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WRONGS. IT'S ONE
TO ONE. CHIME IN ALSO-
CERTAINLY WHEN THIS- THE COVE
IN NINETEEN ERA IN THIS CRISIS
STARTED WE HEARD THAT IT REALLY
AFFECTED OUR ELDERS- THROUGHOUT
ALL OUR COMMUNITIES INCLUDING
THE NATIVE AMERICAN POPULATION
WHO ARE STILL STRUGGLING TO GET
TEST ON COMMUNITIES AND TRAVEL
RESERVATIONS TO THIS DAY. AND
NOW TO SEE THAT THE BUDGET
COMING FORWARD THE BIGGEST CUTS
ARE TO OUR SENIOR POPULATION
THE PROGRAMS THAT ARE THEIR
PROGRAM THAT STARTED TO- TAKE A
ONE EIGHT FROM THAT ARGUMENT
THAT WE NEED TO BE PROTECTING
OUR ELDERS IN THE- CALIFORNIA
OUR SENIOR POPULATE. FOR MOST
AFFECTED BY IT IN ALL IN
ILLINOIS WE SEEN HOMES THAT
HAVE BEEN HAVING SAY AREAS OF
PEOPLE NOT ONLY JUST POSITIVE
FOR COPA NINETY IN. ALSO I MEAN
TO DEATH WITH IN TO SEE THAT
WE'RE TAKE THE MONEY AWAY. THAT
IS SOME THAT WE HAVE TO
STRUGGLE WITH TODAY IT'S NOT
JUST ABOUT. TAKING THAT MONEY
AWAY IT'S ABOUT THE SAFETY AND
THE HEALTH RIGHT WITH THE WITH
THE DIFFERENT DENTAL THE
MEDICAL ALL THOSE THINGS THAT
ARE IN THERE. FOR OUR OUR OUR
ELDERLY POPULATION AND ONE
THING THAT WE CANNOT OVERLOOK
IS THE FOOD SUBSIDIES THAT WE
GIVE TO OUR TO OUR ELDERS I SEE
HERE'S- THAT DEPEND ON THAT. TO
SURVIVE EVERY DAY. THIS AIN'T
THAT THE YEN IS ALARMING TO SEE
NOT ONLY SEE THAT SOME MONEY AS
THEY CAN- AWAY. BUT A LOT. OF
IT. IT THAT EVERY TIME WE GET
INTO BUDGET CONSTRAINTS.
THERE'S ALWAYS A LOOK AT OUR
ELDERS IN OTHER POPULATIONS AS
THE FIRST PLACE TO HIT. AND I
AM JOINING OUR COLLEAGUES TODAY
AND THOSE ARE SPEAKING UP ON
THIS ISSUE. THAT WE NEED TO
SEND A STRONG MESSAGE BACK
THAT. IF WE'RE GONNA CUT THE
BUDGET THAT SENIOR POPULATION
IS NOT THE TO GO TO START TO
LOOK AT. IT ALSO- MISTER CHAIR
IF I COULD THERE WAS A SPEAKER
THAT SPOKE THAT TALKED ABOT
FEDERAL FUNDS BEING IN IN
JEOPARDY BASED ON CRITERIA
CHANGING I WANTED TO GET A
LITTLE BIT MORE INFORMATION ON
THAT. AND IN PARTICULAR TIED TO
PROGRAM A FLOW THROUGH FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO THE STATE
IF WE START CHANGING SOME OF
THOSE. REQUIREMENTS ARE EVEN
FOR FEELING THOSE IS NOW THE
STATE. ON THE HOOK FOR REPAYING
THAT MONEYBACK WHICH IN THE
END COST MORE MONEY TO THE
STATE. RATHER THAN TAKING OUT
OF THE BUDGET. MISTER NEWTON
WITH THE LA- DO YOU MIND A
DRESSING THAT QUESTION I
BELIEVE IT'S ON PAGE TWO OF
YOUR HAND UP. YES CERTAINLY-
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS- YES
THE ISSUE- CONCERNS THAT
FEDERAL GUIDANCE THAT HAS COME
OUT FROM FROM THAT- THE FEDERAL
MINISTRATION RELATED TO THE
FAMILY FIRST TO. FRONT A RELIEF
FOR A VIRUS RELIEF- FIND AND
THE ENHANCED- FEDERAL FUNDING
AND- THE GUIDANCE DOES SUGGEST
THAT TO THAT CHANGES TO- SORT
OF BENEFIT LEVELS AND
ELIGIBILITY LEVELS. SORT OF
PRIOR- WITHIN SORT OF THE
TWENTY TWENTY YEAR COULD
JEOPARDIZE THE FUNDING THE
SCONCES JUST COME OUT AND THAT.
SO IT'S SOMETHING THAT THE- I
THINK THE ADMINISTRATION IS
RECENTLY. AWARE OF AND- AND
THAT'S THE REASON FOR THE
BUDGET CONTROL SECTION- THAT
SAID. THAT A CENT STATE THE-
THAT THE- MATTER. QUESTIONS
THAT WOULD DOT THE LAW OF
JEOPARDIZED OF FEDERAL FUNDS
THAT WOULD IT WOULD NOT THEN
TAKE A FACTOR SO- BECAUSE-
APPARENTLY IT LOOKS THAT THAT
IF YOU JEOPARDIZE. THE FAT ONES.
SMALL SAVINGS ACTION ON THE ON
THE BENEFIT OR- SIDE PROJECT
THE WHOLE PLOT OF FUNDING IN
WE'RE TALKING THE BILLIONS
DOLLARS SO- IT WOULD BE VERY
VERY RISKY TO RESCUE- THE LOSS
OF FEDERAL FUNDS SO. IT IS AN
ISSUE IF IT'S SOMETHING THAT
THE MINISTRATIONS EVALUATING
WERE EVALUATING AND TURN IT
WILL BE ADVISING THE
LEGISLATURE THAT WE'RE NOT TO
WE'RE NOT TO TAKING SORT OF
RELATIVELY SMALL THE GENERAL
FUND SAVINGS ACTIONS THAT THAT
COULD PUT AT RISK- OF THE LARGE
RECEIPT OF FEDERAL FUNDS. THAT
THAT ESSENTIALLY IS THE ISSUE
BUT BEING FACED. THANK THANK
YOU FOR THEM IS CHENNAI'S TO
POINT THAT OUT THAT THAT.
FEDERAL FLOW THROUGH DOLLARS
AND SOMETIMES WHEN WE START TO
LOOK TO HAVE A SAVINGS COULD
HAVE THE REVERSE IMPACT BY
COSTING MORE TO THE STATE. THAT
FOR FILLING THOSE OBLIGATIONS
IN THE FIRST PLACE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALMOST ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RUBIO. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND I- JUST WANT TO.
ACKNOWLEDGE AND COMMEND MY
COLLEAGUES FOR SPEAKING OUT- AT
WHAT I WOULD LIKE TO ADD TO
THAT IS THAT- WE'VE BEEN.
WORKING WITH THIS YEAR
POPULATION FOR THE LAST. FEW
YEARS AND EVEN NOW THAT WE HAVE
THIS PANDEMIC BUT THE GENERAL
SENTIMENT NOT JUST IN
CALIFORNIA BUT THROUGHOUT THE-
COUNTRY IS THAT. WE HAVE TO IF
WE GET. WHEN WE GET OUT OF
THIS. THAT WE NEED TO MAINTAIN
THE SENIORS ARE SENIORS AT
SHELTERED LONG. BECAUSE THEY'RE
MORE VULNERABLE. BUT WHAT WE'RE
DOING IS WE'RE SHELTER THEM AND
START WITH THEM GOING TO
SHELTER THEM. AND NOT PROVIDE
THE MEDICAL SERVICES THAT THEY
NEED. YOU'RE RIGHT IT DOESN'T
MAKE ANY SENSE BECAUSE EVEN
WHEN WE ARE MOVING TO GET OUT
OF SHELTERING IN PLACE. THE
GENERAL RECOMMENDATION IS FOR
THE SENIOR POPULATION
ESPECIALLY THOSE ONE GOALS ARE
COMPROMISED STATE. WELL NOW
WE'RE TELLING THEM STAY HOME
BUT WE'RE NOT GOING TO PROVIDE
ANY SERVICES. ON THIS
COMPLAINT- I- WE'VE BEEN
WORKING THROUGH THIS COMMITTEE
WE WORK ON A PILOT PROGRAM
THREE YEARS A GOAL IN MY AREA
IT'S- ANGEL FOOD PROJECT. WHERE
ARE. THE KEY. J. I. HE DIDN'T
TO FOLKS COME OUT OF THE
HOSPITAL I THEY HAD CONGESTIVE
HEART FAILURE I'M EXCITED FOR
THE RESULTS ARE BE FOR OUR
PROGRAM- THERE THE
HOSPITALIZATION RATE WAS ONE IN
THREE PEOPLE WOULD RETURN TO
THE HOSPITAL WITHIN THIRTY DAYS
THE DATE OF THEIR COLLECTIVE
RIGHT NOW SUGGEST THAT ONE IN
TWENTY PEOPLE ARE GOING ON BACK
TO THE HOSPITAL AND THIRTY DAYS
BECAUSE WE'RE PROVIDING
MEDICALLY NECESSARY FOOD AND
YOU KNOW JUST KIND OF TO PUT IT
INTO PERSPECTIVE PERSPECTIVE I
UNDERSTAND THAT. AND DAY OF
HOSPITALIZATION COST ABOUT TEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS SO IF WE'RE
FEEDING PEOPLE. AND KEEPING
THEM OUT OF THE HOSPITAL. WE'RE
SAVING MONEY NOT ONLY SAVING
LIVES BUT SAVING MONEY AS WELL
AND SO CUTTING THESE PROGRAMS
AND CUTTING THESE YOU KNOW THE
FUNDING IS ONLY GOING TO- WE'RE
SHOOTING OURSELVES IN THE FOOT.
BECAUSE NOW WE'RE SENDING THEM
BACK TO THE HOSPITAL AND IT'S
GOING TO COST US TEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER DAY IF WE ONLY
INVESTED YOU KNOW A FEW HUNDRED
DOLLARS AND FEEDING THEM AND
MAKING SURE THAT THEY'RE
THEY'RE HEALTHY. SO THAT'S THE
POINT I WANTED TO MAKE BUT WE
ARE CORRECT WE KEEP TALKING
ABOUT HOW WE LOVE OUR SENIORS
WANT TO TAKE CARE OF THEM. WELL
DONE WORK WITH OUR SENIOR
LEGISLATORS I'VE WITH A A. R.
P. ALL OF YOU HAVE YOU ALL WE
HAVE ALL BEEN INVOLVED IN THIS
AND THEY'RE SO PEOPLE BECAUSE
THEY SEE POSITIVE IMPACTS AND
THEIR WELL BEING BUT NOW WE'RE-
SORRY TO THAT. BUT IT IS NOT
FROM MY AND TO MISTER FRAZIER
DOES WALL MISTER MATHESON POINT
WHATEVER POOR. WEEK WE ARE.
TALK ABOUT DOING THE RIGHT
THING AND THIS IS NOT THE RIGHT
THING AND BE. PANDEMIC IS A
HELD PANDEMIC RIGHT BUT WE'RE
COMING HEALTHCARE BAD AGAIN I
WON'T BELABOR THE POINT AND
MORE BY WE NEED TO LOOK AT THE
DIFFERENT SOLUTIONS AND
DIFFERENT OPTIONS AND NOT CUT
THESE PROGRAMS THAT ARE ONLY
GOING TO GET US BACK IN THE
HOLE THAT WE WERE IN THE
BEGINNING. WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE PROTECT THESE PROGRAMS
TO PROTECT OUR POPULATION IF WE
WANTED TO LOOK AT IT AS A
BUDGET ISSUE IT'S GOING TO COST
US MORE MONEY IF WE WANT TO
LOOK AT IT AS WE SHOULD BE
LOOKING AT IS A HUMAN. RIGHTS
ISSUE WE HAVE TO TAKE CARE OF
OUR SENIOR POPULATION I AGREE
WITH MR FRAZIER I WANT SOMEBODY
TO TAKE CARE OF ME I WANT TO
TAKE CARE OF THEM NOW AND SHOW
OUR OUR YOUNG FOLKS THAT IT'S
THE RIGHT THING TO DO. SO THAT
WHEN I AM THERE THEY FEEL THE
SAME- COMMITMENT TO TAKING CARE
OF ME. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO AND. I'M
GONNA BE A LITTLE DIRECT I
THINK I HAVE A TOTAL OF FOUR
QUESTIONS AND SO IF I CAN I'M
GONNA START WITH THE LA- MISTER
NEWTON I REALLY WANT TO DO
AGAIN IF I CAN ON TO PAGE FOUR-
IT IT SEEMS UNDER ADDED MAJOR
COSTS THAT THERE'S ONE POINT
FOUR BILLION DOLLARS THAT. IS
ON THIS SPREADSHEET THAT I
THINK NEEDS A LITTLE MORE
EXPLAINING AND SO I'M HOPING
THAT YOU CAN DIG INTO THAT-
WITH SOME DETAILS- YOU HAD
REFERENCED IN YOUR COMMENTS
THAT THIS WAS FIVE TO SEVEN
YEARS OF BACK CLAIMS AND I'M
HOPING THAT YOU CAN EXTRAPOLATE
A LITTLE BIT. BUT CERTAIN
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS YES
THIS REFERS TO THE THREE
PAYMENTS HAVE OF FEDERAL FUNDS
FOR IMPROPER CLAIMING. AND
PROPS THE TO THE ADMINISTRATION
OR THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
CAN. PROPS GIVES MORE SORT OF
TECHNICAL SORT OF DETAILS SORT
OF ON THIS BUT TO WE UNDERSTAND
THIS WAS SOMETHING THAT WAS
JUST DISCOVERED- EARLIER THIS
YEAR- I THINK ADMINISTRATION IS
CALLING THIS SOMEONE OF A
SYSTEMS FAILURE IN TERMS OF HOW
THINGS WORK. PROPS CODED INTO
THE SYSTEM IN TERMS OF THE
CLAIMING THIS ISN'T THIS IS
DOES NOT AFFECT EVERYTHING IN
IN MEDIC HOW IT'S JUST CERTAIN
SYSTEMS WITHIN. THE MEDICAL
DELIVERY SYSTEM FOR SO- THE
ISSUE IS- AT LARGELY AND
CLAIMANTS- CLAIMING FOR BETTER
FISHERIES CERTAIN- WHO DID NOT
HAVE. THROUGH THE SATISFACTORY
IMMIGRATION STATUS TO RECEIVE
SORT OF THE FEDERAL MEDICARE AL
OR THE MEDICAID FUNDING- SO-
APPARENTLY THIS AFFECTED TO
SEVERAL YEARS OF CLAIMING- THE-
THE STATE HAS APPARENTLY ABLE
TO A YEAR TO- MAKE- MAKE AMENDS
WITH THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT- I
THINK THE ADMINISTRATION CAN
CAN. BE TO TERMS OF THE PROCESS
OF IN RING IN THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IT FROM. A THE
STATE'S DISCOVERY OF THIS THANK.
THERE ARE SUPPOSED TO THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO DISCUSS
AT TEN AND I FOR THAT THE
MINORS SO. THE LARGE AMOUNT IN
THE IN THE BY REFLECTS THE
PASSED THE RETROACTIVE- SORT OF
FEDERAL REPAYMENT BUT IT'S AN
ISSUE GOING FORWARD IN TERMS OF
MAKING SURE THAT THE ERROR
DOESN'T DOESN'T CONTINUE AND
THAT THE SYSTEMS HAVE BEEN
ADJUSTED TO ENSURE THAT THE
CLAIM IN IS. IS FULLY PROPER
GOING FORWARD SO THE BUDGET THE
MULTI YEAR BUDGET I BELIEVE HAS
BEEN BEEN ADJUSTED TO REFLECT
THAT- TO INSURE THAT THAT THE
CLAIM IS PROPER OR SO. THAT IS
SORT OF THE PARAMETERS THAT
THAT WE'RE WE'RE AWARE OF
PROBABLY THE STRETCHING BE
PROPS MUCH MORE DETAILED IN
TERMS OF HOW THIS WAS WAS
DISCOVERED- BUT THOSE ARE THE
BROAD PARAMETERS OF THE- OF THE
ISSUE. THANK YOU MISTER NOON
MISTER DORSEY DO YOU- ONE AWAY
AND PLEASE. MR. HI THIS IS
JACKIE COOPER- MISTER DORSEY
HAS ASKED THAT I SPEAK ON
BEHALF OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES MY NAME IS
JC COOPER THE CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES AND ADDS
WAS PRESENTED THE DEPARTMENT
DID IDENTIFY- A CLEANING ISSUE
WITHIN OUR SYSTEM FOR STATE
ONLY PROGRAMS WHERE WE WERE
INAPPROPRIATELY- DRAWING DOWN
FEDERAL FUNDS FOR SERVICES NOT
ELIGIBLE FOR THOSE SERVICES- IT
DOES VERY ACROSS VARIOUS AREAS
DENTAL DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES
SOME PHARMACY REBATES AND THEN
WITHIN OUR MANAGED CARE
PROGRAM- THIS WOULD REQUIRE THE
DEPARTMENT TO IDENTIFY AND
NOTIFY THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
OF THIS. FINDING WE WILL HAVE
HISTORICAL PAY BACK IN VARIOUS
PROGRAMS FOR UP TO THE SEVEN
YEARS IDENTIFIED- AND THEN WE
WILL HAVE FUTURE FORWARD OF
ADJUSTMENTS TO ENSURE THAT WE
ARE APPROPRIATELY CLAIMING
FEDERAL FUNDS FOR SERVICES THAT
DO NOT MEET THE EMERGENCY
SERVICE CRITERIA AVAILABLE FOR
STATE ONLY PROGRAMS. AND I I'M
HAPPY TO FOLLOW UP OFF LINE IF
I CAN FOR- FURTHER DETAIL BUT-
DID JUST WANT TO HEAR THAT
INITIAL EXPLANATION IF I CAN
I'D I DO WANT TO TURN TO.
DURING PLEASE IN THE WITNESS
VIDEO ROOM. AND THAT AND I'M.
I'M REALLY STRUGGLING A BIT
BECAUSE THIS PANDEMIC EVENTS
TAUGHT AT US ANYTHING IS THE
VALUE OF REALLY HAVING A STRONG.
PUBLIC HEALTH WORKFORCE AN
INFRASTRUCTURE. IN FACT MUCH OF
OUR ECONOMIC CRASH IN THE
RESULTING DEVASTATING CUTS THAT
WE NOW FACE CAN BE DIRECTLY
ATTRIBUTABLE TO THE WOEFULLY
UNDERFUNDED PUBLIC HEALTH
THOUGH OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS ARE FACING A
POTENTIAL LOSS OF A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS.
REALIGNMENT FUNDING WHICH WILL
NOT BE BACK FILLED BY FEDERAL.
AID AND SPECIFICALLY. FOR
COVERT COSTS ON A TEMPORARY
BASIS SO. I GUESS I'M TRYING TO.
UNDERSTAND OF FORGETTING LAST
FUNDING ARE WE INVESTING THE
NECESSARY RESOURCES TO GET US
READY FOR THE NEXT PANDEMIC.
IT'S AN EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
QUESTIONS THAT YOU ASK AND I
WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT- WHILE WE
DO- PLAN AHEAD FOR PANDEMICS I
THINK WHAT THIS PANDEMIC HAS
DEMONSTRATED TO US IS THAT.
PREPARING AND PREPARING FOR A
PANDEMIC REQUIRES MUCH MORE
THAN SIMPLY THINKING ABOUT YOUR
INFECTIOUS DISEASE FREE MARKET
ALSO. TO THE POINT HERE- MEANS
THAT WE MUST ALSO BE PREPARED
FOR. SONIC DISEASES FOR MENTAL
HEALTH CONCERNS AND FOR ALL OF
THE OTHER AREAS THAT THAT ANY
KIND OF RESPONSE WOULD REQUIRE
PARTICULARLY WHEN IT REQUIRES
AN ALL OF GOVERNMENT RESPONSE.
SO WHAT I WOULD NOTE HERE IS
THAT INDEED WE MUST CONTINUE TO
FUND OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE BUT LET'S ALSO
NOTE THAT THIS IS ALL OF
GOVERNMENT RESPONSE AND SO THAT
ACROSS ALL OF OUR DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES. THE
FRAMING THAT WE HAVE
INVESTMENTS THAT WE HAVE TO
ENSURE THAT PEOPLE CAN GET
CARE. UP RECEIVE SOCIAL
SERVICES THAT THEY NEED. OVER
TIME ARE ALSO PART OF THE
INVESTMENTS IN MAKING SURE THAT
WE WILL BE A STRONG STATE IN
THE FACE OF ANY FURTHER FIFTY
INFECTIOUS DISEASES THESE ARE
EXTREMELY DIFFICULT TIMES IN
THE DECISIONS THAT ARE BEING
MADE. ARE BY NO MEANS BEING
MADE LIGHTLY- BUT WE ALSO NEED
TO RECOGNIZE THAT IN THESE
TIMES OF ECONOMIC CHALLENGES
ALL OF US TOGETHER LET'S THINK
ABOUT HOW ARE DEPARTMENTS IN A
RESOURCES- TOGETHER- CREATE A
RESPONSE FOR THE CURRENT.
ENVIRONMENT AND FUTURE
ENVIRONMENT THAT CAN CAN GREAT
RESILIENCE IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
I AM DR RANDALL I HOPE WHAT
YOU'RE HEARING IS. A REAL
WILLINGNESS FROM THE
LEGISLATURE TO WANT TO SUPPORT
TO YOUR DEPARTMENT THAT- WE
REALLY LOOK TOWARDS YOU WHEN
THE GUIDANCE THAT YOU'VE HELPED
TO PROVIDE AND- AND TO BELIEVE
IN YOU. AND SO WANTS TO MAKE
SURE THAT YOU HAVE THE
NECESSARY RESOURCES TO. DO THE
HARD JOB THAT YOU HAVE SO.
PLEASE LET US KNOW HOW WE CAN
BEST BE HELPFUL I THINK THAT'S
WHAT I'M REALLY TRYING TO
CONVEY WITH MY QUESTION- TO
MAKE SURE THAT YOU HAVE THE
TOOLS NECESSARY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE IT. MY NEXT
QUESTION THOUGH IS TOWARDS TOBY
EWING AND YOU HAD BROUGHT UP
MENTAL HEALTH AND- I'M GONNA.
MAKE A METAPHOR AND APOLOGIES
FOR IT IN ADVANCE BUT IF. KOBE
NINETEEN IS AN EARTHQUAKE THEN
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE
ABUSE SO THIS THE NOMINEE THAT
ARE COMING FROM THAT. AND I
THINK WE HAVE TO BE REALLY
COGNIZANT OF THAT. AND SO GIVEN
THAT WE KNOW THAT THIS IS
COMING THIS TERRIFYING REALITY
AND THE UNPRECEDENTED LIMITS ON
OUR STATE'S ABILITY TO HELP.
GIVE US TO HELP US COUNTIES IN
ENSURING THAT THEY CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE GOOD ACCESS TO SERVICES.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BE HERE TODAY TO JOIN YOU- I
THINK THERE'S A NUMBER OF
THINGS THAT THE STATE SHOULD
THINK ABOUT. FIRST IS AS YOU
SAID THAT COUNTIES ARE FACING
ENORMOUS. ENORMOUS CHALLENGES
RELATED TO BOTH FISCAL ISSUES.
OPERATING REALITIES AND THEN
GROWING MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS.
RECOGNIZING THAT NEW FINANCING
IS REALLY NOT AN OPTION AND
THAT WE ARE IN A PERIOD OF
CUTS. IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO
THINK ABOUT SOME OF THE FISCAL
INCENTIVES THAT THE STATE IS
CREATED FOR COUNTIES. RIGHT NOW
ALL THEIR FISCAL INCENTIVES ARE
FOCUSED ON SPENDING DOLLARS
QUICKLY AND WE SHOULD THINK
ABOUT STEPPING BACK FROM THAT A
BIT. IN CREATING AN ENVIRONMENT
WHERE WE CAN SLOW DOWN SPENDING.
RELATED TO THAT ARE
OPPORTUNITIES TO CREATE GREATER
FLEXIBILITY. IN TERMS OF MANY
OF THE PROGRAMS THAT THE
COMMISSION IMPLANTS ARE LOCAL
ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS WE'RE
WORKING WITH COUNTIES TO FIND
PLANS THAT WERE DEVELOPED IN
SOME CASES TWO YEARS AGO IN
SOME CASES SIX MONTHS AGO. FOR
EXAMPLE THE MEDICAL STUDENT
SERVICES ACT NONE OF THOSE
PLANS WERE DEVELOPED HE AND THE
CURRENT CODE ENVIRONMENT.
WHETHER THAT'S AROUND HOW WE
OPERATE. OR THE ECONOMIC
ENVIRONMENT THAT WE'RE IN. ANY
OPPORTUNITY TO SUPPORT THE
ABILITY OF STATE AGENCIES TO
GRANT SOME FLEXIBILITY TO
COUNTIES TO RETHINK PRIORITIES
RECOGNIZING THAT WE HAVE TO DO
MORE WITH LESS WOULD BE
IMPORTANT. I WOULD ALSO ADD
THAT THE INNOVATION COMPONENT
OF THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
ACT GIVES US SOME OPPORTUNITIES.
DURING THIS ENVIRONMENT- SOME
OF THE STAKEHOLDERS ARE ASKING
FOR SET ASIDE OF INNOVATION AND
THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ACT.
AND ALTHOUGH THE COMMISSION IS
NOT ENGAGED ON THIS EXPLICITLY.
IT THE EDUCATION COMPONENT IS
REALLY DESIGNED TO SUPPORT THE
ABILITY OF COUNTIES TO THINK
DIFFERENTLY ABOUT MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES NOW MORE THAN EVER
THAT'S IMPORTANT. WE REALLY
HAVE TO STEP BACK AND THINK
ABOUT HOW WE DO THINGS HOW WE
MIGHT BE ABLE TO LOWER COSTS
IMPROVE OUTCOMES. AND FOCUS
MORE ON OUTCOMES. I WANT TO
MENTION. PROBABLY THE MOST
CONCERNING ISSUE FOR THE
COMMISSION AT THE MOMENT.
AROUND SUICIDE PREVENTION. I
WANT TO THANK THIS SUBCOMMITTEE
FOR ITS LEADERSHIP OVER THE
LAST FEW YEARS. TO REALLY BRING
THAT. BRING GREATER ATTENTION
ON SUICIDE PREVENTION AND THIS
OTHER NUMBER RAMOS FOR HIS
LEGISLATION- THAT WAS UP
YESTERDAY THANKS- CHAIR WOULD
OF THE ASSEMBLY HEALTH
COMMITTEE. UP FOR HIS COMMENTS
ON THAT BILL. THE COMMISSION IS
VERY CONCERNED THAT SUICIDE
PREVENTION. NEEDS ARE MORE
EVER BEEN BEFORE. ALTHOUGH I'M
WE DON'T KNOW EXACTLY WHAT'S
HAPPENING ALL OF THE RESEARCH
SUGGESTS THAT THESE KINDS OF
CRISES REALLY DRIVE INCREASES.
AND SO SUBTLE RISK AND BEHAVIOR
AND WE NEED TO THINK ABOUT WAYS
THAT THE STATE CAN SUPPORTER OF
LOCAL PARTNERS IN SUICIDE
PREVENTION IN THE COUNTIES IN
OUR SCHOOLS. IN THE PRIVATE
SECTOR AND- I'D LOVE TO TALK
ABOUT OTHER WAYS THAT THE STATE
CAN SUPPORTERS HAVE PREVENTION
I WOULD SAY THOSE THOSE BIG
ISSUES RETHINKING INCENTIVES.
ADDING SOME FLEXIBLE WHERE WE
CAN. FORTIFYING INNOVATION AND
REALLY DOUBLING DOWN ON
PREVENTION OPPORTUNITIES IN
GENERAL THE SUICIDE PREVENTION
SPECIFICALLY. THANK YOU MISTER
YOU IN MY NEXT QUESTION IS FOR
MICHELLE BOSS AND- I TO. PIGGY
BACK AN ECHO OFF OF WHAT YOU'VE
HEARD FROM MANY PEOPLE HERE ON
THE PANEL. BUT THE MAY REVISE
INCLUDES A VAST NUMBER OF
REDUCTIONS TO NEARLY EVERY
COMMUNITY BASED LONG TERM
SERVICE AND SUPPORT FOR OUR
SENIORS. INCLUDING SEA BASS M.
S. S. P. I. HSS CARE GIVER
RESOURCE CENTERS MEDI CAL
OPTIONAL BENEFITS THAT ARE SO
CRITICAL FOR OUR SENIORS AS
WELL AS NON EMERGENCY MEDICAL
TRANSPORTATION. ALL OF THESE
HELP OUR SENIORS TO LIVE IN THE
COMMUNITY AND TO STAY OUT OF
NURSING HOMES. WE ALL KNOW THAT
NURSING HOMES ARE MORE
EXPENSIVE NOT TO MENTION
PROVIDE A LOWER QUALITY OF LIFE
IN GENERAL FOR OUR FRAIL
SENIORS. THIS WOULD BE TRUE AT
ANY TIME AND- IS ESPECIALLY
TRUE IN THIS PANDEMIC THAT
PRIMARILY AFFECTS SENIORS CAN
YOU PLEASE EXPLAIN YOUR
THINKING. AND HOW THE
ADMINISTRATION JUSTIFIES GOING
SO FAR IN THIS DIRECTION. WE
RECOGNIZE THE IMPACT MANY OF
THESE PROPOSALS HAVE ON OUR
OLDER CALIFORNIANS. AND WE ARE
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AND STAKEHOLDERS ON
THINKING THROUGH OPPORTUNITIES
TO IDENTIFY ALTERNATIVE CARE
MODELS AND WAYS TO KIND OF
DECOMPRESS ARE CONGREGATE CARE
FACILITIES. WE YOU KNOW WE
THINK ABOUT BECAUSE IT IS A WAY
TO ACCELERATE OUR CREATIVE
THINKING ON ALL OTHER WAYS TO
DO BUSINESS AND TO ADDRESS
THESE AT THE NEEDS OF OUR OUR
OUR SENIOR CENTER AND I HAVE AN
OLDER CALIFORNIANS. WE STAND
COMMITTED THESE ARE PROPOSALS
AT THIS TIME AND WE STAND
COMMITTED TO WORK WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AND STAKEHOLDERS ON
ALTERNATIVE AND IDEAS. WITH
THAT I WILL CONCLUDE MY
QUESTIONS BUT I'LL MAKE A BRIEF
COMMENT ALMOST AS IF I WAS THE
FIRST PERSON MAKING UP PUBLIC
COMMENT KIND OF HOW I WANTED TO
FRAME AT. AND I DID WANT TO
TALK ABOUT THREE PROGRAMS THREE
SPECIFIC LINE ITEMS THAT- STUCK
OUT TO ME AND- THE FIRST IS
WHEN I SPOKE WITH DOCTOR ANGEL
I JUST THINK WE AS THE
LEGISLATURE NEED TO LEAN INTO
OUR- DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH AND FIGURE OUT HOW TO
HELP THEM WITH WORKFORCE IN
INFRASTRUCTURE THROUGH THIS
CRISIS. AND ALLOW US TO BE
BETTER PREPARED FOR THE NEXT
PANDEMIC. BUT I WANT TO TALK
ABOUT SONG BROWN IF I COULD
JUST BECAUSE- IT'S DIFFICULT
WHEN YOU'VE MADE COMMITMENTS TO
INSTITUTIONS THAT MAKE
DECISIONS BASED ON THOSE
COMMITMENTS. AND SONG BROWN IS
A PROGRAM THAT WE PROMISED IN
PERPETUITY AND ALLOWED
HOSPITALS TO MAKE CHOICES
REGARDING RESIDENTS. NOW I
WOULD COUNTER AND SAY THAT I DO
THINK THERE NEEDS TO BE BETTER
ACCOUNTABILITY WITH THE PROGRAM
TO ENSURE THAT WE ARE
INCREASING SLOTS AND
UNDERSERVED AREAS. I WOULD
ENCOURAGE THIS ADMINISTRATION
TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO CONTINUE
THAT SOURCE OF FUNDING AS I
CAN'T BELIEVE WE'RE GOING TO
NEED LESS DOCTORS AFTER THIS
PANDEMIC THAN BEFORE US GOING
INTO IT. NOW THE FINAL ONE IF I
CAN AND WOULD ASK THIS
COMMITTEE JUST TO INDULGE ME
I'VE- NEVER TALKED BOUT THEM
IN PUBLIC AND JUST WANT TO TELL
A LITTLE BIT OF A STORY BECAUSE
I THINK SOMETIMES IT.
PERSONALIZES AND REMINDS US
THAT THEY'RE NOT JUST NUMBERS.
HOUSE OF THREE NINE ZACHARIAS
WERE MY GRANDPARENTS WHO CAME
TO THIS COUNTRY WITHOUT
DOCUMENTS SPENT THEIR WHOLE
LIVES WORKING IN THE FIELD. AND
THEY WOULD NEVER IMAGINE THAT
THEIR SON AND GRANDSON WOULD
END UP BEING ON THE LEGISLATURE
AND HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
STAND UP AN ADVOCATE FOR
SOMETHING THAT MATTERS TO THE-
BUT I GOT ACTIVATED TO FIGHT
FOR HEALTH FOR A WHOLE. BECAUSE
I BELIEVE THAT HEALTHCARE IS A
HUMAN RIGHT FOR EVERY SINGLE
PERSON. AND I ESPECIALLY FIGHT
FOR THE SENIORS BECAUSE I
REMEMBER MY GRANDPARENTS AND
THE SACRIFICE THAT THEY MADE
FOR US. AND WOULD ASK THIS
GOVERNOR TO TAKE A SECOND LOOK
AND ANOTHER LOOK AND ANOTHER
LOOK. TO TRY TO MEET HIS
COMMITMENT AT THE START OF THE
SENIORS BECAUSE THROUGH THIS
PANDEMIC I THINK WE SHOULD
STAND UP FOR ALL OF OUR SENIORS.
WITH THAT JUST WANTED TO TELL
YOU THAT I'M HONORED. THAT THEY
MADE THE DECISION TO COME TO
THIS GREAT COUNTRY IN THE STATE.
BECAUSE IT HERE THAT WE SETTLED
WE SETTLED IN CALIFORNIA. AND
WE SET ROOTS HERE WE DECIDED TO
MAKE THIS PLACE BETTER THIS
STATE THAT ARE. MY DAD
GRADUATED FROM PERSON PRETTY
GOOD SCHOOLS ON THE FIRST
LATINO MEDICAL DOCTOR I WOULD
SAY IT'S A GOOD INVESTMENT THAT
THE STATE MADE. I WOULD ASK
THAT THEY CONTINUE TO MAKE
INVESTMENTS INTO OUR SENIORS
INTO OUR CALIFORNIANS INTO
PEOPLE WHO HAVE MADE OUR STATE
BETTER. WITH THAT I WILL CO
CLOSE HER QUESTIONS AND MOVE US
ON TO PUBLIC COMMENT BUT WANTED
TO ADD MY TWO CENTS IN TO TELL
YOU WHY I COME TO THIS FIGHT
AND WHETHER OR NOT WE'RE ABLE
TO ACCOMPLISH THIS THIS YEAR
WILL BE A CHOICE FOR ALL OF US.
BUT I WANT YOU TO KNOW THAT I'M
COMING BACK TO THIS FIGHT AND I
WILL KEEP UP THIS FIGHT UNTIL
WE'RE ABLE TO ACHIEVE HEALTH
FOR ALL BECAUSE I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO TELL PEOPLE WHERE
YOU STAND AND WHAT YOU STAND
FOR. WITH THAT I WILL PASS IT
ON TO DOCTOR WOULD. HAVE
APOLOGIZED ACTUALLY I MADE A
LOT OF COMMENTS BUT IT DIDN'T
ASK A COUPLE QUESTIONS THAT I
MEANT TO SO- THANK YOU THANK
YOU FOR YOUR INDULGENCE-
INDULGENCE MISTER CHAIR. COUPLE
OF QUESTIONS SPECIFIC QUESTIONS
THAT COME TO MIND- IT APPEARS
IN THIS BUDGET THAT POLICY
DECISIONS THAT WERE MADE LAST
YEAR BILLS THAT WERE PASSED.
WITH PROGRAMS THAT WERE TO BE
IMPLEMENTED GOING FORWARD.
THEY'RE NOT BEING PAUSE THERE
BEING ELIMINATED. AND THAT
TROUBLES ME WE COULD HIT THE
PAUSE BUTTON ON SOME OF THESE
THINGS WE ARE WHAT WE AGREED AS
A LEGISLATURE TO IMPLEMENT THEM
THE GOVERNOR SIGNED THEM INTO
LAW. AND NOW THEY'RE BEING
ELIMINATED WHY ARE WE NOT
HITTING THE PAUSE BUTTON ON
THESE PROGRAMS UNTIL THERE IS
ADDITIONAL FUNDING AVAILABLE
RATHER THAN ELIMINATING THESE
PROGRAM SO I LEFT IS OR SOMEONE
WHO WANTS TO ANSWER THAT
QUESTION I THINK OF FOR ALL
GIVE YOU SOME EXAMPLES- THE-
ELIGIBILITY FOR- LOW INCOME
SENIORS BETWEEN A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY. THREE YEARS NOT MEANT
THAT A 138% OF THE FEDERAL
POVERTY LEVEL IN CALIFORNIA
THAT'S THESE ARE THESE ARE
SENIOR CENTER REALLY HURTING.
THAT IT THAT'S ELIMINATED- THE
THING WE CALL FLIPPERS THE
PEOPLE THAT SHE TURNED SIXTY
FIVE AND THEY'RE ON MEDICARE
THERE THERE MEDI CAL. AND
THEY'RE SUDDENLY THEIR INCOME
IS TOO HIGH AND THEY FLIP OFF
AND THEN THEY HAVE TO SPEND
DOWN AND RE APPLY AND GO
THROUGH THE CYCLE OVER AND OVER
AND OVER AGAIN- THAT. WAS MEANT
TO HELP WITH ELIGIBILITY AND
MAINTAIN- EFFICIENCIES AND
THAT. IS BEING. ELIMINATED SO.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND DâN WHY
WERE USING THE BUDGET TO
ELIMINATE POLICY RATHER THAN
JUST BECAUSE IT UNTIL WE
ACTUALLY HAVE. A REALIZATION OR
YOU KNOW OF ADDITIONAL FUNDING
SO COULD SOMEONE EXPLAIN WHY
YOU'RE ELIMINATING. THE WORK
THAT WE DID IN THE LEGISLATURE
RATHER THAN UP HITTING THE
PAUSE BUTTON. EDITOR. TOTALLY
KNOWLEDGE THE THIS SENTIMENT-
AND YOU KNOW I DON'T THINK THAT
WE- DISAGREE WITH WITH THE
SENTIMENT AND A LOT OF WAYS. I
THINK YOU'LL SEE THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET YOU KNOW
DIDN'T PROPOSED A PULL BACK A
LOT OF THESE THINGS IN JANUARY-
WE- DIDN'T WANT TO PULL BACK
OUR OWN PROPOSALS FROM FROM
JANUARY AND THE GOVERNOR SIGNED
A LOT OF THESE BILLS WITH THE-
INTENTION OF IMPLEMENTING THEM
OR DEPARTMENTS OF WORKED. TO
BEGIN IMPLEMENTING THOSE THINGS
AND THE WE HAVE A STRUCTURAL
BUDGET PROBLEM THAT'S BEEN
CREATED BY THIS BUDGET WE ARE
RELYING ON FEDERAL DOLLARS TO
HOPEFULLY- SAVE AND IT KIND OF.
STAVE OFF SOME OF THESE
REDUCTIONS IN THE BUDGET YEAR.
BUT EVEN. THE FEDERAL MONEY
THAT WE'RE ASKING FOR DOES NOT
ADDRESS THE STRUCTURAL ISSUE
THAT'S BEEN CREATED BY- THE
ECONOMIC PROBLEMS THAT WE'RE
FACING. SO WITH THE CERTAINLY
THE BUDGET PROCESS IS A PLACE
FOR US TO WORK THESE ISSUES OUT
AND TO GO SHEET THESE THINGS-
AND YOU KNOW WE WANT TO HAVE
THOSE CONVERSATIONS WITH YOU
ALL BUT- CERTAINLY THE
SITUATION THAT WE'RE AND IS.
EXTREMELY DIFFICULT ONE AND WE
EXPECT THAT IT WILL BE FOR
SEVERAL YEARS TO COME. I
APPRECIATE APPRECIATE THAT BUT
I THE FUNDAMENTAL QUESTION I
ASKED IS WHY DIDN'T YOU JUST
HIT PAUSE. ON SOME OF THESE ON
POLICY THAT THAT WE HAVE ALL
AGREED UPON RATHER THAN JUST
FLAT OUT ELIMINATING THINGS WE
GIVE YOU ANOTHER EXAMPLE OKAY-
THE MEDI CAL STATE RECOVERY
SOMETHING WE'VE YOU KNOW
SOMETHING THIS LEGISLATURE
TRIED TO CHANGE FOR YEARS AND-
THAT'S BEEN THAT'S BEEN
ELIMINATED SO- THE GENERAL FUND
SAVINGS ABOUT SIXTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS. NOW IT THE FEDERAL
MEDICARE REIMBURSEMENT RATE
THIS BASICALLY MEANS THAT THAT
IF YOU ARE A FAMILY MEMBER-
THAT THAT SOMEONE MIGHT NOT
APPLY FOR MEDI CAL BECAUSE THEY
ARE AFRAID OF LOSING. THEIR
HOME. AND SO WHAT HAPPENS IS
THAT WE GO BACK AND- IF SOMEONE
HAS A HOME THAT WE CAN GO BACK
AND TAKE ME TAKE THAT TAKE
MONEY FROM THAT FROM THAT
PROPERTY REPAY THEIR MEDI CAL
BENEFITS OVER THE YEARS. NOW
SOME OF THAT FIT YOU KNOW SOME
OF THAT DEPENDING ON WHAT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
REIMBURSEMENT LEVEL IS OF SOME
OF ITS 50% SO WE DO THAT
RECOVER THAT HALF OF THAT GOES
BACK TO THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
SOME IS NINETY PERCENT. SO IS
IN ESSENCE WERE BECOMING A
COLLECTION AGENCY FOR THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THERE. AND
WHAT WE'RE DOING IS
POTENTIALLY- PUTTING MORE
PEOPLE INTO A HOMELESS
SITUATION SO I YOU KNOW I
STRUGGLE WITH SOME OF THESE.
BUT I GO BACK TO THE
FUNDAMENTAL QUESTION WHY IS
THIS BUDGET. I'M DOING POLICY
DECISIONS RATHER THAN HITTING
THE PAUSE BUTTON UNTIL WE
ACTUALLY HAVE. AN OPPORTUNITY
TO DO THAT AND NOT THAT'S-
ESPECIALLY YOU KNOW PREVENTION.
FOR DIABETES. WORK WERE KILLING
A PROGRAM THAT JUST HASN'T EVEN
REALLY GOTTEN STARTED YET YEAH
WE'RE GONNA SPEND MILLIONS
MAYBE EVEN BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
ON THE TREATMENT OF DIABETES
BUT WE WON'T PREVENT. WE WON'T
WORK ON A PROGRAM TO PREVENT
IT. DO YOU. THAT THIS IS BEYOND
PENNY WISE AND POUND FOOLISH- I
DON'T I TYPE I JUST
FUNDAMENTALLY DON'T UNDERSTAND.
THE SOME OF THESE DECISIONS
THAT THAT ARE LEARNED WITH
LEADING TO SMALL LINE ITEMS TO
HELP BALANCE OUR BUDGET. ARE
GONNA HAVE HORRIBLE
RAMIFICATIONS AND POTENTIALLY
COSTS A LOT MORE MONEY IN THE
FUTURE. DOES ANYBODY MAKE IT
WHO WHO HOW DO THESE DECISIONS
GET MADE. IN OURS IS- THERE'S A
POT OF MONEY WILL TAKE THAT
WILL TAKE THAT. TO THINK ABOUT
WHAT THE POTENTIAL
RAMIFICATIONS AND THAT'S WHY I
SAID EARLY ON IT FEELS LIKE WE
TOOK THE OLD BUDGET PLANT THE
OLD RECESSION PLAN OFF THE
SHELF DUSTED OFF. AND IGNORED
ALL THE THINGS THAT WE LEARNED-
FROM THAT FROM BAD DECISIONS
AND WE'RE JUST GOING TO. DO IT
AGAIN. AND SO. SO FUNDAMENTALLY
WHY ARE WE TAKING. ANSWERED YOU
CAN ANSWER THE QUESTION OR IS
IT JUST JUST THE DIRECTOR TING
WE'RE JUST GONNA UNDUE POLICY
THAT THE LEGISLATURE PUT IN
PLACE INSTEAD OF PUTTING ON
HOLD. I THINK THAT WE'RE MORE
THAN HAPPY TO TAKE YOUR
SUGGESTIONS FROM THE
LEGISLATURE ON ON ON OTHER
IDEAS FOR HELPING NEIGHBORHOODS
EIGHT EIGHT WHILE. OF THE JAZZ
BUT NOW I THINK WHAT DOCTOR
WHAT IS SAYING IS APPROPRIATE
AND IF I CAN STEP IN HERE-
MISTER DORSEY AS WELL AS THE-
AUTHOR OF THE PIECE OF
LEGISLATION TO WHICH HE'S
REFERENCING. I TOO AM MOVED TO
FIGURE OUT IF THERE ARE OPTIONS
THAT WE CAN CONSIDER SIMPLY FOR
PAUSING RATHER THAN ELIMINATE.
BECAUSE THAT WILL ALLOW US IF
BUDGET TIMES CHANGE TO.
CONSIDER OUR OPTIONS BUT SIMPLY
TO ONE WIND WHAT WAS A FAIR
AMOUNT OF WORK FOR US IN THE
LEGISLATURE TO- GAIN THE
SUPPORT TEND MOMENTUM- WOULD BE
SOMETHING THAT I THINK WE WOULD
WANTS TO ENGAGE THIS
ADMINISTRATION WITH. BACK TO
YOU DOCTOR WHAT IF YOU HAD ANY
QUESTIONS THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR YOU SUMMED IT UP AND
YOU'RE GONNA. HAVE BROUGHT MY-
BLOOD PRESSURE DOWN THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER ON THIS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR
ALLOWING US TO CONTINUE TO ASK
QUESTIONS ON THESE TOPICS FROM
TOBY EWING PRODUCT THE AREA OF
SUICIDE SOME CERTAINLY AND THE
BILL THAT MANY OF US SOME ALL
AROUND THIS DIRE SOME ARE CO
AUTHORS ON A THANK YOU FOR THAT
BUT IT BRINGS UP THE- SUICIDE
RATES THAT ARE RISING- NOT ONLY
NOW AND COVERT NINETEEN. ERA
BUT HAVE BEEN ON ON. SOME YEARS
BACK- FOR MENTAL HEALTH
OVERSIGHT AND ACCOUNTABILITY
COMMISSION TO DRAFT A STATEWIDE
SUICIDE PREVENTION STRATEGIC
PLAN AND WITHIN THAT PLAN I'M
CURIOUS TO KNOW THAT IF SOME OF
THAT WORK STARTS TO IDENTIFY
SOME OF THE AREAS THAT WE'RE IN
NOW BECAUSE WE HAD A- YOU KNOW
COMMENTS ON THE POPULATION OF
OUR ELDERS AND IN THE STATE BUT
WE ALSO KNOW THAT ARE YOU ARE
IMPACTED SEVERELY BY THIS
BUDGET THAT ARE THAT IS HERE.
AND WE HAD TESTIMONY- YESTERDAY
AND HOW OF YOUNG PEOPLE A YOUNG
PERSON WHO- NEED AT THESE
RESOURCES THAT WERE THERE SO I
THINK FOR TOBY IF HE COULD COME
BACK UP AND SEE IF THERE IS
SOME. AREAS THAT MAYBE WE COULD
HEAR ABOUT THE MAYBE WE CAN
START TO ADVOCATE FOR- AROUND
THE SITUATION THAT'S HERE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CONTINUES TO
BE. A NUMBER OF ONE COMPONENT I
BELIEVE WE CANNOT TALK ABOUT
RESTARTING AN ECONOMY UNLESS WE
START TO TALK ABOUT THE BALANCE
OF MENTAL HEALTH ALONG WITH IT.
THOSE THAT ARE GOING THROUGH
ECONOMIC HARDSHIPS THOSE THAT
ARE LIVING ALONE THAT ARE
ISOLATED THOSE ARE ELDERLY
THAT. THAT FEEL THE NEED
RESOURCES TO CONTINUE TO COPE.
THERE'S A COMPONENTS TO MOVING
THE ECONOMY FORWARD AND WITHIN
THE BUDGET TAKING OUT CERTAIN
THINGS THAT TAKES AWAY THAT
BALANCE. STARTS TO REALLY
QUESTION HOW SUCCESSFUL WE WILL
BE MOVING FORWARD IF ALL OF OUR
EFFORTS ARE ON JUST ONE
ELIMINATING STUFF FROM THE
BUDGET. AND MOVE FORWARD WITH
THE ECONOMY OPENING UP AND NOT
TAKING INTO PERSPECTIVE. MENTAL
HEALTH COMPONENT THAT MANY
PEOPLE YOU'D NEED IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA SORT OF TOBY
COULD ELABORATE A LITTLE BIT
MORE ON THAT PLAN. THANK YOU
THE SENATE RAMA SPEECH AT THE
OPPORTUNITY AGAIN- YET THAT THE
COMMISSION HAS BEEN DOING A
NUMBER OF THINGS THAT WE THINK
ARE ACTUALLY VERY SIGNIFICANT.
FOR THE CURRENT MOMENT IN TIME
WE ARE PARTNERING YEAH OUT OF
I'LL TALK ABOUT SAYS HAVE
PREVENTION BUT I WANT TO
MENTION A COUPLE OF OTHER
THINGS JUST TO GIVE YOU SOME
IDEAS. WE'VE BEEN PARTNERING
WITH DH CS WITH COUNTIES WITH
THE PART IN STATE HOSPITALS
WITH OTHER DEPARTMENTS TO
REALLY UNDERSTAND THAT MENTAL
HEALTH PROGRAMS THAT WE HAVE IN
PLACE TODAY. WHERE THEY'RE
WORKING WHERE THEY'RE NOT. INTO
SUPPORTER COUNTY AND COMMUNITY
PARTNERS TO REALLY RETHINK SOME
OF THOSE PROGRAMS AND TO
REDESIGN THEM TO THAT WE CAN BE
MORE EFFECTIVE. IN TERMS OF HOW
WE'RE USING LIMITED PUBLIC
RESOURCE THAT'S- THE BIGGEST
OPPORTUNITY IS AROUND FULL
SERVICE PARTNERSHIPS FOR
EXAMPLE. WERE WORKING WITH A
NUMBER OF COUNTIES TO REALLY
UNDERSTAND DATA ON FULL SERVICE
PARTNERSHIPS. AND JOINT WHAT
WE'RE WELL IN WHAT DOESN'T. IN
TERMS OF SO PREVENTION I WOULD
SAY THE EXACT SAME STRATEGIES
ARE NECESSARY IN CALIFORNIA HAS
PUT IN PLACE REQUIREMENTS FOR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO DEVELOP
SAYS HAVE PREVENTION PLANTS
MANY COUNTIES HAS. HAVE SUICIDE
PREVENTION PLANTS THE STATE NOW
HAS A SUICIDE PREVENTION PLAN
WE CAN DO MORE IN TERMS OF
COORDINATING THOSE EFFORTS.
ACROSS STATE COUNTY IN SCHOOL
DISTRICT BOUNDARIES THERE'S
TREMENDOUS OPPORTUNITIES TO
WORK WITH OUR COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS PRIVATE SECTOR
ORGANIZATIONS. BUSINESSES AND
OTHERS. REALLY FOR BROAD LEVEL
PREVENTION BUT SUICIDE
PREVENTION IN PARTICULAR. EVEN
EXAMPLE. RECENTLY THE STATE PUT
IN PLACE A REQUIREMENT THAT
EVERY SCHOOL DISTRICT HAVE A
PLAN. AS A PLAN BUT WE HAVE NOT
YET SAT DOWN WITH OUR SCHOOLS
TO UNDERSTAND HOW THAT'S
WORKING. EVERY SCHOOL IT'S
REQUIRED TO DO SO SITE
ASSESSMENTS BUT WE DON'T HAVE
CONSISTENT STANDARDS THAT ARE
HELPING OUR SCHOOLS UNDERSTAND
WHICH ASSESSMENT ARE WORKING
MOST EFFECTIVELY. WE'RE NOT
GATHERING THE DATA TO
UNDERSTAND HOW THE HOW THOSE
ASSESSMENTS ARE RESULTING IN
THE RIGHT KINDS OF HANDOUTS.
THOSE ARE CLASSIC OPPORTUNITIES
TO REALLY UNDERSTAND HOW TO
MEET THE NEEDS OF CHILDREN AND
HOW TO DO PREVENTION BETTER. ON
A PARALLEL TRACK. A NUMBER OF
COUNTIES AND SCHOOL PARTNERS.
USING SOME OF THE TRIAGE FUNDS
THAT THE STATE IS MADE
AVAILABLE. AND MORE RECENTLY WE
HOPE TO KNOW HOW STUDENT
SERVICES ACT DOLLARS THAT ARE
AVAILABLE. ARE BEGINNING TO
ENGAGE YOUNG PEOPLE TO DEVELOP
MENTAL HEALTH STRATEGIES
THROUGH THEIR SCHOOLS. WE DON'T
KNOW WHAT THAT'S GOING TO LOOK
LIKE AS WE BEGIN TO REOPEN
SCHOOLS AND HAVE HAD A- NEED TO
UNDERSTAND. HOW ISOLATION
ORDERS WILL IMPACT THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES. BUT WE SEE
TREMENDOUS POTENTIAL TO
ACTUALLY ENGAGE YOUNG PEOPLE TO
HELP EACH OTHER. WITH USED
THESE MODELS FOR DECADES BUT
WE'VE NOT FULLY DEPLOYED IN
CALIFORNIA AND WAYS THAT CAN
IMPROVE OUTCOMES AT LOWER COSTS
FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS. REMEMBER
ALMOST YOU RECALL THAT WE SPENT
SOME TIME WITH YOUR STAFF UP
IN- HUMBOLDT COUNTY TALKING TO
NATIVE AMERICAN GIVE. AND THAT
WE TALK WITH THE COUNTY AND
SOME OF THE TRIBES THAT THEIR
ABOUT. PEOPLE TOGETHER TO TALK
ABOUT HOW WE COULD BETTER
TAILOR OUR STRATEGIES. OR IN.
THAT WAS A TREMENDOUS UP. TO IS
PRETTY. WITH OF TO OPERATE. TO
GET. ARC TRIBAL ON TRIBAL
THROUGHOUT REGION. IN AT
SIMILAR STRATEGY FOR ALL ADULTS
WELL OTHER THAT ARE HIGH. THOSE
ARE THE KINDS OF. THAT WE NEED
BE PURSUED. THAT OUR LOW COST
IT WILL HELP OF ABOUT HOW TO
MAKE. IT BETTER BANG FOR THE
DOLLAR THAT WAS HAVE AVAIL.
THANK YOU YOU I. FOR THAT
RESPOND THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
AND THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HIGHLIGHT MUCH
NEEDED RESOURCES IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. NOT ONLY IN
TIMES OF CRISIS BUT WE START TO
TALK ABOUT BUDGET. IN TRYING
TO- FOR TAKE AWAY AND MONEY
FROM VITAL RESOURCES YOU'RE
HEARING IT FIRST HAND. THAT
MENTAL HEALTH SUICIDE
PREVENTION IS SOMETHING THAT
CONTINUES NEEDS TO BE INTACT.
NOT BEING TAKEN AWAY FROM
WITHIN THE BUDGET. BECAUSE
THERE STILL IS A LOT OF-
HEALING A LOT OF AREAS THAT
NEED TO MOVE FORWARD- MISTER
EVENING WAS- UP IN HUMBLE- UP
IN AND THE TRAVEL COMMUNITY.
WHERE THIS RESOURCES IN THIS-
COMMUNICATION COORDINATION
CONTINUES TO BE NEEDED
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND THANK YOU
ISSUING FOR BRINGING UP THE
THAT THE TRIBAL COMMUNITIES.
BECAUSE WHEN WE START TO TALK
ABOUT THESE BUDGET CUTS
ALGER'S- CHILD. SUPPORT
SERVICES ALL THE AREAS
SOMETIMES WE FORGET THAT THE
NATIVE AMERICAN POPULATION IS
INCLUDED HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. IN ALL THESE AREAS
THAT HAVE HIGHER STATISTICS
THAN ANY OTHER GROUP. IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. SO WE
START TO PULL AWAY RESOURCES.
THEN WERE REALLY STARTING TO.
EXACERBATE THOSE RATIOS WITHIN
DISPARITIES HERE IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AND I THANK YOU
FOR THAT I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY MISTER.
THANK YOU AND- SEE NO FURTHER
QUESTIONS FROMCOMMITTEE
MEMBERS I DO THINK THAT- GREAT
WAY FOR US TO AND OUR- COMMENTS
AND- WOULD JUST- NOTE THAT WE
WILL BE KEEPING A CLOSE EYE ON.
MANY OF THOSE DISPARITIES AND-
WILL WANTS TO ENSURE THAT MEANT
ALL OF OUR COMMUNITIES HAVE
ACCESS TO SERVICES. AS WE CAN.
NOW AS WE TURN THE PUBLIC
COMMENT I WANT TO FIRST START
BY THANKING THE PANELISTS WHO
WERE PARTICIPATING IN TODAY'S
HEARING IN THE WITNESS VIDEO
ROOM. WE COVERED QUITE A BIT IN
A SHORT PERIOD OF TIME TRYING
TO MAKE THE BEST USE OF. OUR
TIME AS WE NAVIGATE THIS MAY
REVISIONS. NOW I'D LIKE TO
START WITH MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WHO ARE HERE FOR COMMENT
IN ROOM FOUR THIRTY SEVEN OF
THE CAPITAL AND IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE MOVE FORWARD TOWARDS THE
MICROPHONE. YOU CONTINUING TO
STAY SOCIALLY DISTANCE FROM
OTHERS WHO ARE IN THE ROOM. NOW
AS I MENTIONED AT THE OUTSET OF
THE HEARING- WE WILL BE USING A
MODERATED TELEPHONE SERVICE FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT ALL ALL OUR WORK
CALL IN NUMBER TODAY. IS ONE
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO.
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN AND THE
SAYS CODE IS TWO EIGHT THREE
FOUR THREE EIGHT. AGAIN PLEASE
ONLY TYPE IN ONE ZERO ONCE. RE
ENTERING THIS WILL TAKE YOU OUT
OF CUES SO PLEASE AVOID DOING
THAT. AT SOME POINT THE
OPERATOR WILL CALL ON YOU AND
ASK FOR YOUR NAME FIRST. SO
PLEASE BE PREPARED TO SPEAK
WITH THE OPERATOR IS THIS WILL
FACILITATE WINNER TAPPED TO
SPEAK TO THE COMMITTEE. NOW I
WOULD LIKE TO ASK THAT ALL OF
YOU TRIED TO KEEP YOUR COMMENTS
BRIEF IN ORDER FOR US TO HAVE
TIME TO HEAR FROM EVERYONE. WHO
WOULD LIKE TO COMMENT. AND
FINALLY I JUST WANTS TO
ACKNOWLEDGE. THAT AS YOU SEE
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE
LEAVING THE HEARING ROOM.
PLEASE KNOW THAT THEY ARE
CONTINUING TO LISTEN TO PUBLIC
COMMENT FROM THEIR OFFICES OR
FROM ELSEWHERE. SO WITH THAT I
WOULD LIKE TO START WITH PUBLIC
COMMENT FROM HERE IN THE ROOM.
SHARE MEMBERS HELLO AGAIN PARA
BEHALF OF OUR MORE THAN FIFTY
THOUSAND POSITION MEMBERS. THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED MAYBE BY
CRIPPLES THE HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM'S ABILITY TO PROVIDE
CARE AND LESSEN THE ABILITY OF
THE STATE TO SAFELY RE OPEN AND
KEEP OPENED THE ECONOMY. SEE ME
OUTSIDE THE LEGISLATURE TAKE
THE FOLLOWING ACTIONS FOR THE
FINAL JUNE FIFTEENTH BUDGET. WE
ARE SEVEN THE GOVERNOR'S MAY
REVISE ATTEMPTS TO AGAIN RE
LITIGATE THE ISSUE OF WHETHER
PROPERTY SIX CAN BE USED TO
SUPPLANT GENERAL FUND
EXPENDITURES. LEGISLATURE HAS
TWICE BEFORE SETTLE THISISSUE
AND SHOULD ONCE AGAIN REJECT
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL. THE
UNLAWFUL USE OF ONE POINT TWO
BILLION AND PROP FIFTY SIX
TOBACCO TAX REVENUE COULD
REMOVE NEARLY THREE BILLION AND
FEDERAL AND STATE FUNDING TO
ENSURE MEDICAL PATIENTS HAVE
ACCESS TO DOCTORS. DENTISTS AND
CLINICS IN THEIR DISTRICT. WE
ASK YOU AGAIN TO REJECT THE MAY
REVISED PROPOSAL TO REPURPOSE
PROP FIFTY SIX. WE ALSO ASKED
THE LEGISLATURE REJECT THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISED PROPOSAL
TO SIDELINE OVER TWO HUNDRED
SEVENTY MEDI CAL PROVIDERS. BY
ELIMINATING THE PROP FIFTY SIX
LOAN REPAYMENT PROGRAM. PART OF
THE PROPERTY SIX RE PURPOSING-
IS THE ELIMINATION OF YEARS TWO
THROUGH FIVE OF THE WILDLY
SUCCESSFUL LOAN REPAYMENT
PROGRAM. WHICH PLACES DOCTORS
AND DENTISTS DIRECTLY
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. THERE ARE CURRENTLY OVER
ONE THOUSAND APPLICANTS WAITING
TO HEAR WHO RECEIVED THE AWARDS
BUT THAT ANNOUNCEMENT WAS NEVER
MADE LEAVING AT LEAST TWO
HUNDRED SEVENTY PROVIDERS.
READY TO SERVE MEDI CAL
PATIENTS ON THE SIDELINE. TO
SUPPORT THE INCREASING MEDI CAL
PATIENT CASELOAD THE
LEGISLATURE MUST REJECT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BUDGET
SOLUTION. AND MOVE FORWARD WITH
THE OVER TURNED SEVENTY YEAR TO
AUTHORITIES. AS MANY OF YOU
SEEN IN YOUR DISTRICT THROUGH
PRESS EVENTS AND NEWS ARTICLES
RELATED TO THE FIRST YEAR AWARD
EASE. THE PROGRAM IS VITAL TO
PROVIDING CARE CLOSE TO HOME.
DOCTOR ARAMBULA FRESNO COUNTY
HAD SEVENTEEN PHYSICIAN A
DENTIST ORTIZ. THE MEMBER RAMOS
HAMMER AND YOU KNOW COUNTY HAD
ALMOST THIRTY ORTIZ.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RUBIO LA COUNTY
SO FORTY EIGHT PHYSICIANS AND
DENTISTS DEPLOYED.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER CONTRA
COSTA SACRAMENTO IT'S ONE OF
COUNTIES COMBINED SON NINETEEN
PHYSICIANS AND DENTISTS. AND IN
RURAL COUNTIES WERE EVERY
SINGLE PROVIDER COUNTS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WOULD YOU HAD SIX
PROVIDERS DEPLOYED AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MATHIS BEAT PROVIDERS.
YOU MAY ALSO PROPOSES THE
LEGISLATURE REQUIRED NONPROFIT
AND FOR PROFIT INSURERS AND
HEALTH PLANS. UTILIZED PLANT
MEDICAL SERVICES MONEY TO
MAINTAIN ADEQUATE PROVIDER
NETWORKS. SEEM I GOT A LITTLE
CREATIVE AND CAME UP WITH SOME
SOLUTIONS. THE CALL THE
NINETEEN RECESSION IS
THREATENING TO CRIPPLE
CALIFORNIA'S HEALTH CARE
INFRASTRUCTURE. IF I WAS
ALLOWED TO OCCUR HEALTH PLANS
AND INSURERS WILL BE UNABLE TO
MEET THEIR STATUTORY
REQUIREMENT. TO MAINTAIN
ADEQUATE PHYSICIAN NETWORKS AND
MEET THE DEMAND FOR MEDICALLY
NECESSARY CARE. THE FIRST
QUARTER FINANCIAL STATEMENTS OF
PUBLICLY TRADED HEALTH
INSURERS. NOTED THAT THE COVERT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS NOT
HAMPER THEIR PROFITABILITY AND
THE UTILIZATION OF MEDICAL
SERVICES HAS SIGNIFICANTLY
DECREASED. CREATING A FINANCIAL
WINDFALL. THAT NGUYEN FALL
CONSISTS OF RESOURCES THAT WERE
PLANNED TO BE SPENT BY THE
INSURERS ON MEDICAL SERVICES.
AND MUST BE REQUIRED TO BE
REDIRECTED FROM SHAREHOLDER
PROFITS AND INSTEAD MAINTAIN
THE STATE'S PROVIDER NETWORKS.
HEALTH INSURERS HAVE LARGELY
FEEL TO VOLUNTARILY ACT. TO
PROTECT THE NETWORKS THAT
CONSUMERS. EMPLOYERS IN THE
STATE THROUGH MEDI CAL CONTINUE
TO PAY MONTHLY PREMIUMS FOR IN
ORDER TO ACCESS THAT CARE.
THEREFORE ACTION MUST BE TAKEN
BY THE LEGISLATURE TO ENSURE
SHAREHOLDER PROFITS ARE NOT
INCREASED AT THE EXPENSE OF
PATIENTS SEEKING CARE. I
HOUSEMAN FORSMAN MECHANISMS
THAT I RECOMMEND- TO ENSURE THE
RESOURCES ARE DEPLOYED
APPROPRIATELY. ALMOST DONE
THANK YOU- OPTIONS ARE TO
CREATE A REQUIREMENT THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED
HEALTHCARE AND THE DEPARTMENT
OF INSURANCE CONSIDER HEALTH
PLANS OR FOR INSURERS FINANCIAL
SUPPORT. OF ITS PROVIDER
NETWORKS BETWEEN MARCH ONE
TWENTY TWENTY AND JULY ONE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE IN THEIR
REVIEW OF THE PLANTS- INSURERS
ANNUAL HEALTH- ANNUAL RATE
INCREASES. TO THE EXTENT THAT A
PLAN A RICHER CANNOT ADEQUATELY
DEMONSTRATE. HOW ITS RATES
SUPPORTED ITS PROVIDER NETWORK
DURING THAT TIME. THE
DEPARTMENT SHALL NOT APPROVE
THESE RATES AND DEEMED THEM AND
REASONABLE. ADDING A
REQUIREMENT THAT RISK BRING
ORGANIZATION CERTIFIED THEIR
CONTRACTING HEALTH PLANS. HOW
THE A PASSED CAPITATION
PAYMENTS DIRECTLY THROUGH THE
PROVIDERS. DURING THAT SAME
TIME PERIOD. AND LASTLY IT
SHOULD BE REQUIRED- I'M SORRY
COMMERCIAL HEALTH PLANS AND
INSURERS THAT PARTICIPATE IN
MEDI CAL SHOULD PROVIDE
EVIDENCE THE PROVIDER SUPPORT
AS A CONDITION OF CONTINUED
PARTICIPATION IN MEDI CAL
MANAGED CARE. TO THE EXTENT
THAT A PLANT CANNOT DEMONSTRATE
THIS PROVIDER SUPPORT DURING
THAT SAME TIME PERIOD. THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES WILL TO CLEAR THEM
INELIGIBLE TO REMAIN UNDER
CONTRACT AND THEY'LL BE BARRED
FROM FUTURE PROCUREMENTS FOR
FIVE YEARS. IN CLOSING. THIS
LEGISLATURE HAS WORKED
TIRELESSLY TO ENSURE MEANINGFUL
ACCESS TO QUALITY HEALTHCARE
FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS. AND THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISE THREATENS
TO READ THOSE EFFORTS AND
RESCINDED PROMISED ME TO VOTERS
WITH THE PASSAGE OF PROP FIFTY
SIX. AT THIS MOMENT ACCESS TO
HEALTHCARE IS CENTRAL TO
CALIFORNIA'S ABILITY TO RE OPEN
AND MAINTAIN AN OPEN ECONOMY.
THE MAY REVISE FEELS RECOGNIZE
THE NECESSITY TO PRIORITIES
HEALTHCARE IN ORDER TO MEET
THIS MOMENT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. SEEING NO FURTHER PUBLIC
COMMENT IN THE ROOM I WILL NOW
ASK THE OPERATOR IF YOU HAVE
OUR FIRST CALLER. YES PUT THOSE
WHO HAVE NOT ALREADY CUED UP
THE ONE ZERO COMMAND. FOR OUR
FIRST QUESTIONER OR A COMMON
LINE FORTY BY THE OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. FIND FORTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE STATE YOUR
NAME AND YOUR AFFILIATION. THE
PICTURE NUMBER MODEL COLEMAN
WITH ACT OF. WE HAVE THE
COMMITTEE FOR HOLDING THIS
HEARING TODAY AFFECTED FOR THEM
AT THE- OF ADVOCATE FOR
HEALTHCARE CONSUMER AND MANY OF
LAST RECESSION THE STATE OF
OVERCOME. FOR THIS RECESSION
BUT ACT RESULT FROM THE HELP
CRISIS WE WERE PARTICULARLY
DISMAY BY THE PROBE AND
SERVICES WELL THE WITH OTHER
PROPOSALS AT THE BEACH VERY
TIME INVESTMENT COMMUNITY. NEED
HAVE TO STAY AND SERVE AND
THRIVE THE BUDGET THAT
HEALTHCARE COME. TO HELP
BENNETT FROM OUR GOAL AND WILL
LIKELY GO BACKPACK TO CARE
CONSIDER. I WOULD REALLY HELP
BENEFITS WE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
THE CHIU BECAUSE IF WE DON'T
GET FEDERAL DOLLARS PUT. AS IT
RELATES TO OPTION MEDI CAL
BETTER AND ALSO CUT TO PROVIDE
WE OPT THINK WE NEED TO. IN
RIGHT NOW HI THEY THE MOST IN
THE MIDDLE THAT HELPED. WE ARE
PARTICULAR SHOCK DUMPING AT THE
CO THAT IN IS ACROSS BOARD WE
IT FROM MANY MEMBERS TODAY
WHETHER THE CUT SIX OR WHETHER
BECOME OR WHAT OF THE PROGRAM'S
SERVICE LIKE I TOOK THAT. WITH.
HE BACK AND OTHER. THE PROGRAM
WE SHOULDN'T BE ELIMINATING-
WHAT WE FIX LAST YEAR ROUND
FLIPPER THE HOW WE FIXED INCOME
COUNTING FOR SENIORS WHO AT
TIMES LOST ACCESS TO MEDICAL-
WE SHOULDN'T BE. BRINGING BACK
ASSET RECOVERY IF BIG RECOVERY-
TO DISCOURAGE SINGERS FROM
ENROLLING IN THAT ACCOUNT AND
WE MUST ALSO CONTINUE TO WORK
ON THE PROPOSAL TO EXPAND
UNDOCUMENTED- PULLED OVER THE
COP ONE DOCUMENT IN YOUR
VEHICLE THAT NINETEEN PRINTER
MAKE IT. AGAIN AS PRIDE MONTH
BETTER THAN WE URGE LEGISLATORS
TO EXPECT A BRIGHT WHITE AND
NOT LET THE PROGRAM BEEN
PROPOSALS. BMI MANDATED FOR
WITHDRAWN BY THE GOVERNOR WE
IMPLORE YOU TO START A HARD
LINE HERE IN CALIFORNIA SURE
THAT EVERY SENIOR IN OUR STATE.
HAS ACTIVE THE MEDI CAL AND WE
MUST FIND DIFFERENT PATH
FORWARD MORE ON COVERAGE THE
BUDGET ALSO. FUNDING THAT WITH
THE READY ALLOCATED TO HELP
CALIFORNIANS BY COVERAGE COVER
CALIFORNIA MONEY COMMITTED AS
PART OF THAT DEAL WITH
LEGISLATORS WITH ONLY A QUARTER
OF THE INVESTMENT TRULY NEEDED
TO HELP MIDDLE INCOME
CALIFORNIANS PURCHASE COVERAGE
BUT INSTEAD OF DOING MORE TO
HELP CALIFORNIANS AT A TIME. UP
AND DOWN THE INCOME INCOME
SCALE THE MONEY WAS ESSENTIALLY
HIJACK ONE PART OF THE OTHER
CUTS. THAT I MENTIONED BACK TO
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE WILL BE
DIFFICULT DECISION TO MAKE IN
THE BUDGET CYCLE BUT WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT THE
LEGISLATURE AND GOVERNOR WORK
OUT A BUDGET. THAT DOESN'T
DRAIN THE VERY PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES COMMUNITIES WILL
DEPEND ON AND HEALTH CARE
PRICES THE LAST PLACE WE SHOULD
BE TALKING OF COVERAGE BENEFIT
AN ACT THAT CALIFORNIA THE
THIRD MORE. OUR STEERS BURKE
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE LATER AND THEN.
MINISTRY THE CROP THE BUDGET
THAT REFLECT. EXPRESSED BY THE
LEGISLATURE TODAY. FIVE A NOT
WORK OUT. WHAT UNDERSECRETARY.
THANK SIR OPERATOR DO YOU OUR
NEXT. YES LINED POINT YOUR IS
OPEN PLEASE STAY YOUR NAME AND
YOUR- THE MORE THIS IS MITCH
MATHEWS WITH THE PROJECTS UNDER
MANAGING BOTH MULTIPURPOSE
SENIOR SERVICE PROGRAMS AND
CAREGIVER RESOURCES IN TAMPA
NATO MODERATE IN SANTA CRUZ
COUNTY. THREE WE REALLY
STRONGLY ADVOCATE THE- THE
REJECTION OF THE CUTS FOR THE
CARE GIVER RESOURCE CENTERS AT
THE CARE GIVERS THE FAMILY
CAREGIVERS ARE THE BACKBONE OF
CARING FOR PEOPLE THAT ARE
UNABLE TO CARE FOR HIMSELF TO
SPECIFICALLY. PEOPLE WITHOUT
CLIMBERS OTHER FOCUS OF
NEUROCOGNITIVE DISEASES AND
IMAGES. PEOPLE ARE COMPLETELY
RELY ON THEIR- CARE GIVERS TO
SUPPORT THEM WE CAN'T RESOURCE
CENTER PROVIDES A WEALTH OF
SUPPORT. ISN'T A LOT OF THEM TO
KEEP THEIR LOVED ONES APPLE BUT
THE CLOTHES BEING AND FACILITY
WHERE THERE LIKELY TO THE
TERRORISTS MUCH MORE RAPIDLY
THE- OUR PRIMERS PROJECTIONS
LOW WHO ARE EXPECTED IN THE
NEXT. FIVE YEARS. GETTING BY
WORK THE TWENTY COURSE. RIGHT
NOW WITH PEOPLE AT HOME IT
SAVING THE STATE BILL IN THE
DOLLARS IN THAT TIME. IN ORDER
TO KEEP THEM AT HOLD AND
SUPPORT THE CARE. THE CARRIER
WILL THE TYPES OF. FOR LIKE HIS.
VISIBLE AND MAY HEALTH. THEY
ARE GIVING UP THEIR OWN WORK
TIME THEIR RETIREMENT IN
POTENTIAL HEALTHCARE BENEFITS
AS WELL THE HELP. OF THE CARE
GIVERS IS IMPERATIVE TO KEEP
THE SPOKE HOLE IN THE CARE
GIVER RESOURCE CENTER THE ALLOW
THE POSSIBILITY BUT PROVIDING.
COUNSELING SUPPORT GROUPS
RESPITE LEGAL SERVICES AND MORE
WE URGE YOU STRONGLY TO
THOUGHT. OF YOUR GUMS ARE TO
REJECT THE- CUTS TO THE
CHARACTER RESOURCE CENTER IS A
THANK YOU SO MUCH DOCTOR AROUND
A LOT FOR YOUR SUPPORT THE
EMPHASIS PEAK. AND IT'S ENOUGH
PROGRAM WE'RE TRULY GRATEFUL
HERE THAT LOOKS TAKE CARE OF
THE ELDERLY AND OUR REGION ARE
DOING GREAT WERE AND DIFFICULT
THANK. YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU
SIR AN OP IF CAN GO THE NAY IN
LINE AND KEEPER. TAB WE HAVE A-
SIXTY PEOPLE ON THE CALL
WAITING TO COMMENT. LINE FORTY
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MAKE INTO BURKE ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA HEALTH
PLUS ADVOCATES REPRESENTING
THIRTEEN HUNDRED COMMUNITY
HEALTH CENTERS THIRTY SEVEN
MILLION PATIENTS IN CALIFORNIA
WE CERTAINLY- ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT THE IMPACT IT'S REVISED
BUDGET WILL HAPPEN TO HELP THE
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES. AND
THE HEALTH CENTERS THAT THEIR
FAMILY SUBMITTED FULLER COMMENT
FROM THE COMMITTEE LAST NIGHT
SO I JUST WANT TO TOUCH ON A
FEW OF THE ITEMS HERE FIRST
WHILE WE SEE TELEHEALTH AND
TELEPHONIC CARE AT THE AREA OF
GREATEST OPPORTUNITY IN OUR ON
GOING COLD BUT NINETEEN
RESPONSE THE AREA. OF GREATEST
CONCERN BEEN RATE IS THE
PHARMACY TRANSITION WE FIRMLY
BELIEVE NOW IS NOT THE TIME FOR
THE ADMINISTRATION TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH THE MEDI CAL
PHARMACY TRANSITION WE HAVE
BEEN WORKING WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR MORE THAN A
YEAR HIGHLIGHTING THE FINANCIAL
IMPACT THIS WILL HAVE ON THEM
AND THE PATIENT THAT THEY
SERVE. A TRANSITION THAT ALLOWS
THE STATE. ALL THE THINGS
HEALTH CARE IF TO RELY UNDER
THE CURRENT SYSTEM COUPLED WITH
A NO MANY ASIAN PREVIOUSLY
PROPOSED SUPPLEMENTAL PICK.
BOTH REPORTED ONE. A LOT IT
MEANS NEW MAY RIGHT MAY REFER
PROPOSAL IT'S ONLY A TO THE
CODE NINETY RESPONSE BUT WILL
FURTHER DE THE BRING A DISH ON
FINANCE PARTS ON HEALTH CENTER
WE WERE THAT THE TRANSITION BE
DELAYED AND THAT BUT MICHAEL ON
TELEHEALTH ONE ITEM IS AFTER AT
THE TO NINE RIGHT AND NOT BE
CONSIDERED IN THE CON BUT THE
BUDGET IS A- CURRENT PUBLIC AND
TELEPHONE FLEXIBILITY AND
PAYMENT IN ORDER FOR HEALTH
CENTERS REMAIN VIABLE THEY
MIGHT BE ABLE TO CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE NEEDED CARE TO THEIR
PATIENTS VIRTUALLY. WE URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO COMMIT TO MAKING
VIRTUAL VISIT ALLOWABLE UNDER
MEDI CAL NOT DURING DECEMBER
AGENCY BUT WELL INTO THE FUTURE
ON WORK FOR I THANK THE CHAIR
WE ARE EXTREMELY DISAPPOINTED
TO SEE THAT THE MAY REVISED TO
PULL BACK ON THE COMMITMENT TO
MAINTAINING SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENT AND HEALTH CARE WORK
FORCE FUNDING INCLUDING
INVESTMENT. IN FONG. FIFTY SIX
LONER PAY. THE PANDEMIC HAS
BEEN CUT THE GUY HEALTH WORK
FOR GAP THE CUBAN HIGHLY PERSON
TIME. WE URGE THE LETTER. AND
THE ADMIN TO. HEALTH WORK
PROGRAM. IT'S DOING IT'S BETTER
RESOURCES ARE RECEIVED. MAY
REVISE ALSO PROPOSES TO
ELIMINATE FQHC AND OUR EIGHT
FAR. DENTAL AND OTHERS STATES
AND REQUIRE HEALTH CENTER TO
BUILD THOSE SERVICES INTO THEIR
PP AT THREE. PRIDE BUT IT'S
PROPOSAL IN TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND THE FULL IMPACT OUR
PHARMACY DIRECTORS HAVE BEEN
QUICK TO NOTE HOW COMPLEX
PHARMACY SERVICES ARE AND FOR
THAT REASON HOW DIFFICULT IT
MIGHT BE TO ACCURATELY AT A
RATE FOR GUARANTEED AT THAT
RATE WILL KEEP UP WITH THE
DYNAMIC COUGH THE PHARMACY
SERVICES. ADDITIONALLY THE
PROPOSAL MUST BE ANALYZED IN
COMBINATION WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION THANK YOU MOVE
FORWARD WITH MEDI CAL ARE ACT
WITHOUT PROVIDING SUPPLEMENTAL
PAYMENTS TO HEALTH CENTERS WERE
GREATLY CONCERNED. HEALTH
CENTERS WILL HAVE NO OPTION BUT
TO LIMIT THEIR PHARMACY
SERVICES PROPOSAL MOVED FORWARD.
MY MEDI CAL AND ROMAN WE ARE
URGING IMMEDIATE IN THE BUDGET
CYCLE TO ADVANCE XCELERATED
INVOLVEMENT DUE TO THE
INCREASED WE WILL BE ACTED OUT
IMPLEMENT AND FINALLY I JUST
WANT TO SPEAK TO THE ROLE OF
THE LIFELINE GRANT PROGRAM AND
THE- WORLD. AND COULD BE PUT IN
TODAY TO SUPPORT ENTERED WE
BELIEVE THE LIFELINE GRANT
PROGRAM WHICH IS AN ESTABLISHED
PROGRAM ADMINISTERED THROUGH
THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH
FACILITIES FINANCING AUTHORITY.
COULD BE PART OF THE SOLUTION.
AGAIN MOBILE AND GUARANTEEING
DOROTHY. AND STAFFERS TO URBAN
TO PUT CARE THEIR PEACE. AND
THE WE ARE BOOK THAT THE LEAD
TO. TAKE ACTION IN THE BUDGET
MICHAEL. HEALTH CENTER TAX THE
ROOM FUNDS IN THE PROGRAM. AND
AT THE EARLIEST OPPORTUNITY
WITH WE GOT THE PROGRAM AND I
THINK THE COMMITTEE COMMITTEE
FOR YOUR INCREDIBLE ATTENTION
TO THESE- MATTER AND-
APPRECIATE WORKING WITH YOU
LOOKING FORWARD. THANK YOU
MA'AM OPERATOR CAN YOU GO TO
THE NEXT ONE. LINE SIXTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE STATE
YOUR NAME AND YOUR AFFILIATION.
THE MORNING THIS IS CHEN CORY
WITH WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY. WE RECOGNIZE THE
DIFFICULT ECONOMIC TIMES THAT
WE'RE IN RIGHT NOW BUT WE'RE
ESPECIALLY CONCERNED WITH THE
MEDICARE ELIGIBILITY CUTS THAT
TARGET SENIORS AND PERSONS WITH
DISABILITIES- MY COLLEAGUES IN
THE WAY IT'S GOING TO DISCUSS
THE BENEFIT CUTS IN HER
TESTIMONY. WE OPPOSE
REINSTATING THE SENIOR PENALTY
WHICH THE CHAIR CHAMPION. UNDER
THE PROPOSAL SENIORS AND
PERSONS WITH DISABILITIES WILL
REMAIN SUBJECT TO A LOWER
INCOME ELIGIBILITY AND ABOUT A
HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE DOLLARS LESS
A MONTH AND ANY OTHER ADULTS ON
THAT ACCOUNT. THESE INDIVIDUALS
WILL BE STUCK PAYING OVER SEVEN
HUNDRED DOLLARS A MONTH TO
ACCESS NEEDED HEALTHCARE
SERVICES THROUGHOUT THE
PANDEMIC. AND THOSE WHO TURN
SIXTY FIVE DURING THIS CRISIS
WILL LOSE ACCESS TO PRE
MEDICARE OUT AS SOON AS THE
TEMPORARY FREEZE ON TERMINATION
AND- WE OPPOSE THE RELATED
REINSTATEMENT AND OUTDATED
PROGRAM RULE THAT KICK SENIORS
AND PERSONS WITH DISABILITIES.
OFFERING MEDI CAL BASED ON WHO
IS PAYING THE MEDICARE PART B.
PREMIUM EVEN WHEN THEIR INCOME
HASN'T CHANGED. WE SHOULD BE
AIMING TO STABILIZE HEALTHCARE
COVERAGE RIGHT NOW NOT ADDING
ELIGIBILITY RULES THAT CREATE
CHAOS. WE ALSO OPPOSE EXPANDING
ITS STATE RECOVERY WHICH ACTS
AS AN ENROLLMENT BARRIER FOR
PEOPLE FIFTY FIVE AN OLDER FOR
FEAR THAT THE STATE WILL PUT A
LIEN ON THEIR FAMILY HOME WHEN
THEY DIE. CURRENTLY ONCE AND
MEDICARE BENEFICIARY DIED THE
STATE ONLY RECOVERED FOR
SKILLED NURSING FACILITY CARE
PAID BY MEDI CAL BUT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS PROPOSING TO
GO BEYOND THAT FEDERAL
REQUIREMENTS. JERRY COVER FOR
ALL MEDI CAL SERVICES EIGHT
INCLUDING THE PAYMENT MADE
EVERY MONTH TO MEDI CAL PLANNED
EVEN WHEN NO HEALTH SERVICES
ARGUES. THE LAST THING WE NEED
DURING A PANDEMIC IS A PUNITIVE
RULED THAT WILL COST OLDER
CALIFORNIANS TO GO WITHOUT CARE
AND A RULE WHICH EXACERBATES
THE RACIAL DISPARITIES IN INTER
GENERATIONAL WEALTH
TRANSFERRED. BY TART TARGETING
THE MODEST HOMES AND LOW INCOME
PEOPLE. FINALLY WE WERE
DISAPPOINTED THAT THE NAY
REVISION DID NOT INCLUDE
MEDICAID EXPANSION TO INCOME
ELIGIBLE UNDOCUMENTED ADULTS.
GROUPS ARE MORE AT RISK TO THE
HEALTHCARE ECONOMIC EFFORT THAT
CODE NINETEEN IN THE SENIOR
TOUR UNDOCUMENTED AND OFTEN
WORKING LOW WAGE HIGH RISK
JOBS. AND THEN INCLUDING WE
WOULD ALSO REQUESTED THE
ADMINISTRATION ADAM FORM OF
XCELERATED INVOLVEMENT IN MEDI
CAL TO PLAN FOR THE LARGE
NUMBERS OF PEOPLE WHO WHO DO
NEED TO ENROLL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MA'AM. OPERATOR CAN
WE GO TO THE NEXT COLOR. YES
LINE SEVENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME AND YOUR
AFFILIATION. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS JOHN LINGER ON
BEHALF OF THE NATIONAL
COALITION PERSISTED AND RE HAVE
TECHNOLOGY WE ARE THE PROVIDERS
OF COMPLEX THREE AFTER
KNOWLEDGE E. WHICH IS
INDIVIDUALLY CUSTOMIZED
WHEELCHAIRS AND DOUBT THAT THE
CLINTON IT FOR SEVERELY
DISABLED CHILDREN AND ADULTS-
THE PANDEMIC HAD BEEN
PARTICULARLY CHALLENGING FOR
OUR PATIENTS. WITHOUT TIMELY
ACT THE CARE CAN END UP IN THE
HOSPITAL MANY TIMES WITH
RESPIRATORY ISSUES THAT COULD
REQUIRE VENTILATOR- THAT WE
TESTIFIED BEFORE A PROVIDERS OF
CONTINUE TO SUFFER UNDER THE
809710% RATE CUTS FROM THE
GREAT RECESSION. IN ADDITION TO
THE PROPOSED MANAGED CARE CUT
IN THE MAY REVISED IN THAT THAT
ALSO RECENTLY APPROVED THE
STATE PLAN AMENDMENT THAT WILL
CUT OUR RATE EVEN FURTHER AND
CLUB BACK PAYMENTS ALREADY MADE
TO OUR PROVIDERS DATING ALL THE
WAY BACK TO JANUARY ONE TWENTY
NINETEEN. WE RECOGNIZE THE
DIFFICULT DECISIONS THAT MUST
BE MADE GIVEN THE STATE BUDGET
REALITY BUT WITHOUT ANY RELIEF
OUR MEMBER COMPANIES SIMPLY
CANNOT SUSTAIN ALL THE CUTS
WILL BE FORCED MAKE DIFFICULT
DECISIONS WHICH COULD INCLUDE
REQUIRING ARE VULNERABLE
PATIENTS TO TRAVEL TO OUR BILL
WHICH WILL. INCREASE NON
EMERGENCY MEDICAL
TRANSPORTATION COSTS FOR THE
STATE CAN RESORT RESULT MORE
HOSPITALIZATION BUT THAT WE
WOULD STRONGLY ENCOURAGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER EITHER
RESTORING THE A. B. NINETY
SEVEN SEVEN THANK. YOU. RIGHT
DOT THAT THE GRAY CUT FOR A
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE YOU CAN
TO ALLOW FOR A TEA AND OF WHICH
HAD BEEN TEMPERED GRANT UNDER
THE ORDERS WITH THAT LOOK BILL
WOULD HELP MEMBERS MAINTAINING
CERTAIN LEVEL OF REGULAR IN ALL
SERVICE THAT THEY- GREATLY WE
NEED. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU SIR
OPERATOR CAN WE GO TO THE NEXT
CALLER. YES LINE EIGHTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE STATE
YOUR NAME AND- YOUR AFFILIATION.
HELLO MY NAME IS RENEE NASA AND
I'M HERE AS A DAUGHTER A
GRANDDAUGHTER AND A MEMBER OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
ADULT DAY SERVICES. I WANT TO
THANK YOU CHAIR ARAMBULA
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD FRAZIER
MATHIS RAMOS CAN RUBIO YOUR
WORDS MAKE ME CONFIDENT IN THE
FUTURE OF THE STATE. AS A YOUNG
PERSON I HAVE SPENT MY ENTIRE
CAREER WORKING IN SENIOR
SERVICES. AND I AM HERE TODAY
TO COMPEL YOU TO SAVE THE SEA
BASS AND THAT THAT THE PROGRAM.
THESE BENEFITS ARE REFERRED TO
AS OPTIONAL BENEFITS BUT I CAN
ASSURE YOU THAT THEY ARE IN NO
WAY OPTIONAL. IN FACT THE
GOVERNOR HIMSELF SAID THAT THEY
ARE ESSENTIAL THE GOVERNOR ON
APRIL FOURTH CALLED UPON US.
FEEDBACK CENTER TO HELP KEEP
OUR MOST VULNERABLE SENIORS
STATE DURING THIS CRISIS HE
PERSONALLY CALL. FIVE OF OUR
PARTICIPANTS PLEDGING TO KEEP
THEM SAFE. THIS PROPOSAL MAKES
NO SENSE IN THIS CONTEXT I
TRULY BELIEVE THIS PROPOSAL IS
AN OVERSIGHT I BELIEVE GOVERNOR
NEW SO MUST NOT BE AWARE THAT
HE SIGNED A BUDGET PROPOSAL
THAT ELIMINATED US AS THE
SERVICE THE HE CALLED A CENTRAL.
AND REASSURED BY THE OUR
SENIORS WE WOULD BE THERE FOR
THEM. WE SERVE THIRTY SEVEN
THOUSAND SENIORS IN THIS STATE
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES HOW
CAN WE EXPLAIN THE THREE
HUNDRED AND 60 DEGREES CHANGE.
WHO ADDED FEEDBACK TO THE
CHOPPING BLOCK ONLY A MONTH
AFTER WE WERE ASKED TO
TRANSFORM OUR SERVICE. TO MEET
THE NEEDS OF THESE SENIORS THAT
ARE SHELTERING IN PLACE. TWO
WEEKS AGO MY GRANDMOTHER PASSED
AWAY IN THE HOME HE WAS IN THE
LATE STAGES OF ALZHEIMER'S
DEMENTIA SHE UTILIZED ADULT DAY
HEALTH CARE ALSO KNOWN AS HE
BACKED. UP UNTIL THE LAST YEAR
OF HER LIFE SHE LEFT THIS WORLD
IN OUR HOME. IN HER COMMUNITY
PLEASE DO NOT SENTENCE ARE
FRAGILE POPULATION. THE
INSTITUTIONALIZATION AND DEATH
THERE IS NO REPLACEMENT FOR THE
SEA BASS BENEFIT. I THANK YOU
ALL FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU MA'AM OPERATOR CAN WE
GO TO THE NEXT COLOR. APPLYING
TENURE LINE IS OPEN. DOCTOR
ARAMBULA MEMBERS HER CHILD
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA WE
APPRECIATE THE EFFORTS THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS MADE TO
PROPOSE A HEALTH BUDGET FROM
MULTIPLE FUNDING SOURCES
PRIMARILY THE FEDERAL FUNDING
IN THE COPA PACKAGE- HOWEVER OF
THE S. THE- MEMBERS HAVE
ALREADY NOTED- THIS MORNING THE
CARD SURE THAT REMAIN IN THE
REVISION CO DEPRESSED INTERNET
MEDI CAL SERVICES THAT SERVE. A
PERSONS WITH DISABILITIES AND
THE ELDERLY MEN AND ONE OF THE
MOST SHORT SIGHTED ARE THE
PROPOSED CUTS TO SEE BASS AND
AM SSB PROGRAMS. THE VERY
PROGRAMS THAT ARE DESIGNED TO
KEEP INDIVIDUALS OUT COSTLY AND
WE KNOW DANGEROUS NURSING
FACILITIES RIGHT NOW NEARLY 50%
OF THE CO THE DEATHS IN
CALIFORNIA ARE TOO LATE TO-
NURSING FACILITIES. THEY HAD
THE OPPORTUNITY YESTERDAY THERE
ARE A LOT OF COMMENT ON THE
IMPACT OF- POTENTIAL CUTS IN
THIS AREA SO I WON'T GO INTO
THAT- BUT I DO WANT TO BE
CLEAR- THE BUT WE BELIEVE THE
C. B. S. PROGRAM CUTS ARE
ILLEGAL. AND WE KNOW THAT
BECAUSE- THESE CUTS ARE A
RETREAD FROM THE SINK CUTS THAT
WERE MADE BACK IN. TWO THOUSAND
NINE TWO THOUSAND TEN TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN. BUT DURING
THOSE YEARS R. C. AND OUR
COLLEAGUES JUST IN AGING THE
MAP HEALTH CLUB FOR. CHALLENGE
THEM IN COURT AND WHICH BUT-
CHARLIE TO FEDERAL COURT THE
PROPOSED ELIMINATION OF THE DAY
HELP- CARE PROGRAM WHICH IS NOW
THE- SEA BASS PROGRAM- IN IN
VARIOUS ORDERS THE COURT FOUND
THAT NOT WITHSTANDING BUDGET
PROBLEMS- THE STATE COULD NOT
ABDICATE ITS DUTY TO ENSURE
COMPLIANCE WITH THE ADA.
SECTION FIVE FOR EVEN THE-
COMPARE ABILITY AND REASONABLE
STANDARDS REQUIREMENTS UNDER
FEDERAL MEDICAID LAW- MOREOVER%
THESE CUTS WOULD VIOLATE THE
STATE'S OBLIGATION UNDER THE
OLMSTEAD DECISION REQUIRING
THAT INDIVIDUALS HAVE A RIGHT
TO RESIDE. IN THE LEAST
RESTRICTIVE ALTERNATIVES- IN OF
IMAGE AND THE USE THESE CASES
WERE ULTIMATELY SETTLED THAT
CREATED. AS PART OF THAT
SETTLEMENT TO SEE BASS FOR A
PROGRAM THAT WE PROVIDED THE
COMMITTEE- THIS MORNING OUR
WRITTEN COMMENTS- SUMMARIZING
THAT LITIGATION AND WHAT WE
THINK ARE THE- FLAWS- AND WE
THINK THESE PROPOSED CUTS HERE
TO SEE ABOUT SOME. AMBASSADORS
FOR THE- SUFFER FROM THE SAME
DEEP TAXES IN THE- PRIOR
LITIGATION SO THE STAKES ARE
TOO HIGH FOR THE MOST
VULNERABLE INDIVIDUALS WE'RE
TRYING TO KEEP OUT OF HARM'S
WAY- THE SIGNIFICANT INCREASES
AND HOSPITALIZATIONS AND LONG
TERM CARE COST. THIS WELL THOSE
IS THE EXPENSE OF LITIGATION.
CHALLENGES WITH. CERTAINLY OUT
WAY IN SAVINGS AND TO BE ON THE
WE WERE WANT TO GO UPTHE
FEDERAL. PART FOR MORE THAN
HALF OF THE FUNDS FOR THIS
PROGRAM. SO FOR THESE REASONS
WE STRONGLY OPPOSED TO THE BASS
MSP. LOS REDUCTION AND WE'RE
ALSO STRONGLY ACROSS TO THE
OTHER CUTS THAT SEEMED ONCE
AGAIN TARGETED AGAINST THE
ELDERLY PERSONS WITH
DISABILITIES- BILL IN THE
NATION ABOUT MEDI CAL. A IN THE
PROGRAM OUR A AND D. INCOME
LEVEL TO ONE HUNDRED AND THIRTY
COSTS EIGHT PERCENT- HALTING
THE ELIMINATION OF THE MEDICARE
PART B. DISREGARD WITHDRAWING
THE MEDI CAL EXPANSION DAHLE
BURKE- IMMIGRANTS THE
ELIMINATION OF OPTIONAL
BENEFITS AND- THE REINSTATEMENT
OF THE MEDICARE OUR STATE
RECOVERY IN THIS YEAR HEARD
YESTERDAY BUT- SSI ANCESTRY WE-
CHECKED. BENEFITS SO WE REQUEST
THAT YOU REJECTED TO THESE
REDUCTIONS AND PROTECT THOSE
WHO'VE BEEN TAKING THE BRUNT OF
THE. AND THAT MAKE ALREADY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR.
OPERATOR CAN WE GO TO THE NEXT
CALLER. YES NINE ELEVEN ZERO
OPEN. HI KAREN MEMBERS CAN'T BE
BURKE WITH THAT HEALTH OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA- I
WANTED THANK YOU DOCTOR
ARAMBULA FOR YOUR QUESTION
ABOUT FUNDING LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS AND BY ASKING THAT
QUESTION YOU'RE SORT OF MAKING
THE INVISIBLE VISIBLE IT'S
REALLY HARD TO BELIEVE THE WORK
DONE BY PUBLIC HEALTH. IN TIMES
LIKE THIS PANDEMIC WHO DO GET
SOME ATTENTION BUT MOSTLY
WORKED ON BY LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS KEEP PEOPLE FROM
GETTING SICK AND MEETING CARE
IN THE FIRST PLACE AND IT'S
REALLY HARD TO TELL THE STORY
OF THINGS THAT DON'T HAPPEN-
AND SO I'M REALLY GRATEFUL FOR
THE ATTENTION OF IT TODAY-
EVERY MEMBER OF THE COMMUNITY
BENEFIT FROM THAT WOULD BE
PREVENTION WORK DONE BY PUBLIC
HEALTH- WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
THE ABOUT THAT AND FOR CALLING
IT OUT. I AM WE SUBMITTED A
BUDGET PROPOSAL. TO IMPORTANT
WORK. AND WE WOULD FORWARD TO
WORKING. TAKING DIDN'T. GET
THANK YOU MA'AM OPERATOR CAN WE
GO TO THE NEXT. YES LINE ONE A
ONE YOUR OPEN. ONE ZERO ONE.
DURING A MEMBER CAN I REPRESENT
THE CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF EMERGENCY
CONNECTION. WE WANTED A QUICK
COMMENT RELATED TO THE NEW
REVISED. IN THE NINETEEN TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY BUDGET THEIR
WORD THAT ALLOCATION OF TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS INCLUDED THAT
WOULD PLAY YOU ACCOUNT CLERK
DRUG AND ALCOHOL COUNSELOR CAN
BURN THE PARTNER. BUT DIED OF
WORDS TALK CUT WILL PILOT THE
SHOW GREAT REGAL. WHEN HAVING A
THE DEPARTMENT TO HELP OUR
PATIENTS. I WOULD PROBABLY LOOK
AT THE X. ISSUES. THANK YOU ALL
OF THEM AGREED OPPORTUNITY ONE
CUP OF CONTENT TO NUMBER ARE IN
A QUITE GOOD. TO TALK TO THEM
GO THEY TEND TO GO. A DIRECTOR
UNDERLYING ADDICTION ISSUES. IT
PROGRAM HAS JUST BEEN COULD
BEGIN BY THE OF HEALTH CARE SIR.
THE APPLICATION HAD ALL BEEN
BETTER AT THE END OF MARCH IN
THE PARKING WOULD NOT CLICK THE
START TDAY IS A MATTER OF FACT
BUT OF COURSE THAT COVER
QUICKLY BY THE GOVERNMENT IN
THE BY. ON THAT ARE STILL WE'RE
ASKING THE ALLEGED TO REJECT
THAT CUTS ACROSS MILLION. TURN
ON THAT OUR DOLLARS THERE.
RICHARD CONSIDER FUNDING THOSE
FACILITIES THAT HAD THAT THEIR
APPLICATION ARE AT THE BALLOT
TO THE FUNDS COULD BE USED
TOWARDS THE BUDGET DEFICIT THAT
THE STATE IS FACING RIGHT NOW.
WE APPRECIATE YOUR TIME AND
CONSIDERATION ON THIS REQUEST
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR AND WE
WILL BE FOLLOWING UP- TOMMY WHO
WAS THE INSPIRATION BEHIND THAT
TASK IS STILL ON MY MIND AND
WILL BE NECESSARY DURING THIS
CRISIS. WITH THAT OPERATOR CAN
YOU GO TO THE NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. LINE ONE HUNDRED YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS DID
DID MJ DETACHED FROM SCA YOU
CALIFORNIA ON BEHALF OF OUR
SEVEN HUNDRED THOUSAND WORKING
MEMBERS AND THEIR FAMILIES.
THANK YOU DOCTOR ARAMBULA FOR
HAVING THIS HEARING AND FOR
ASKING THE SAME HARD QUESTIONS
THAT WE HAVE WE ALSO THANK YOU
FOR JOINING US IN THE FIGHT AS
YOU MENTIONED EARLIER. THAT MAY
REVISED PROPOSAL IS ESSENTIALLY
AN ALL CUT PROPOSAL WE ARE
DISAPPOINTED WITH THE
WITHDRAWAL OF THE HEALTH FOR
ALL SENIORS PROPOSAL AND A
THREE FORTY BE SUPPLEMENTAL
PAYMENT POOR PROPOSAL. WE
EXPAND SADDENED TO SEE
SIGNIFICANT CUT PROPOSED ON
MEDI CAL ELIGIBILITY BY NOT
IMPLEMENTING PAST POLICIES THAT
EXPANDED ELIGIBILITY AND ALL OF
THE PROPOSED CUTS ON OPTIONAL
BENEFITS THAT TOOK TEN YEARS TO
RESTORE. LASTLY WE ARE
DISAPPOINTED WITH THE
DIVESTMENT OF RESOURCES FROM
CLINIC COUNTY MEDICAL PROVIDERS
AT A TIME WHEN TWO MILLION MORE
PEOPLE WILL BE AUTOMATIC HOW BY
JULY TWENTY TWENTY. ALL OF THE
CUTS COMMITTEE HEARD YESTERDAY
ON SOCIAL SERVICES AND ALL OF
THE FACT THAT YOUR DAY.
HEALTHCARE AFFECTED PARK GEN
THE PEOPLE. FOR AND MORE PEOPLE.
WE ARE. MORE THAN ITS FAIR OF
OUR MOST VULNERABLE POP. AND IN
SO WE ARE SHE OUR RESPONSE. TO
THEM AND CREATE GREATER LONGER
TERM. AND DISPARITY. SB YEAH
YOU MEMBERS ARE FIGHTING ACROSS
THE COUNTRY FOR FEDERAL SUPPORT
OF FRONT MIGHT. BE OR STATE AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENT AT THE
LEGISLATURE MUST FILL OUT A
PATH FORWARD THAT IS BASED ON
EQUITY INCLUSION COMPASSION AND
JUSTICE WE ASK YOU TO NOT MAKE
THE SAME MISTAKES THAT THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR
DID TEN YEARS AGO DURING THE
GREAT RECESSION. WE ASK YOU TO
NOT BALANCE THE BUDGET ON THE
BACKS OF OUR FRONTLINE
ESSENTIAL WORKERS AND THE
WORKING POOR WE ASK YOU TO
CONSIDER A SOLUTION THAT IS NOT
JUST BASED ON GOVERNMENT ROLE
OF CUTTING CRITICAL HEALTH CARE
FOR THEM. AGAIN A SHORT TERM.
WE ASK YOU TO LOOK FOR.
ECONOMIC STRUCTURE THAT IS ONE
OF ACOSTA ALL LOVE OF INCOME
AND AT EASE. NOW IS THAT AND
THE BILL THEN YOU SOCIAL COM
THE DRY. EQUITY HEALTH OPERATE.
AND DIGNITY FOR ALL. BLACK
BROWN API OR WHY REGARDLESS OF
THE ZIP CODE OUR COUNTRY OF
BIRTH AND REGARDLESS OF
IMMIGRATION STATUS AND INCOME.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO FINDING REAL
SOLUTIONS WOULD YOU SOLUTION
AGAIN THAT DID NOT JUST COME AT
THE EXPENSE OF WALKING
CALIFORNIANS. THANK YOU AND
MORE PROVIDE YOU MORE WRITTEN
COMMENTS WITH MORE POLICY
DETAILS THE GESTION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MA'AM. OPERATOR NEXT
CALLER. FIVE ONE LOW FOR. YES
THANK YOU MY NAME IS MARTY A
MOTO I'M A FAMILY MEMBER OF MY
OLDER SISTER AT DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES AND PHYSICAL
DISABILITIES ALSO EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR AND FOUNDER CD CAN
CALIFORNIA DISABILITY-
COMMUNITY ACTION NETWORK I'M
ALSO THE MEMBER A MEMBER OF THE
MASTER PLAN FOR AGING
STAKEHOLDERS SUBCOMMITTEE THE
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES
PASSPORTS THE HOMESTEAD
ADVISORY COMMITTEE AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDER GROUPS JUST WANT TO
THANK ALL OF YOU FOR DOING THIS
THESE HEARINGS. AND ALLOWING
FOR EXTENSIVE PUBLIC COMMENTS
TO THE PHONE HOOKUP GENERALLY
DEPONENT THE BEST WORK REALLY
WELL AND APPRECIATE THE WORK IN
A BUDGET COMMITTEE STAFF IN
SETTING ALL OF THIS UP ALSO
WANT TO THANK THE OPERATOR FOR
HAND ONLY THE CALLS THOUGH I
DON'T QUITE UNDERSTAND THE
NUMBERING SYSTEM I. JUST WANT
TO SAY THAT WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
WITH THE CHAIR AND WOOD
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS WOULD FRAZIER
RUBIO BAPTISTS IN THE BROWN
MOST HAVE SAID ABOUT THE
PROPOSED CUTS TO HELP THE
SERVICE IS JUST ALSO WANT TO
SAY I'M WE APPRECIATE THE
FEELINGS OF THE MOTION
EXPRESSED BY DOCTOR. AND DOCTOR
WOULD WE. FEEL THOSE EMOTIONS
TO. WORK BY. AND WE HOPE IT
WILL MEAN DIFFERENT IN BUT-
FAMILIES AND PEOPLE'S LIVES
DEPEND ON THE- WE- THE WORK OF
THE GOV AND ADMIN. RESPONDING
TO COAL BED CRISIS THAT HAS
BEEN COMPASSIONATE HE IS A GOOD
MAN AND HE HAS DONE GOOD THINGS
FOR US BUT THE CUT THE HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES ARE NOT
GOOD. THIS IS AN ECONOMIC
CRISIS BUT AS MANY OF THE
MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE
APPOINTED OUT THIS IS MOST OF
ALL A PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS THAT
WE HAVE NEVER FACED BEFORE
DENNIS KILLED TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF PEOPLE IN OUR COUNTRY
THOUSANDS IN OUR STATE. THIS IS
THE PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS WITH A
PEN DEPICTED HAS NO CURE OR
VACCINE IN WITH NO END IN
SIGHT. THAT REQUIRES A VERY
VULNERABLE TO BE ON THE FRONT
LINES. TO FIGHT THIS AND TO
KEEP PEOPLE SAFE. THE ESSENTIAL
PEOPLE MANY OF THE CUTS TO
HELP. AND HUMAN SERVICES NOT
ONLY HARM BUT UNDERMINE THE
ESSENTIAL PEOPLE IN THIS FIGHT.
WHO ARE ON THE FRONT LINES IN
BY THIS VIRUS THE CUT TO MEDI
CAL INCLUDING OPTIONAL BENEFITS
TO HUMAN SERVICES INCLUDING THE
ELIMINATION OF AM AT THAT THE
pDEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES AND
REGIONAL CENTERS I JUST SAT AT
THE THOUGHT I AT THE P. THESE
WILL HARM THE VERY PEOPLE
INCLUDING THE WORKERS WHO ARE.
THE MOST VULNERABLE TO COAL
BED. AND ON THE FRONT LINES AND
FIGHTING TO KEEP PEOPLE SAFE
AND OUT OF THE EMERGENCY ROOMS.
OFTEN THE SAME PERSON NOW IF
YOU NOTICE. THE SAME COMMUNITY
INCLUDING COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
PEOPLE WHO ARE UNDOCUMENTED WHO
ARE THE VERY PEOPLE WHO ARE
IMPACTED BY THE CUTS. THIS IS
NOT THE WAY TO RESPOND TO THIS
CRISIS. BECAUSE THIS IS A
PUBLIC. HEALTH CRISIS AS A
MEMBER ROUTE ANOTHER SAID IN A-
BED TIME AND- WE NEED BUDGET.
SOLUTION THAT ARE PERSON
CENTERED ABOUT THE- CHECK. THE
THANK SISTER WHEN SHE WAS ALIVE
SEE THE BLIND PEOPLE WHO ARE
WORK IN FOR SERVE WHO EVERY DAY
ARE BY TO CRY BY AND ON THE
FRONT LINE FIGHTING SO LET'S
THINK TOGETHER OF OTHER WAYS TO
CLOSE THE SHORTFALL THAT DO NOT
UNDERMINE THE EFFORTS AND HARM
THE LIVES TO GET CENTRAL PEOPLE
WHO ARE FIGHTING WHO ARE
RESPONDING TO THIS PUBLIC
HEALTH CORRECTIVE MANY YOU ARE
SCARED WHO ARE DESPERATE IN
NEED HELP NOT CUT. AND NOT
CLEAR THE GOVERNOR HAS PROVEN
THAT IT IS POSSIBLE TO COME UP
WITH SOLUTIONS THAT HELP PEOPLE.
TO HELP COMMUNITIES WITH THE
ACTION IN RESPONDING TO THAT.
BUT THE PROPOSED CUTS DO NOT DO
THAT THE GOVERNOR LEGISLATURE
AND THOSE ON THE SUBCOMMITTEE
AND EVERYONE SAYS WE'RE IN THIS
TOGETHER. AND THAT RECOGNIZES
THE REALITY THAT BITING COALBED
IS ABOUT PROTECTING PEOPLE AND
THAT MEANS BOTTOM LINE THAT WE
CAN COME UP WITH BETTER
SOLUTIONS TOGETHER. THE SHEIK
AGAIN THE TIME THAT YOU HAVE
GIVEN TO ALL OF US IN PROVIDING
PUBLIC COMMENT AND THANK YOU
FOR ALL YOUR WORK MISS CHAIR.
THANK YOU SIR OPERATOR CAN WE
GO TO THE NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
BY LARA LOGAN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THE NAME CHANGE NUMBER ONE THE
WHITE WITH BLACK PAINT AND
ARMAND POVERTY. YOU CAN HEAR ME
OKAY. YOU'RE COMING YOU'RE
BREAKING UP A LITTLE BIT SO. MY
APOLOGIES. I ECHO BUT I'M GONNA
CAN YOU. WE OPPOSE THE PROPOSED
MEDI CAL BENEFIT CUTS TARGETED
TOWARDS OLDER ADULTS THE
NEIGHBORHOOD ABOUT DENTAL
BENEFITS THAT WOULD RESTORED IN
TWO THOUSAND AND INCLUDING
PARTIAL DENTURES TREATMENT AND.
MISS WAY WERE HAVING TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTIES A IF WE CAN'T
IMPROVE THE CONNECT AND I
THOUGHT THAT. CAN YOU HEAR ME
OK YES THAT'S MUCH BETTER. WHEN
YOU CONTINUE PLEASE THANK YOU.
I REMEMBER HIM CUT ADULT BUT NO
BETTER AT IT WITH THIS BEFORE
TO AND YOU HAVE REACHED. BEEN
PARTIAL DENTURE. AND WE ARE THE-
THANKS ACT EIGHT I DON'T
QUALIFY FULL DENTURES. WE HAD
AT THE CRITICAL BENEFIT MANY OF
WHICH WERE JUST BE ANYONE RIGHT
AFTER HAND HERE. REFERRED TO
THE NOW THE THEY CAN SHOOT TO
PROVIDE TO THEIR- THE NOT
OPTIONAL TO BE LONELY WHO NEED
THEM THE FEDEX INCLUDE COMMON
TREE PROPERTY AND- BUT I. THREE
DOLLARS. I'M SURE IT'S THERE.
CLEAN AND WASH ACTIVE DUTY BUT
THE PREVENT DETERIORATION THAT
HEALTH AND THE USUAL CAUGHT AND
THE SERVICE THAT. WE ALSO THE
THIRD THAT IN THE BILL TO PUT
SELECT THE INTERNAL CLICK THE
BACK AND THAT HE AND OCCUPIED
THERAPY. CURRENT HEALTH CARE HE
NEEDS AND WE SHARE YEAH YEAH
THE QUEST TO LOOK AT THE SHOOT.
BEYOND THAT AND LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE LEGISLATURE
AND ADMINISTRATION TO PROTECT.
CLARK CAREGIVERS AND
GRANDPARENTS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISS Y. OPERATOR CAN WE GO
TO THE NEXT CALLER PLEASE. IT
WILL BE A LINE ONE ONE SIX GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS AN IMPRINT
THAT'S WHAT THE CALIFORNIA
ACADEMY OF FAMILY PHYSICIANS
PERSONA STATE THAT- FAMILY
POSITION DEEPLY APPRECIATE THE
ACTIONS YOU HAVE TAKEN SO FAR
TO IMPROVE ACCESS TO CARE TO
TELL HEALTH. AND THE CURRENT
PERSONAL PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT
WE HAVE BEEN INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT PRIMARY CARE
PHYSICIANS ON THE FRONT LINES
AND WE ARE DOING TESTING
TRADING IN EDUCATING PATIENTS
ON OF THE NINETEEN. WHAT WERE
VERY KIND ABOUT. OF PRIMARY
CARE IN CALIFORNIA. SOME OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS WOULD
EXACERBATE ACCESS TO CARE GREEN
IT'S QUITE THE- FUTURE. WE
SHARE TEAMMATE CONCERNS
REGARDING PROP FIFTY SIX LONG
AND MEDICARE RATES. BUT WE URGE
YOU TO TAKE THREE SPECIFIC
ACTION TO ENSURE AFTER OUR
RECORDS NOT IMMEDIATELY
COMPROMISED. IS MAINTAINED
THROUGHOUT THE PROJECT- THE
PANDEMIC AND IS REFORM TO
BETTER SERVE CALIFORNIA. FIRST
PREVENT CUTS TO THE FONG BROWN
PRIMARY CARE PHYSICIAN TRAINING
PROGRAM- SECOND REQUIRE HEALTH
PLANS. FOR PRIMARY CARE
PRACTICE BY PROVIDING
PERSPECTIVE GRANT. AND THIRD
HELPING TO TRANSFORM OUR. MAKE
YOUR PAYMENT AND DELIVERY FOR
THE FUTURE. THE GOVERNMENT MAY
REVISE BUDGET ALSO SLASH THE
FONG BROWN. MY CHARACTER
TRAINING PROGRAM WHICH PROVIDES
FUNDING FOR PRIMARY CARE RENT
THE TRAINING PROGRAMS WITH A
PROVEN TRACK RECORD OF
GRADUATING PHYSICIAN TO
PRACTICE PRIMARY CARE AND
UNDERSERVED AREAS. SERVING
UNDERSERVED POPULATIONS
INCLUDING FINGERS CHILDREN I'M
NOT CHILDREN AND THOSE WITH
SPECIAL NEEDS. WE COULDN'T
AGREE WITH THE FOLLOWING NUMBER
RANDALL MORE THAT THE CAT WILL
DO ALMOST NOTHING TO FIX OUR
BUDGET SHORTFALL IT WILL
SIGNIFICANTLY UNDERMINE AFFECT
THE PROPER CARE FOR YEARS TO
COME. WITHOUT THIS FUNDING MANY
FOR THIS TRAINING PROGRAMS WILL
BE FORCED TO CLOSE ELIMINATING
ACT THAT THE PRIME RETURN
UNDERSERVED POPULATIONS. THAT
NEED IT MOST DURING AND AFTER
THIS QUITE THE SONG RAPPER
GONNA HIGH THE OVER AT THE-
NEED HEALTHCARE. MANY AND MEDIA.
EACH FAMILY MEDICINE RESIDENT
PROVIDES AT LEAST SIX HUNDRED
PARKER HM BUT THE CORE YEAR
WHILE IN TRAINING. SUPPORTING
PRIMER COVERED THE PROGRAM'S
ALL PLUGGED INTO VIçT LONG
TERM BENEFITS FOR COMMUNITY. AT
THE MAJORITY OF RESIDENTS DAY
AND PRACTICE IN AREAS IN WHICH
THEY TRAIN. IN THE LAST THREE
YEARS ALONE. SONG BROWN HELP TO
CREATE AND FIND TWENTY THREE
NEW PRIMARY CARE RENT THE
PROGRAMS. THIRTY SIX IN
RESIDENT THE SLOT EXISTING
PROGRAMS AND MORE THAN SIX
HUNDRED NEW PRIMARY CARE
PHYSICIAN RESIDENTS OF GONE ON
PROVIDE CARE TO THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS. EVEN WORKING. IS
THE NUMBER CRIME PACK THERE
CLOSING. AS A RESULT OF A-
UNDERPAYMENT PRIMARY CARE AND
THE EFFECTS OF THE OF THE
NINETEEN CRISIS. THESE
PRACTICES WILL NOT RETURN
WITHOUT IMMEDIATE HELP. RECENT
STUDIES INDICATE NEARLY 80% OF
PRIMARY CARE CLINICIANS ARE
EXPERIENCING SEVERE WORK POSTED
SEVERE FINANCIAL STRAIN. AS A
RESULT OF COVER NINETEEN.
VULNERABLE PRIMARY CARE
PRACTICES ARCHITECT WILL BEING
PURCHASED BY LARGE CORPORATE
AND THE- LITTLE FURTHER
CONSOLIDATE THE HEALTHCARE
MARKET. CONSTRAINT CHOICE AND
DRIVE UP ALL. MEANWHILE
CALIFORNIA TELL AND THEN
INSURERS ARE MADE BY PROFITABLE
AS THEY CAN TO COURT ASIAN.
WITHOUT PAYING FOR SERVICE. ACT
MOODY'S MOVIES AND SERVICES
PRODUCTS MOST INSURERS WILL
MEAN. OVER THE NEXT FEW YEARS
WE URGE THE STATE TO ACQUIRE
HEALTHCARE SERVICE PLAN AND
HEALTH INSURERS WITH AN ACTIVE
FEE FOR SERVICE CONTRACT WITH
PRIMARY CARE PRACTICE. PROVIDE
A ONE TIME PAYMENT EQUAL TO THE
AMOUNT A THE PREVIOUS YEAR FROM
MARCH IN NINETEEN TWENTY
THINKING. THE COVERED STATE OF
EMERGENCY BE EXTENDED PAST JUNE
TWENTY TWENTY EACH PAYMENT
CHICKEN IN MONTH A MONTH INTO
THE EMERGENCY DECLARATION IS
OFFENDED BY THE GOVERNOR. THIS
SOLUTION WILL NOT REQUIRE STATE
GENERAL FUND DOLLARS BUT SIMPLY
REQUIRE HEALTH PLANS DEFENDER
RELEASED BRINGING DOLLARS TO
ENSURE ACCESS TO CARE DURING
THIS CRISIS AND BEYOND. WITHOUT
IT PATIENTS WITH FOUR FIFTY
CARE AND SPENT THE RUMORED
ENSURING THE. LIKELIHOOD OF
CONTAGION WILL ONLY GROW. AND
MY SHARE BUT THERE WAS TO
ENSURE A THE BACK THAT THE CARE.
AND I THE- WELL THE MEDIA FUNDS
ARE NECESSARY LIFE BY TO KEEP.
CARE PRACTICE OF. WE URGE THE
THANK TO ENSURE TOP DOES NOT
WITH BROKEN IT'S FUN HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM WHEN INITIALS. OF THIS
PRACTICE AT. WE ARE THE STATE
TO CONVENE PAYER PROVIDERS AND
CONSUMERS TO IDENTIFY HOW THE-
OUR SYSTEM CAN MOVE PRIMARY
CARE TO VALUE BASED PAYMENT.
ALIGNING PAYMENT REPORTING IN
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENT AND
FINALLY PROVIDING THE REAL
RESEARCH IS NEEDED FOR ABOUT
PRIMARY CARE FOUNDATION
CALIFORNIA TO HELP. THEM. THIS
CAN BE DONE THROUGH. WITH
PERFORMANCE BASED AT THAT
PAYMENT THE OLD POSITION THE-
FOR AND COST. ONE OF THE PANEL
AND PARTICULARLY THE
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS PRESENT FOR ALL
YOUR SUPPORT OF COMMON THINK
COMMITMENT TO HEALTHCARE GREEN
INCREDIBLY DIFFICULT TIME.
THANK YOU MISTER FRANCIS
OPERATOR CAN WE GO TO THE NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. WILL BE LINE
SIXTY FIVE GO AHEAD PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS KELLY
BROKEN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
PUBLIC HOSPITALS WE RECOGNIZE
THE UNPRECEDENTED IMPACT THE
COVER NINETEEN ON OUR ECONOMY
AND THE SIGNIFICANT FISCAL
CHALLENGES AHEAD AS OUTLINED IN
THE NAY REVISION. CALIFORNIA'S
TWENTY ONE PUBLIC HEALTH CARE
SYSTEMS HAVE BEEN SERVING AN
INTEGRAL AND THE COVER NINETEEN
RESPONSE PARTICULARLY FROM MANY
IN CALIFORNIA'S MEDI CAL
POPULATION THOSE WHO REMAIN
UNINSURED AND OTHER VULNERABLE
PATIENTS SUCH AS THOSE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
WORKING ALONG BY LOCAL PUBLIC
HEALTH DEPARTMENT AND EMERGENCY
PERSONNEL HEALTHCARE SYSTEM
MEET OUR MAP CHANGES. RATIONS
TO PREPARE FOR THIRDS CAPACITY
BRING UP BUT THEN THERE. AND
CONVERT NANKANA FACES AND
SETTING PUBLIC HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM HAVE ALSO BEEN AT THE
FOREFRONT OF ACCELERATING
CALIFORNIA'S TESTING CAPACITY
AND INCREASING ACCESS TO TOP.
THE PAGE SUPPORT CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION AB WORK FOR
ADDITIONAL. INVESTMENT AND
HOSPITALS IN THE CURRENT YEAR
IN THE BUDGET YEAR AS PUBLIC
HOSPITALS REVENUES DECLINE DO
RESEARCH CAPACITY PREPARATION.
WE ALSOWANT TO MAKE CLEAR AT
THE PUBLIC HOSPITALS RELY ON
NINETEEN NINETY ONE REALIGNMENT
REVENUES WHICH ARE PLUMMETING.
WE JOIN THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES AND
SEEKING ASSISTANCE AND SELLING
THOSE REVENUES. PUBLIC
HOSPITALS USE THESE REGULAR
DAHLE. AS A NON NOT. WHICH
MEANS A LOSS OF ONE DOLLAR IS
MORE AKIN TO TWO DOLLARS OR
MORE TO OUR PUBLIC HOSPITAL
SYSTEM. DEMI REVISION ALSO THE
SIGNIFICANT NEED FOR FEDERAL
SUPPORT CAP TO SPENDING AN EXIT
AN EXTRAORDINARY AMOUNT OF TIME
ENERGY. FOCUSED ON FEDERAL
OPPORTUNITIES INCLUDING
SUPPORTING THE HEROES ACT WE
ARE SEEKING ADDITIONAL FEDERAL
FUNDING FOR HOSPITALS. AND
FERMENT AROUND FOR THE MEDICAID
PROGRAM AND THE BUDGET PROCESS
MOVES FORWARD C. PH REMAINS
COMMITTED TO PARTNERING WITH
THE GOVERNOR AND LEGISLATURE.
AND FEDERAL OFFICIALS TO FIND
CREATIVE SOLUTIONS TO ENSURE
THE VIABILITY OF THE SIXTY
NINTH DURING COVER NINETEEN
AMBIENCE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME THIS MORNING. THANK YOU
MISS. OPERATOR CAN WE GO TO THE
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THAT WILL
BE LIVE FIFTY FIVE GO AHEAD
PLEASE. HELLO MY NAME IS JEFF
CARTER GEAR WHEN I MADE MY
PUBLIC COMMENT YESTERDAY AND
WHY A KENYAN TO THE CHAMBER WAS
TO REMIND YOU OF THE FACE. WHO
DISABILITY AND- YOUR SENIORS
WHO LOOK LIKE. ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT YEAH RACHAEL
EVERYTHING THAT I HAVE HEARD
BEFORE AND APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY OF PUBLIC COMMENT I
WANT TO ENCOURAGE YOU. DOCTOR
ARAMBULA AS THE ASSEMBLY. HERE
PLEASE HOLD MORE INFORMATIONAL
HEARING THIS TIME SO WE ADDRESS
THIS SITUATION SO WE DO NOT DO
AS WE'VE TALKED ABOUT TEN YEARS
AGO YEAH I REMEMBER THAT QUITE
HUGE SO PLEASE AND HOPEFULLY WE
WILL ALL GET THROUGH THIS. GOOD
TO AND YET PARDON ME DENTIST
BECAUSE BY JUST SIMPLY DO NOT
HAVE THE MARRIAGE THAT THEY
NEED TO PERFORM A CENTRAL
SERVICES IN THE CORNER QUORUM.
OF HOW MUCH YOU NEED YOU NOT
ONLY ARE SENIORS WHICH IS WORTH
SO MUCH OF. LAST TWO DAYS HAVE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT BUT FOR ALL
OF THE POPULATION OF CALIFORNIA
THE INCREDIBLE NEEDS YOU ARE OF
THE ASSEMBLY CHAIRPERSON AND
WHAT NEEDS. TO BE DONE. HILL
NEW TO BE DONE. AND I WANT TO.
YOU BUT ALL GET THEIR STUMP
MORE. IN OVER. FOR IN READ.
THERE CAN BE ASSOCIATED WITH
YOU KNOW I AM OPEN TO IT. LET
ME BE OF ASSISTANCE PLEASE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SIR OPERATOR CAN WE PLEASE GO
TO THE NEXT CALLER. ITEM ONE
TWENTY FOUR GO AHEAD. BUT ONE
TWENTY FOUR IS DROPPED WILL
WANT TO LINE ONE THIRTY THREE
GO AHEAD PLEASE. ONE THIRTY TO
NEARLY EVER LINES OPEN SO I HAD.
THIS IS DANNY MARTINEZ UP IN
THE CALIFORNIA PHARMACISTS
ASSOCIATION ARE WE RESPECTFULLY
DO OPPOSED- SOME OF THESE
ELIMINATIONS BUT THERE ARE ARE
PROPOSED- NOTABLY THE- PHARMACY
SERVICES THAT ARE UNDER THE
ADULT DENTAL AND OTHER OPTIONAL
BENEFITS- THS PROGRAM WAS WAS
APPROVED IN TWENTY SIXTEEN AND
UNFORTUNATELY THAT NOTS THE
DEPARTMENT DID NOT START THIS
PROGRAM UP. FOR A MINUTE
SERVICES FOR PHARMACISTS UNTIL
APRIL TWENTY NINETEEN AND WE'RE
BLESSED IN THE FISCAL YEAR INTO
THIS PROGRAM. ONE OF THE
CONCERNS THAT WE IS THAT THIS
IS ONLY JUST FISCAL
CONSIDERATION BUT THIS SEEMS TO
BE MORE A FUNDAMENTAL SHIFT IN
HEALTHCARE POLICY WE BELIEVE
THAT THE LEGISLATURE TO LOOK
BEYOND THE STATED BOTTOM LINE
APPROACH AND STATE. TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION. THE FACT THAT
PHARMACY SERVICES INCLUDE.
ITEMS JUST BIRTH CONTROL
SMOKING CESSATION VACCINATIONS
AND THIS STARTING THIS YEAR-
PREP AND PAP COVERAGE. AND IT
IS DONE SO AT A RATE 15% LESS
THAN OTHER HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS
THAT ARE CURRENTLY OFFERING
THESE THESE SERVICES. SO THIS
IS NOT AND- THIS IS A LESS
EXPENSIVE. BENEFIT TO THE STATE
THAT'S BEING ELIMINATED- BOB IS
OBVIOUSLY THIS IS ESPECIALLY
TROUBLING THE MIDDLE THE
PANDEMIC- WHEN WE SHOULD BE
EXPANDING SERVICES NOT
ELIMINATING THEM AND I WOULD
NOTE THAT VACCINATIONS AS I
MENTIONED WOULD BE SEVERELY
IMPACTED BY THIS DECISION.
WHICH WOULD MAKE THIS AND
FUTURE HEALTH EMERGENCY WORSE.
ADDITIONALLY WE ALSO OPPOSE THE
NOMINATION OF THE THREE FORTY
B. PHARMACY SERVICES BOB THIS
THE SERVICES ARE. DONE IN UP
FOR THOSE MANAGED CARE
ORGANIZATION DO NOT PROVIDE
DIRECT OUTPATIENT PHARMACY
SERVICES AND WHAT HAVE AN
ESPECIALLY DEVASTATING IMPACT
ON LOW INCOME AND MEDICALLY
UNDERSERVED POPULATIONS-
LIMITED ENTRY BECAUSE- PHARMACY
SERVICES. WHAT RESTRICTIONS
BEING LEFT WITHOUT LIFE
SUSTAINING MEDICATIONS THAT
COULD RESULT. IN A I'M SORRY
NOT COULD RESULT WILL RESULT IN
HIGHER UTILIZATION RATES. OF
HOSPITAL EMERGENCY ROOMS IN
PLACE ADDITIONAL FINANCIAL
BURDENS ON THE ALREADY. STUDENT
ALREADY OVERTAXED COMMUNITY
CLINIC SYSTEM THE PENCIL IMPACT
OF THE STATE'S MOST ONE OF OUR
PATIENTS AND THEIR ABILITY TO
RECEIVE THE MET ESSENTIAL
MEDICATION IS WORTHY OF ROBUST
DISCUSSIONS THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS AND CPJ URGES THAT YOU
REJECT THIS RECOMMENDATION LET
US NOT FORGET THAT WHAT HURTS
COMMUNITY PHARMACY HURTS THE
PATIENTS WERE THEY PROVIDE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
ENOS OPERATOR CAN WE GO TO THE
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. FIND ONE
TWENTY FOUR. YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ONE MOMENT PLEASE AB MINUS
DROPPED ALSO LINE ONE FORTY
THREE YEAR LINE IS NEXT. YES
HELLO IT IS RICK HARKEN TO GET
AND DISABILITY RIGHTS ADVOCATES
DISABILITY RIGHTS ACTIVIST
DISABILITY RIGHT FRIEDMAN WHILE
I'M SPEAKING ON MY OWN BE HAPPY
TO TELL YOU THAT I'M A MEMBER
OF CAPITAL PEOPLE FIRST AN
ORGANIZATION RUN BY AND FOR
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES
SERVING SACRAMENTO COUNTY AND
THE- AGAIN LIKE I SAID
YESTERDAY INFORMED. OF
CALIFORNIA. DEVELOPMENTAL
CONSUMER ADVISORY COMMITTEE I.
ALPINE COLUSA EL DORADO. NEVADA.
SACRAMENTO SIERRA. THE OTHER.
SACRAMENTO CALIF SUTTER YOLO
AND YUBA COUNTIES. IF I
MENTIONED ALL CAN COUNTY SO
THAT MEANS I COVER ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA REGIONAL CENTER NOW
WHEN IT COMES TO MEDI CAL
LUCKILY I GOT MEDICARE AND MY
PRIMARY INSURANCE MEDICARE IS
MY PRIMARY MEDICAL INSURANCE.
HELLO IS MY SECONDARY MEDICAL
INSURANCE NOW I NEED NON
EMERGENCY MEDICAL
TRANSPORTATION TO GET ME TO
CERTAIN PLACES LIKE I NEED TO
GO TO. FOR IN ABOUT A MONTH
FROM NOW THE CIGARETTE
BACHELORS THE NET THAT READ THE
FENCE WITH HELP ME I MAY NEED
TO GO. FIND AT LEAST THAT CAN
AT LEAST UNTIL I CAN GET MY
FACE HIDDEN BACK TO WHERE I CAN
USE PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION. WELL
IF. MEDI CAL PAY FOR THAT A
BURKE NOT OVER THE MOON CRACK.
THE PUBLIC. I'M A TO ASK THE
REGIONAL CENTER. YESTERDAY OF
THESE CUTS GO THROUGH. FROM THE
HAVING. CLICK WITH THE CENTER.
I MAY HAVE CONFLICT WITH MY CAL
AND THE- IF OKAY NUMBERS. AND
IF I HAVE TO GO THE REGIONAL.
THEY MADE WILL GO TO ANOTHER
FIRST AND THAT THE PRICE COULD
BE A LONG ORDEAL AND IT COULD
BE. AS MUCH. BE VERY NASTY AND
THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR AND I'M NOT
GOING TO MENTION THE VOTER IS
NOT SOMEONE THE BACKGROUND
WHERE HE CAN BE VERY. ABLE AND
VERY NASTY WITH SO. WHAT INTO
THE RIVER. I'M NOT GONNA FOR
THE DEMO SO THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SIR OPERATOR CAN WE GO TO
THE NEXT CALLER PLEASE. OVER A
LINE NINETY SEVEN GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING DOCTOR CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THIS IS ADRIAN SHELTON
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE OF CHILD AND FAMILY
SERVICES. WHERE ORGANIZATION OF
A HUNDRED FORTY FIVE NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION SERVING MORE THAN
HALF A MILLION VULNERABLE
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES ACROSS
THE STATE. THE IMPACT OF THE
PANDEMIC ON THE MENTAL HEALTH
OF CALIFORNIANS IS
UNPRECEDENTED. IN THE
LEGISLATURE TO BE APPLAUDED.
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP AND
NAVIGATING THE IMMENSELY BUDGET
WHICH- THE URGENCY IN THE FACT
THAT HE TO SECURE SIGNIFICANT
ADDITIONAL FEDERAL FUNDS IS
CLEAR THROUGHOUT THE BAY BUDGET
REVISION. AND WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO
ADVOCATE FOR THESE FUNDS WHAT
ARE CONGRESSIONAL LEADERS. AT
THE SAME TIME CALIFORNIA MUST
BE CLEARED OUR STATE'S RECALL
TO PROTECT THE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH SPEAKING THAT. WHICH IS
EXTREMELY RARE. DUE TO THE
SPEED ECONOMIC RECESSION AND
ALSO BECAUSE OF WHAT WE ARE
SEEN AS A DRAMATIC RISE IN THE
NEED. FOR MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES. ALLIANCE MEMBER
ORGANIZATIONS ARE ON THE
FRONTLINE OF SUPPORTING
CHILDREN YOUTH AND FAMILIES WHO
BLOCKED OUR MOST BASIC SUPPORT.
WHAT THE PROJECTED THE QUIET
ARE REVENUE SOURCES THAT FINE
ARTS BUT HERE THESE NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE THE
ESSENTIAL FIFTY THAT FOR
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
FAMILIES WILL HAVE TO REDUCE
CRITICAL FACTOR IN. WHAT MANY
OF THE ABILITY TO RESPOND TO
THE OVERWHELMING BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH NEEDS THAT WE ALL SEE
COMING IN. WE URGE THE
LEGISLATURE AND THROUGH THE
LEADERSHIP OF THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE TO IN FACT FUNDING TO
STATES CALIFORNIA'S. NOT
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SYSTEM.
FURTHER THE PROVIDER ALONG WITH
THE COUNTIES ARE REQUESTING
TEMPORARY EMERGENCY FLEXIBILITY
AND EXPAND THE IN MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ACT FUNDING. DEFERRAL
OF REGULATORY AND
ADMINISTRATIVE REQUIREMENTS AND
OTHER ADMINISTRATIVE RELIEF TO
HELP WEATHER THE STORM WE ALSO
STRONGLY SUPPORT LEADERSHIP ON
SUICIDE PREVENTION UP WHILE. A
COMPOUND THE FACTS OF THE
MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS FOLLOWING
THE PANDEMIC COUPLED WITH
PROBABLE LOCAL COUNTY BUDGET
CUTS. THREATENED TO DECONSTRUCT
THE SAFETY NET SYSTEM THAT
COULD LEAD TO EVEN GREATER ****
AND BOTH DOLLARS AND HUMAN
LIFE. IN THE LONG RUN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MA'AM. OPERATOR CAN
WE GO TO THE NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
LINE NINETY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU ELLIOTT CARTER WITH
THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION E'RE
BEGINNING TO LIVE FOR WHAT
CHAIR ARAMBULA SHARED AS A
METAPHOR THE CODE NINETEEN
EARTHQUAKE AS CREATED AND WILL
EXACERBATE AT BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
THE NOMINEE WE'RE CURRENTLY
EXPERIENCING RIGHTS THAT THE
RISE OF THE NEED FOR BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH SERVICES WELL BEING
ASKED TO DO THE AND WORK ALL
ADDRESSED TO NAMI OF NEEDS WITH
SIGNIFICANTLY DECLINING
REVENUES. WE ARE FUNDED BY
SALES TAX VEHICLE LICENSE FEE
AND A AND A TAX ON MILLIONAIRES
AS WELL AS FEDERL FUNDS USED
LEVERAGED WITH THESE ADDITIONAL
DOLLARS ALL OF THE FUNDING
SOURCES WILL BE REDUCED
SIGNIFICANTLY BECAUSE OF THE
ECONOMIC DOWNTURN CAUSED BY
COVERED NINETEEN THREATENING
ACCESS TO BE ABLE HEALTH
SERVICES DURING THE CURRENT.
COUNTY GREAT VARIOUS AND
CRITICAL PROGRAM ON BEHALF OF
THE STATE TO RIP. HEALTH AND
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER SERVICES
IT WOULD NEVER IMAGINED WHEN
REALIGNMENT WAS AGREED TO THAT
WE'D BE FACING AN EXTRAORDINARY
CIRCUMSTANCE I COVERED NINETEEN
HUNDRED ARE BEING ASKED TO
ADDRESS THE GROWING BEHAVE ROB
ACCIDENT EPIDEMIC WITH 11220%
LESS REVENUES. WHILE STILL
COMPLYING WITH STATE AND
FEDERAL ROLE IN TOTAL COUNTY
THEY'RE GONNA LOSE THREE POINT
THREE BILLION DOLLARS OVER THE
NEXT TO YOU. COUNTY IS THE LEAD
LED BY THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES ARE
ASKING TO WORK TO GET WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION TO PRESERVE
REALIGNMENT PROGRAMS AND AVOID
MASSIVE CUTS TO ANSWER AND
SERVICE DESTRUCTION. TO THE
VERY LOW INCOME RESIDENTS NEED
MOST DURING THIS TIME IN
ADDITION IN LINE PROJECTIONS.
FOR WE ATE ALONG WITH THE
COALITION OF BE HEALTH CONSUMER
AND HER GROUP HAVE COME
TOGETHER TO FOR NEEDED BUT THE
AND HOW TO USE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICE ACT FUNDING TO MORE
EFFECTIVELY USE THE FUNDS TO
MEET THE CHALLENGES ASSOCIATED
WITH CALVET NINETEEN WE ARE
QUITE SUPPORT ALSO FOR MENTAL
HEALTH PEERS YOUTH MENTAL
HEALTH FIRST AID TRAINING WHICH
ARE BOTH SUCCESSFUL MOP AND
PROVIDING CAUGHT HAVE BEEN
CALLED UP IN EVERY INDIVIDUALS
WITH MENTAL. RIGHT WRITTEN
TESTIMONY FOR YOUR- AND THANK
FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU MA'AM
OPERATOR CAN WE GO TO THE NEXT
COLOR PLEASE. LINE SEVENTY SIX
GO AHEAD PLEASE. SHARE MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO ADDRESS THE SUBCOMMITTEE I'M
KATHY MUSBURGER MY COMMENTS ARE
BEHALF OF THE DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES NETWORK AND MANY OF
YOU KNOW OUR HOMES OFFER
RESIDENTIAL SERVICES FOR PEOPLE
WITH ANTI INTELLECTUAL
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES CLUB
FEDERAL HEALTHCARE NEEDS TO
REQUIRE NURSING SERVICES AND
ABILITY TO THE FIFTEENTH WITH A
SPECIALIZED LEVEL CARE WE ARE
ABLE TO PROVIDE OUR RESIDENTS
WITH WHO FILLED RELATIVELY
INDEPENDENT LIFE THEIR
COMMUNITIES. AND HELP YEAH WE
HAVE THOUSAND HOME MANY FORTY
SIX BED SERVING SEVEN THOUSAND
PEOPLE WITH ID THE MINISTRY
PROPOSED TO ELIMINATE ALL PROP
FIFTY SIX RIGHT SUPPLEMENTAL
THIS IF ENACTED VERY LIKE WITH
ME THE END OF OUR HOME AND THE
VALUE TO THE LIVING OPTION THEY
OFFER FOR CALIFORNIANS WITH IGP
ARE HOME. FROM THAT AT FOUR OUR
RE THE TO THE. NINE ENTERS.
YEAH. TWO THREE BE HELD THE
MYTH IN THE CASE WE HAVE A NO
INCREASE INSTEAD BOWSTRING ONLY
THE OUT THE ONLY THING REVERSE
THE IS THE MOST. UPPER MIDDLE
PAYMENT PROVIDE UNDER POP SIX.
AND NOW THE- PROPOSES TO
ELIMINATE THAT SUPPLEMENTAL IN
NORMAL TIME THIS CUT WE TRY
WOULD WORK TO OFFSET IT THIS
ADJUSTMENT AND WOULD BEEN VERY
HARD BUT WE HAD WHAT WE WOULD
WORK TO OVERCOME THAT BUT NOW
WE CAN. MINUTE ACOSTA MATURING
WE CAN KEEP RESIDENTS. DURING
THE COLD CRISIS. CUT CUT WHEN
JUST HURT BUT IT WOULDN'T BE WE
WOULD BE ABLE TO. THAT IT VERY
LIKELY TO BE IN. I HAD LOTS OF
CONVERSATIONS WITH OUR HOME.
AND ME REVISED HAS COME OUT AND
IT REALLY IS LOOKING DESPERATE
OUT THERE WE ARE LOOKING LIKE
WE ARE GOING TO HAVE TO CLOSE.
SEVEN THOUSAND PEOPLE. CAN HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO BUILD DISTILLING
LIVES OF THE RESIDENTS ARE
HOME. THIS CALL. SEVEN OUT OF.
ON WE SHOULD ALL FEAR THE CARD.
PLEASE READ WE ARE MEMBERS THE
MEMBERS TO REJECT PLAN REVISED
PROPOSAL. AND WANT TO THANK YOU
MUCH FOR THE HEARING TODAY
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING US TO
BECOME. THANK YOU MA'AM.
OPERATOR CAN GO TO THE NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. I IN SIXTY SIX
GO AHEAD PLACE. YOUR NUMBER
FIFTY ONE BILLION CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTING OVER FOUR HUNDRED
AND FIVE THOUSAND LONG TERM
CARE PROVIDERS I'M DEFINITELY
ECHO THE COMMENTS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES- NJ WHO SPOKE
EARLIER I JUST WANTED TO
SPECIFICALLY TALK ABOUT OUR
LONG TERM CARE COMPETITORS I'LL
BE RECOGNIZED DIFFICULT
DECISIONS THAT HAVE TO BE MADE
DURING THE I'M PRESIDENT THAT
TIME OF. KOBE NINETEEN PANDEMIC
BUT UNFORTUNATELY WE HAVE
CONCERNS WITH PROPOSALS RELATED
SKILLED NURSING FACILITY OUT OF
TOUCH ON TO AND FROM OF COURSE
WILL PROVIDE WRITTEN DETAILS.
OF THAT COMMITTEE. THE GOOD
PROJECT TWENTY. NURSING WORKERS
IN OTHER TO HER GOVERNOR'S BUT
TROUBLE. WHO WILL GET HELP.
EIGHT LBS THEN AND OTHER OF THE-
IT'S THESE WORKERS ARE ON THE-
FOUGHT KERN DURING THE PANDEMIC
AND PRIOR TO THE PAN. OF CARE
FOR THE RESIDENTS TO OUR STORE
HOURS. RIGHT FROM CONDITION
THAT REQUIRE AROUND CLOCK CARE.
THEY ARE THE ONES THAT'S HOURS
EVERY DAY AND IRAQ CONTACT WITH
RESIDENTS HAVE A HIGH IMPACT ON
THE QUALITY OF CARE WITH THE-
WE'RE CONCERNED. THE PROPOSED
CHANGES. BRING MORE. THE LADY
WORKING STRUCTURE WHEN PRODUCE
BETTER ALL. NOR WILL PROMOTE
ACCOUNTABILITY. AND THAT. TO
LINK BETWEEN THE NURSING WORK
FOR AND QUALITY OF CARE.
ESPECIALLY AT A TIME AT DYER
AND NOW. NURSING FACILITY WHERE
BOTH PROVIDERS AND THAT ARE
DYING DIFFICULT AT NINETEEN WE
MUST EXAMINE OUR CURRENT
STRUCTURE AND ENSURE WE ARE
INVESTING IN BOTH DIRECT AND
INDIRECT. LABOR AND- QUALITY OF
CARE. WE LOOK FOR TO CONTINUED
COMPASS WITH THE ADMIN AND THE-
ON VERY SPECIFIC CHEN BETTER
NEED IT RELATED TO MOVE TOWARDS
THE STATE'S GOLAN THE PAPA NEW
BRAKE OUR SYSTEM THE LATEST
PERFECTLY TO THE PROPOSED 10%
RATE INCREASE FOR FOUR MONTHS
DURING THE PANDEMIC BUT GOT
NURSING FACILITY I. THERE ARE
AIR MARKED BUT WAGES BEEN A AND
PP NURSING HOME WORKERS WE ARE
OPPOSE WELL THE SIMPLE FACT
THAT THE ECONOMIC IMPACT OF THE
PANDEMIC THIS PROPOSAL CLEARLY
SHOWS A PRIORITY PLAGUE OF
FACILITY. RATHER THAN THE
PROVIDERS AND RESIDENTS OF
THOSE FACILITIES. PROVIDER
CURRENTLY DOT WITH THE PASSWORD
PAY DURING THE PANDEMIC AND
THEY CONTINUE TO RISK THEIR
LIVES BASICALLY THE CARE FOR
THE RESIDENTS. THANK AND THE P.
REMAIN IN. FOR THE PARENT THAT
DEFENSE WORKERS ARE NOT AT THAT.
THAT THERE WOULD SAID EARLIER
IF YOU SAFE TO BE IN A NURSE
HOME NOW AND WE ALL KNOW IT YET
BUDGET NOT REFLECTIVE OF THAT.
IT'S NOT SAFE NOW IMAGINE WHAT
WILL HAPPEN WHEN THERE'S AN
INFLUX OF INDIVIDUALS THAT NEED
TO GO TO A NURSING. ABOVE ALL
PROJECT AT AND WHEN THEY
REVIVED THAT WE HAVE DISCUSSED
FOR THE LAST FEW HOURS OFTEN
THE HEARING. ULTIMATELY THE
PANDEMIC HAS SHOWN THE
MCCALLUM. SAYS THAT
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECT LOW
INCOME AND TROUBLES WE- AND
THAT. THE G. SPECIAL ABOUT OF
THE- A SPECIAL THE FRONTLINE
WORKERS. HERE AND THE DISABLED
AND ALL THE MOST VULNERABLE
INDIVIDUAL. THE CURRENT MADE.
AND PROPOSED CUTS AFFECT THE
STATE BAR. POWERLESS AND MARGIN.
INTO WE IMPLORE YOU TO STAND
FOR THE THAT ARE. BETTER MOST
BONUS AND DEVELOP THE BALLOT
BUDGET BUT NOT ON THE BACK OF
WORKERS AND THE- ADULTS MOVE.
THANK YOU MAY. OPERATOR WE GO
TO THE NEXT CALLER PLAY. LIONEL
OLD GO AHEAD PLEASE. AFTER A
GOOD MORNING RATHER MY NAME IS
MELINA REYES AND I'M WITH THE
INLAND CARE GIVER RESOURCE
CENTER WHICH IS PART OF THE
CARE GIVER RESOURCE CENTER THAT
SPAN ACROSS THE STATE MY
PERSONAL WHILE WE WORK DAY IN
AND DAY OUT FIRST HAND WITH
FAMILY CARE GIVERS. QUIT
PROVIDING CARE TO ADD THEIR
LOVED ONE CAN BE IN YOURS. OR
WHO MAY BE SUFFERING FROM AN
ORGANIC BILLION IMPAIRMENT.
THESE ARE THE VERY CARE GIVERS
WHO ARE GENERATING WELL OVER A
BILLION DOLLARS IN UNPAID LABOR
AND REGULARLY PROVIDING CARE TO
THEIR LOVED ONE. OUR SYSTEM IS
SIMPLY UNEQUIPPED BY. HERE AT
THE BEACH ARE ABLE TO PROVIDE
SUPPORT SERVICE TO THEM WHICH
INCLUDES. SUPPORT AS WELL AS
RESOURCES BACKBEAT CARE GIVERS
NEED NOT BE ABLE TO ACT THAT
FINANCIALLY INCLUDING RESPITE.
THE THREAT GUARANTEED THEM
VALUABLE OPPORTUNITIES TO TAKE
CARE OF THEIR OWN HEALTH AND
MANY OF THEM CANNOT BELIEVE
THEIR LOVED ONE UNACCOMPANIED
WITHOUT RISKING THEIR HEALTH
AND WILL BE. WHAT I'M CALLING
ON A IN FIFTEEN IN OPPOSITION
TO GOVERNOR RECENT POSITION
EVER BIRTH AUGMENTATION IF THE
R. T. I. D. PROPOSALS WOULD
CAUSE SIGNIFICANT CHANGES AND-
IN SAID. THAT WE ARE ABLE TO
PROVIDE CARE GIVERS SERVICE ME.
VERY WELL HELP ME. THEIR
PHYSICAL AND MENTAL WELL DURING
THE CRISIS. AND THERE BURDENS
ARE LIKELY TO INCREASE AS THE
CRISIS CONTINUED TO REMOVE SUCH
FUNDING ENCOUNTERING AND
COUNTERPRODUCTIVE. AND SO I
THINK YOU ALSO HOLDING THIS
HEARING LISTENING TO US ALL AND
I GREATLY APPRECIATE. THE VERY
IN THE HEART OF THE MOTION THAT
I'VE HEARD FROM SEVERAL OF
THEM- BUT I CAN LET ANY OF YOU
ARE AWARE OF THE SIGNIFICANT
IMPACT. THAT NOT ONLY ARE A
CLIENT. A BUT THE OTHER TWO
THAT WOULD BE AT THE GOVERNOR
AND THREE THE FISH. I THINK YOU
THE TIME AND I ENCOURAGE YOU TO
MA'AM ROBERT TO THE CHECK.
THANK YOU. OPERATOR GO TO THE
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. FLIGHT
NINETY THREE GO AHEAD PLEASE.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS AT
LATE NOT BE HALF OF THAT AND
WE'LL TAKE CARE COALITION
REPRESENTING EIGHT IN MEDICAL
GROUP COMPRISING OVER TWENTY
FIVE AND FIFTY ABSTRACT BUT LET
THAT PROVIDE LIFESAVING AND
LIGHT AND HAVE BEEN CARED FOR
EIGHT MONTHS HONORABLE TOLD.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO THE ME READ BY IT. LIKE MUCH
OF OUR WORKFORCE IDIOTIC BUT
SELECT ARE STRUGGLING
FINANCIALLY IT IN THE CUPBOARD
CREATE BETTER. HAVING FROM
INCREASE HOT AND DRASTICALLY
REDUCED PATIENT VOLUME. THE
THIRD THIRTEEN RAFI AT 3240%
REDUCTION AND WRAPPED THEM. OUR
PRIMARY IS STILL LARGELY DEEPER
SERVICE MEDI CAL FOR WHAT
CALIFORNIA RANKS NEAR THE
BOTTOM FOR RATE. THE TECH
BUBBLE NOW PAYMENTS OVER THE
LAST THREE YEARS HAVE BROUGHT
RATE FOR THE APPROVED HELLO
THIRTEEN THIRTY WITH MEDICARE.
ANYWHERE FROM 5275% OF THEIR
PEAK AND POPULATION IS ENROLLED%
IN MEDICAID HOW ARE YOU YES.
THEREFORE ADEQUATE MEDICAL
REIMBURSEMENT AND MEDICAL
REMAINING FINANCE LATE FALL AND-
WE HAVE THREE MAIN REQUEST
RELATED TO THE BUDGET FIRST WE
URGE THE LEGISLATURE TO RETRACT
THE GOVERNOR FOR BOTH BOTH THAT
WE PROPOSITION. SIX DOLLARS.
EVERY GENERAL THAT THE MEDICAL
PROGRAM IT FUNDING IS NEEDED
NOW MORE THAN EVER THE RECRUIT
AND RETAIN AN ADEQUATE
PEDIATRIC SUBSPECIALTY BUT THAT
DIDN'T WORK FOR. ME ASIAN NEED
PARTICULARLY IN LIGHT OF THE
ANTICIPATED INCREASE MEDI CAL
EXPLODE. BACK IN. WE THOROUGHLY
ENCOURAGE THE LEGISLATURE TO
REQUIRE NONPROFIT AND FOR
PROFIT AND EARTH AND HEALTH
PLAN. THE PROTECT ACT AN ACT
THAT ERROR FREE DIRECT
FINANCIAL AT THE SPENT THERE
FOR THAT THE NETWORK. AND
LASTLY WE ASK THAT THAT WILL
HELP HIM AND PARITY IN MEDIC
I'LL BE MADE PERMANENT. HOW TO
HELP THAT PROVIDED A VITAL LINK
BETWEEN CHILDREN WHAT IMPACT OF
THEIR NEEDS AND THEIR PROVIDER.
IN A PANDEMIC AND WE INVESTMENT
MAIN CRITICAL PART OF. THE
LABOR. OVER BARRIERS TO CARE.
THE FOR MEDI CAL PROVIDERS BE
REIMBURSED. AND PRETEND THAT
THAT WILL BE VITAL OPTIMIZING
AT YOU THANK YOU AGAIN. THANK
YOU MA'AM. OPERATOR CAN WE GO
TO THE NEXT CALLER PLEASE. LINE
EIGHTY GO AHEAD PLACE. HELLO
THIS IS MICHELLE NEVINS
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR WITH DEL
ORAL CARE GIVER RESOURCE CENTER
AND MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA
CHARACTER RESOURCE CENTERS. I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE AT THE.
REJECT OUR PROJECT THE AT TWO
DOCUMENTATION FUNDS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA CARE GIVER RESOURCE
CENTERS WHICH WERE JUSTIN ACTED
THE IN THE TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY BUDGET- I WANT TO FIRST
AND FOREMOST THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO COMMUNICATE OUR THOUGHTS AND
HAVE APPRECIATED- THE
COMPASSION THAT I'VE HEARD FROM
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS THUS FAR-
RECOGNIZE SEEM THAT
CALIFORNIA'S OVER SIXTY FIVE
POPULATION IS PROJECTED TO GO.
TO EIGHT POINT SIX MILLION BY
TWENTY THIRTY GOVERNOR NEEDS
SOME IT IS AN EXACT. IN PREDICT
THE MASTER PLAN. THE GOAL
OUTLINED- FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS
ARE SERVICES THAT SUPPORT.
LIVABLE COMMUNITIES THE PURPOSE
HEALTH AND WELL BEING ECONOMIC
SECURITY AND SAFETY AND
CALIFORNIA'S CHARACTER RESOURCE
CENTERS- TOUCH ON EACH ONE OF
THESE GOALS. WE PROVIDE
ESSENTIAL SERVICES TO UNPAID
FAMILY CARE GIVERS TO PROVIDE
CARE AT HOME- WHERE MOST PEOPLE
WANT TO BE WE CARE FOR THE
HEALTH AND WELL BEING OF FAMILY
CAREGIVERS PROVIDING SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES ALONG THE WAY AND
TRAPPED THEIR JOURNEY- WE
INSURE THAT. AS LANDED HER
ORDERS THAT THEIR FOOD IS NOW
NOT THAT TO CUT SIR THIS THE
FAMILY MEMBERS WHO ARE CARRYING
FOR THE MUSCLE OKAY AT A TIME
THEY ARE MARBLE. THAN EVER.
SEND THE ON SET UP IN NINETEEN
SO PLAY ORDER FAMILY SEARCH
EVEN MORE SIX THEIR LOVED ONE
AT HOME AND OUT OF AT HOME AND
OUT OF HOSPITALS AND NURSING
HOMES. AND SERVICES SHOULD NOT
BE CUT THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
ACTUAL DREAM ADDITIONAL
RESPONSIBILITIES TO BURDENS TO
KEEP THEIR ABOUT TWENTY SAFE AT
HOME. SENIOR TODAY DON'T WITH
DISABILITIES ARE THE ONES
HARDEST HIT BY KOBE NINETEEN.
IT WAS BECAUSE OF AUGMENTATION
RECEIVED THIS HERE THAT OUR
SECURITY SYSTEM WAS ABLE TO
RESPOND IMMEDIATELY TO
CHALLENGES CREATED BY THE
SHELTER TO PLACE ORDERS. WE NOT
ONLY REMAINED OPEN TO AND
PROVIDED ESSENTIAL SERVICES
THAT PITTED RAPIDLY TO CONTINUE
SERVICES REMOTELY TELEPHONE
COMPLIANT ONLINE PLATFORMS AND
VI<c.cyan> COVERED NINETEEN</c>
COMPLAINT IN HOME PRESS THAT
OUR PROVIDERS. WE PROVIDED
SUPPORT AND GUIDANCE FUND
CURRENTLY SOURCES OF THE
SERVICE OPTIONS FINDING
AVAILABLE COMMUNITY SUPPORT TO
HELP THEIR LOVED ONES AT HOME.
ACCESS TO ACT. TO OKAY SUPPLY.
PP I'M IN ALL THE WILD REST
FIND FOR IN HOME CARE WHEN THEY
COULDN ATTEND- BRICK AND MORTAR
PROGRAMS SUCH AS ADULT DAY CARE
CENTERS IT'S JUST. CALIFORNIA'S
FOR TWENTY MILLION FAMILY
CAREGIVERS ARE NOT GOING AWAY
THIS VIRUS HAS DESTROYED SO
MUCH SHOULDN'T DESTROY VALUABLE
SERVICES AND SUPPORT THAT HAS
BEEN IN PLACE FOR MORE THAN
THIRTY YEARS THIS VIRUS ONLY
EXACERBATED. PLANNED FOR
RELEVANT SERVICES AND PUT
PRESSURES AND STRESS FOR
FAMILIES HIS AFFECT WILL LINGER
LONG AFTER CALIFORNIA RETURNS
TO WHATEVER THE THIS NEW NOR HE-
PLEASE. IT'S NOT CUT THE COW
CARE GIVER RESOURCE CENTER
SYSTEM AND ADDITIONALLY I ASK
THAT YOU DO NOT ELIMINATE I'M
ACCESS P. OR C. BACK PROGRAM
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MA'AM. WE
HAVE APPROXIMATELY FIFTY PEOPLE
IN Q. FOUR COMMENTS OPERATOR
CAN WE GO TO THE NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. FORTY NINE GO AHEAD
PLEASE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
EIGHTEEN FROM THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES I
WANT TO THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BILL OUT AND
MEMBERS NEED TO EVERYBODY POINT
TODAY- AS THE STATE IS
GRAPPLING WITH THIS
UNPRECEDENTED BUDGET SHORTFALL
IT'S A DIFFICULT TASK OF
DEVELOPING A BUDGET COUNTY ARE
ALSO GRAPPLING WITH ON PRESS
THE PORT ALL YOU OF MY CALL
YESTERDAY. ABOUT THE SHORTFALLS
IN NINETY ONE AND TWENTY ELEVEN
REALIGNMENT WHAT'S HELP FUND
LOCAL PROGRAMS FOR PUBLIC
HEALTH AND- HEALTH. WE ARE DOWN
THREE POINT THREE BILLION
DOLLARS IN THE CURRENT AND
BUDGET YEAR THIS IS WITHOUT
TAKING INTO CONSIDERATION THE
INCREASE. IN COSTS. HAVE COME
WITH COLD AT NINETEEN THERE
WERE THREE POINT THREE BILLION
DOLLARS DOWN FOR LOCAL REVENUE
FOR SERVICES WITHOUT. FACTORING
IN THE KOBE COST YEAH. WELL WE
APPRECIATE THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH WHY
EFFORT INCLUDE GETTING PP FOR
LOCAL AND I'M HELPING LOCAL
HAVE BEEN. I WANT MY YOU THAT
HELP DELIVERED. BY HI
DEPARTMENT STAFF LOCAL PUBLIC
HEALTH THE FIVE SO FAR MENTION
THEM. EVERY IN A MILLION
DOLLARS LESS THAN THEY RECEIVED
BEFORE THE MASS GREAT RECESSION
SO PUBLIC HEALTH IS REALLY BEEN
ALLOWED TO WITHER ON THE VINE
OF PEOPLE SAID. AND BY PUTTING
OUT A PLEA TO ASK FOR YOUR HELP
WE URGENTLY NEED HELP IN LOCAL
PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENT WE
NEED WORKFORCE WE NEED
RESOURCES. AND WE NEED. MUCH
HELP BUT POSSIBLE WITH BOTH OF
THOSE THINGS SHORT TERM AND
LONG TERM THE SAME GOES FOR
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH WHICH
AGAIN WOULD STRUGGLING TO
OPERATE UP IN A PHYSICAL
FISCALLY RESPONSIBLE WAY MANY
HAVE AN AFFRONT REVENUE TO
PROVIDE THE SERVICES WERE
FIGHTING. BUT HOPE IT. OKAY
ASHLEY. IDA AND RIDE DEPRESSION
IF COMING AS THEY SAID WE'VE
ALSO HAD TO THE PIVOT TO USE
TECHNOLOGY TO PROVIDE THE
SERVICES TO MUCH OF WHICH WE
HAD TO PURCHASE. OR BORROW AND
THEN THE PROVIDER NETWORK IS IN
GRAVE DANGER OF FALLING APART
AS MANY OF YOU ON THE COMMITTEE
HAVE NOTICED- LASTLY ON TELL
HIM- YOU KNOW WE'RE- AT THE- AT
THE POST. OF THE DELAYED TO
FUNDED BUT WE ARE JOINING OF
THE STATE AND ASKING IN THE
CONGRESS. ENGINE BOTH A LOT IF
TICKET WAIVER AND NINETEEN
FIFTEEN HE- SALINAS BOTH WAYS.
BUT PROVIDE CRITICAL FEDERAL
THE INTAKE HE IS AN PROVIDERS
INCLUDING PUBLIC. WHICH AS YOU
HEARD EARLIER RG CRITICAL RIGHT.
NOW AND THE WHOLE. RIGHT AT
INCOME EXTENDED AND THROUGH
TWENTY TWENTY AND- WHAT THE
STATE AND THAT WE'RE ALL LIKE
THE OFTEN LOBBY KAMBER HARD ON
THE THAT AN ONGOING FUND FOR
CAN PUBLIC AND ISSUES LAST THAT
YOU MENTION IS THE COUNTY
MEDICAL SERVICES PROGRAM WITHIN
THE MAY REVISION OF THE NUMBER
PROVIDE HEALTH WILL AND- ALSO
BEEN BOND TO COPE A HELP BILL
PROVIDERS BUT THE- GRANT. TO
RURAL PROVIDERS TO HELP THEM
KEEP WRITING DURING COVERED IN
WITH THE CURRENT THING AND WE
LOOK FOR TO WORKING WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION LEGISLATURE ON
THAT PROPOSAL TO FEED. TO
PRESERVE. THE WORK THEY'RE
DOING IN OUR- WE WERE WE OVER
BUT YOU UP FOR VERY
REQUIREMENTS THAT WE JUST CAN'T
NEEDS- SUCH AS PROVIDER RATE
SHOWS AGAIN THE PROVIDER
NETWORK IS IN DISARRAY AND
WE'RE GOING TO NEED HELP THE
BILL THAT BACK UP. I LASTLY
ALSO MAKE THE POINT THAT COUNTY
IS THE MINISTER THIS CRITICAL
PROGRAMS ON BEHALF OF THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AND EVERYBODY ALL
THE CALIFORNIANS SUFFERING
TODAY ARE THE ONES BEING HELPED
BY THE COUNTY ADMINISTERED
PROGRAM. WE FOR YOUR CHURCH
SURE THAT WE CAN. THE THIRD
THOSE WERE SERVING RIGHT NOW
AND THOUGH WE ANTICIPATE MAY
SUFFER OF THE EFFECT OF THE
CRACK THE INDOOR. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MOM AN- OPERATOR
PLEASE GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. EIGHTY NINE GO AHEAD
PLEASE. I THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THIS IS AND THE ONLY WITH THE
SAN FRANCISCO AIDS FOUNDATION
THE END THE EPIDEMIC COALITION.
CALIFORNIA APPETITE IS ALLIANCE
AND THE CALIFORNIA HIV ALLIANCE.
AND I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT AND ALSO
FOR CREATING THE SPACE FOR WHAT
HAS BEEN REALLY COMPELLING AND
MOVING COMMENTS THIS MORNING-
AND WE JOIN OUR COLLEAGUES
URGING YOU TO OPPOSE CRITICAL
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICE. CUTS
NOW WE FOCUS ON PUBLIC HEALTH.
AND AGAIN WE REALLY APPRECIATE
I REALLY APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS WE HEARD ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
SOMEONE SAID RECENTLY THAT
PUBLIC HEALTH IS HONORING. OF
OUR INTERDEPENDENCE AND WE
APPRECIATE HOW SERIOUSLY THE-
COMMITTEE TAKING THAT. AND THE
UNDERSTANDING THAT BEEN CLEAR
THE PUBLIC HEALTH ENTERED THIS
EPIDEMIC. WE UNDER FUNDED AND
WE ARE NOW INCREASINGLY STRANGE
BY ADDRESSING HOPE IT NINETEEN.
SO AS WE ADDRESS AS WE STRUGGLE
TO ADDRESS THE CODE NINETEEN
PANDEMIC WE CAN'T AFFORD TO
PULL BACK ON ADDRESSING THE
OTHER THEORIES THAT THE DAMAGE
THE CALIFORNIA FACING INCLUDING
HIV HEPATITIS B. AND AT BECAUSE
IF WE DO THAT IT ONLY
DECREASES. IT INCREASES THE
DISPARITIES THAT WE CURRENTLY
HAVE IN CALIFORNIA AND AS MANY
AT THAT IT'S ASKING. THE MOST
VULNERABLE TO SEPARATE THEM OUT
AGAIN THE ALL OF THESE
EPIDEMICS ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECT ON.
THE MOST VULNERABLE CALIFORNIA.
SO WE CRAFTED FOR PRIORITIES
THAT WE WANT TO LIST AND WE
CRAFTED THEM WITH THIS CRISIS
LINE WERE REALLY ASKING FOR
WHAT IS THE MOST MINIMAL JUST.
SO THAT WE CAN NOT. REALLY
GROUND IN ADDRESSING THAT THE
TENANT. THE FIRST ISSUE IS THAT
THE FOR PRIOR IS. TO MAINTAIN
THE CURRENT INVESTMENT IN HIV
HEPATITIS C. AND AT THE SERVICE
THAT WE REALLY APPRECIATE THAT
LAST YEAR ON SMALL INVESTMENT
FRANK WAS LEFT IN PLACE IN THE
NAY REVISED AND JUST WANT TO
POINT OUT THAT WE- REMAIN HERE
THREE UNDERFUNDED HAVE NOT YET
REACHED A LEVEL. OF FUNDING
THAT WE HAD PRIOR TO THE TWO
THOUSAND NINE CUTS. ON AND THE
ONLY EXCEPTION IS IN HEPATITIS
B. WHERE THEY'RE ACTUALLY WAS
NO INVESTMENT THAN TO CUT. SO
WE REMAIN REALLY UNDERFUNDED
BUT WE APPRECIATE VERY MUCH ON
THE RETENTION OF THAT SMALL
AMOUNT OF FUNDING FROM LAST
YEAR. I'M NOT PRIORITY NUMBER
TWO IS THAT WE URGE YOU TO
REJECT THE NAY REVISION
PROPOSAL TO TAKE A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS IN WHAT'S
CALLED THE LOAN FROM THE AIDS
DRUG ASSISTANCE PROGRAM REBATE
FUND. A THAT IS THE BACKBONE OF
OUR STATE EFFORT TO KEEP PEOPLE
WITH HIV IN THOSE AT RISK HIV
AND NECESSARY CARE WITH ACCESS
TO TREATMENT. THE REBATE FUND
ALLOWS A THAT AND THE CREE
EXPOSURE PROPHYLAXIS ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM TO ALL WHO NEED IT WITH
ABSOLUTELY NOTE STATE GENERAL
FUND CURRENT LAW REQUIRES THAT
THE REBATE DOLLARS BE USED
EXCLUSIVELY. FOR A THAT
SERVICES AND WE'D BE NO
GUARANTEE IN THE PROPOSAL THAT.
LOAN WILL BE RETURNED OR THAT
THERE WON'T BE MORE IN QUOTE
AGAIN LOANS THAT ONE BECAUSE
THAT WILL BE TAKING THE FUTURE.
WE DO THINK THAT FUNDING RIGHT
NOW AS PEOPLE ARE IN FINANCIAL
CRISIS AND LOSING JOBS AND
HEALTHCARE COVERAGE IS. REALLY
IRRESPONSIBLE. I'M PRIORITY
NUMBER THREE IS TO INCREASE
INVESTMENT IN CALIFORNIA THE
RANGE EXCHANGE BY CLEARING
HOUSE WERE ASKING FOR A VERY
SMALL INVESTMENT OF THREE
MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY.
CALIFORNIA THE RANGE SERVICE
PROGRAM DISTRIBUTE CRITICAL
COMPLIES INCLUDING COVERED
NINETEEN SUPPLIES SUCH AS
PERSONAL ON PROTECTION
EQUIPMENT TO PEOPLE WHO USE
DRUGS. CRITICALLY IMPORTANT
THERE OFTEN THE ONLY WELCOME
THREE POINT OF HEALTH CARE
CONTACT FOR SOME OF THE MOST
VULNERABLE CALIFORNIANS. THE
HOUSE WOULD NOT BEEN ABLE TO
KEEP PACE WITH THE MANTA AND
LEFT THE- PROGRAMS WITHOUT THE
CENTRAL PLOT. SO SINCE THE
CLEARING HOUSE WITH THE
FABULIST SIXTEEN NEW RANCH
CORPORATE SITE HAVE BEEN
AUTHORIZED IN FOR MORE EXPECTED
TO BE AUTHORIZED IN TWENTY
TWENTY. AND THE PENSIONER
FOCUSED ON HIGH RISK FOR ALL
COUNTY. THE CURRENT CLEARING
HOUSE BUDGET THREE MILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY WITH ALREADY
INADEQUATE. AND NOW COLBERT
NINETEEN HAS MADE IT HAS
INCREASED THE DEMAND FOR
SUPPLIES. SO WE UNDERSTAND HOW
CHALLENGING THIS FISCAL TIENEN.
AND FEEL THIS IS A REALLY SMALL
INVESTMENT THAT URGENT URGENTLY
NEEDED TO ENSURE THAT WE-
CONTINUE THESE LIFESAVING
SERVICES AND THE CONNECTION
OTHER HEALTHCARE. OUR LAST
PRIORITY IS THAT WE URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER
FINANCIAL SUPPORT FOR-
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
THAT ARE BURBANK WHAT I'D BE
HAPPY TO BE AND AS- EASE. AS
YOU CAN ACCORDING OTHER
NONPROFIT NONPROFIT ENTITIES.
ON OUR COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS THAT SHE NO
PLAYED A CRITICAL ROLE IN THE
PUBLIC HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE
BECAUSE THEY ARE ABLE TO REACH
OUT TO VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES
AND INDIVIDUALS. WHO OTHER
PEOPLE MAY NOT BE ABLE TO REACH
OUT TO. ONLY NAY OR DON'T TAX
TO. NO HEALTHCARE SYSTEM. A LOT
OF CBO AS WITH SO MANY OTHER
ENTITIES THAT BLOCKS FUNDING
BECAUSE OF COVERT NINETEEN AND
ARE REALLY STRUGGLING TO
RESPOND TO COPE IN NINETEEN AND
ALSO AT THE SAME TIME. THE
ACTUAL H. D. H. B. AND AT HER
BECAUSE- SO WE RECENTLY DID A
SURVEY WITH ON OUR COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS AND EVEN
THOUGH MANY OF THAT HAVE
APPLIED FOR ADDITIONAL FUNDING.
IT'S STILL GOING TO BE YOU KNOW
VERY ITS RESOURCES THAT ARE
AVAILABLE THE COURT IS STILL
GOING TO BE AN ADEQUATE TO
MAINTAIN EXISTING SERVICES.
EVEN WITH IT PEOPLE ARE ABLE TO
ACCESS THE FUNDING
OPPORTUNITIES. 66% OF SURVEY
RESPONDENTS RESPOND HERS
ANTICIPATED BEING ADDITIONAL
FUNDING TO CHANGE. AND THAT THE
OVERALL NOW WITH THE PROXIMITY
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS ACROSS
THE ON. OUR KIDS ARE BY
RESPONDED WITHOUT ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES 40% OF THE COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS ARE GOING
TO BE REQUIRED TO FURTHER
REDUCE SERVICES 17% WILL HAVE
TO FURLOUGH STAFF 21% WILL BE
REQUIRED TO LAY OFF YEAH THIS
IS ALSO THE CONTACT THAT MANY
PEOPLE ARE BEING RE DIRECT TO
THE FIGHT AGAINST KOBE EIGHTEEN
MANY. STAFF SO WE WOULD ASK AS
YOU CONSIDER- COVERED NINETEEN
ECONOMIC RELIEF PACKAGES.
REALLY URGING YOU TO CONSIDER
FINANCIAL SUPPORT THE TYPICALLY
FOR COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE HIV.
HURT PEOPLE WITH HIV HEPATITIS
C. AND AT TD. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU MA'AM AND-
OPERATOR BEFORE WE GO TO THE
NEXT CALL I MADE JUST. REMIND
EVERYONE WE HAVE A HARD STOP AT
TWO PM TODAY AS THERE IS A
COMMITTEE MEETING IN THIS ROOM
AFTERWARDS AND SINCE WE HAVE
STILL FORTY PEOPLE IN Q. I
WOULD JUST ASK THAT WE TRY TO
KEEP OUR COMMENTS BRIEF. WE ARE
HAPPY TO RECEIVE PUBLIC COMMENT
IN WRITING- THROUGH THE
SUBCOMMITTEE AND WITH THAT
OPERATOR IF YOU CAN GO TO THE
NEXT CALLER ON THE LINE. LINE
TWENTY PARDON ME LINE ONE
TWENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS ON THIS IS
BARB REPLACE IT WITH A
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL IS THAT THE
ASIAN. NO QUESTION CALIFORNIA'S
EIGHTY ONE OF THE MOST
CHALLENGING BUT YEARS THIS
STATE HAS EVER SEEN. AT THE
BUDGET IS A REFLECTION OF THE
STATE VALUES AND PRIORITIES
EVEN DURING DEVASTATING
ECONOMIC TIMES WHEN THE STATE
IS WORKING HARD TO RETURN MANY
SECTORS OF OUR ECONOMY TO A
MORE NORMAL ACTIVITY. IT'S A
VITAL HOSPITAL. AIN'T OPEN
STAFF READY FOR THE STATE'S
ONGOING COLBERT NINETEEN
RESPONSE. BUDGET REVISION
EXCLUDES CRITICAL FUNDING THAT
HOSPITALS HAVE BEEN SEEKING NOT
ONLY DOES THE GOVERNOR'S NEWLY
REVISED FAILED TO INCLUDE A
MUCH NEEDED FINANCIAL LIFELINE
FOR HOSPITAL FEELING WITH THE
CO THE NINETEEN CRISIS. BUT
THERE ARE ALSO SIGNIFICANT
PAYMENT REDUCTIONS FOR
HOSPITALS INCLUDED IN THE
PROPOSAL AS PART OF MEDI CAL
MANAGED CARE VISION THING. THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES EFFECTIVE JANUARY
FIRST OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE IS
PROPOSING TO IMPLEMENT A NEW
DIRECTED PAYMENT PROGRAM THAT
TARGET EIGHT INPATIENT SERVICE
BETWEEN BIRTH MEANT FOR PRIVATE
IN DISTRICT HOSPITAL. WHICH IS
NEARLY ALL HOSPITALS IN THE
STATE. IS MANAGED KERRY FISSION
NEEDS ARE EXPECTED TO AMOUNT TO
TENS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND. AND POTENTIALLY
HUNDREDS OF MILLION IN TOTAL
FUND SAVINGS FOR THE STATE.
MOST. OF WHICH- I'M RATE
REDUCTION TO HOT. SHE L. THAT
YOU REGION THAT PROPOSAL WHAT
CALIFORNIANS HOT RECOGNIZE THE
CHOICES FACING LEADERS HOSPITAL
CANNOT SUSTAIN ANYMORE
REDUCTION IN REVENUES. DUE TO
THE PANDEMIC HOSPITAL STAY
SHORT TERM LOSSES FROM TEN
BILLION DOLLARS TO FOURTEEN.
IT'LL BE ACROSS THE STATE
ANSWERED THE CALL TO RESPOND IN
THIS UNPRECEDENTED CRIED BUT
WITHOUT AN IMMEDIATE INFUSION
OF RESOURCES MANY WILL REMAIN.
FINANCIAL JEOPARDY. THANK YOU
MEMBERS FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
OF THIS AS AN FOR TODAY'S
HEARING WHERE YOU HAVE POINTED
OUT JUST HOW DEVASTATING THESE
NUMEROUS REDUCTIONS IN HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES WILL BE FAR
MOST VULNERABLE. THANK YOU MISS
GLAZER WITHOUT OPERATOR CAN GO
TO THE NEXT COLOR. NINE FIFTY
GO AHEAD PLACE. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ARAMBULA AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MY NAME IS KRISTEN HEY MAN AND
I'M THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA BEACHES RIGHT
DON'T THEY- THE- THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH
YOU TODAY. AND THANK YOU TO THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS SPOKE IN THE
MORNING AS PART OF OUR
COMMUNITY BASED SERVICES.
YOU'RE STILL VERY APPRECIATIVE.
I WANT TO I WANTED TO EXPRESS
TODAY THANK. HEARING ON MEDI
CAL BUT WE DO NOT SUPPORT
ALTHOUGH THE NAY REVISIONS TO
ELIMINATE IT DON'T THEY
HEALTHCARE PROGRAM. IN THE
MULTI PURPOSE SENIOR SERVICES
PROGRAM OFTEN IN THE SENSE THAT
HE BY JULY FIRST OF THE YEAR
AND WE ARE ASKING THAT THE
COMMITTEE REJECT THE PROPOSED
CUTS. SIMILAR TO THE BACK AND
THE TWENTY THIRD FRAIL OLDER
ADULTS. AND ALLOW THESE
INDIVIDUALS TO CONTINUE TO STAY
IN THE COMMUNITY RATHER THAN IN
INSTITUTIONS. THEIR CLIENTS ARE
CERTIFIED ELIGIBLE FOR SKILLED
NURSING HOME PLACEMENT WHICH IS
AN INDICATION OF FROM HEALTH.
AND THE KEY IS A PROVEN COST
EFFECTIVE BOTTLE OF CARE. IN
THE ELIMINATION OF THIS PROGRAM
WILL RESULT IN INCREASED
NURSING HOME PLACEMENT AT A
GREATER COST OF THE STATE.
REGARDING AT THE EIGHTY EIGHT.
RIGHT AS I NOTED YESTERDAY IN
THE HUMAN SERVICES. AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE CALL THE
NINETEEN CAN'T THAT MAKE
GOVERNOR NEW SEVENTEEN ARE ADHD
BACK PROGRAM AT THE RESIDENTIAL
SERVICE BECAUSE THE PROTECT THE
VERY PEOPLE WHO ARE AT RISK
FROM CO THAT NINETEEN. YOU TO
THEIR AGE AN UNDERLYING HEALTH
CONDITION. SINCE THE ISSUE THIS
MARCH NINETEENTH EXECUTIVE
ORDER. OUR MEMBERS AND OUR
LEADERSHIP HAD THE WORKING
CLOSELY WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION. IN IRAQ THE
DESIGN OF A CONTINUED. SERVICE
TO ARE YOU THAT PROTECTANT
THREE NEW TEMPORARY ALTERNATIVE
THE AUTO CLUB PATH. AND WE
CERTAINLY APPRECIATED THEIR
SUPPORT AND PARTNERSHIP. OUR
SERVICE IS THAT NOT ONLY HELP
TO KEEP OUR PROTECT. AND THEIR
FAMILIES THINK BECAUSE THE
NINETEEN. BUT OUR SERVICES HAVE
ALSO HELPED MAINTAIN OUR
PARTICIPANTS HEALTH STATUS. AN
ADDITIONAL DRAFTED ISOLATION
AND MOST IMPORTANTLY REDUCE THE
POTENTIAL FOR PEOPLE TURKEY
PREMATURE INSTITUTIONALIZATION.
TODAY WE ARE ASKING FOR A
CLARIFICATION ON THE DATE WHEN
THE EIGHTY EIGHT THE BACK
PROGRAM IS SCHEDULED TO BE
ELIMINATED AND WE ARE
REQUESTING THAT THE COMMITTEE
THE APPLICATION ON THE ISSUE.
RIGHT WHAT IS STATED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S NEWLY REVISED
SUMMARY. WHICH DOES THAT THE
EIGHTY EIGHT THE FEEDBACK FROM
THE NATION OF WILL TAKE EFFECT
THE END OF TWENTY TWENTY. BUT
WE HEARD LAST NIGHT THAT THE
DATE TO ELIMINATE THE PROGRAM
IS ACTUALLY EFFECTIVE JULY
FIRST. THIS WOULD LEAD THE VERY
PEOPLE WHO ARE MOST VULNERABLE
TO COPE IT WITHOUT OUR
SERVICES. I WON A POSSIBLE
SECOND SEARCH THE CURRENT.
LIMITING THE EIGHTY EIGHT EIGHT
FEEDBACK PROGRAM IN THE END OF
THE PROGRAM. AND REDUCING THE
FUNDING TO THE CARE GIVER
RESOURCE CENTERS ACROSS THE
STATE MORE MONEY IN THE LONG
RUN. IT WILL LEAVE THE VERY
PEOPLE THAT THE GOVERNOR IS
WANTING TO PROTECT WITHOUT THE
RESOURCES THAT THEY NEED. WE
ALSO URGE THE COMMITTEE TO
REJECT A PROPOSAL TO ELIMINATE
OUR HOME COMMUNITY. SAFETY NET
PROGRAM WE ARE READY TO PARTNER
WITH THE LEGISLATURE AND
ADMINISTRATION TO WORK ON A
REASONABLE SOLUTION TO SAVE OUR
SENIORS AND PEOPLE WITH ALL
THESE TOGETHER. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU MISS
HAMMOND. OPERATE WE PLEASE MOVE
ON TO THE NEXT CALLER. NINE ONE
FIFTY FOUR GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
UNDER OUR PARTY WITH A
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF COMMUNITY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AGENCIES I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR WITH
YOUR COMMENTS AND YOUR CONCERNS
ABOUT THE IMPACT OF THE BUDGET
ON THE SAFETY NET THE TERM. THE
IMPACT THAT WOULD HAVE
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
HAVE BEEN PROFOUND AND IS
GROWING OUR PROVIDERS REPRESENT
OVER FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
CALIFORNIA UPPER FROM A MENTAL
HEALTH OR SUBSTANCE ABUSE
DISORDER AND PROVIDER TYPE OF
ENCOUNTERED THINGS SUCH AS THE
LACK OF PREVENT PROTECTIVE A
QUICK. AFTER WRAPPING AND
OFFICE AND IT'S AND AN
ADDITIONAL CBO CONTINUE TO HAVE
PROBLEMS PROVIDING CARE AND
CONGREGATE CARE SETTING AND
KEEPING TRACK OF CLIENTS WHO
ARE HOMELESS OR HAVE NO ACCESS
TO TECHNOLOGY IF WE DON'T
ACCEPT NOW TO A THAT THE- OF
THE TIME BY IT. ALL FUN AND
LOOKING STATE HUNT WE CAN
MILLIONS OF INDIVIDUALS WITH
MENTAL ILLNESS AND ADDICTION TO
ARRIVE IN OVER TO ACT EMERGENCY.
DEPARTMENTS ACROSS WITH. AFTER
TEN DEMOCRATIC OVER THE TWO
THAT THE- IS TAKEN OFF THE BE
GAVE HER HOPE THAT MAKE. WILL
INCREASE AND THIS CALL ALSO
HURT THE ON OUR MEMBERS. TO
PROVIDE CARE. IN ORDER TO
BOLSTER THE SYSTEM NEED TO BE.
I THE THING THAT AVAILABLE THE
SAFETY NET AND FOR NOW BY IN
EMERGENCY FUNDS INTO COUNTY AND
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
TO PRESERVE MADE IT THERE BUT
THAT. THANK YOU FOR THE TIME TO
SHARE COMMENT ON BEHALF OF CBJ
MEMBERS. THANK YOU MA'AM
OPERATOR CAN WE PLEASE HAVE THE
NEXT COLOR. LINE ONE FIFTY
EIGHT GO AHEAD. THIS IS REBECCA
GONZALEZ I'M WITH THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER AND I WILL
BE FREE I DO WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE YOUR COMMENTS ON
PROTECTING THE MOST VULNERABLE
CALIFORNIANS I TRULY BELIEVE
YOU ARE TRYING TO PROTECT AS
MANY PEOPLE AS POSSIBLE. I'M
GETTING IT HEALTH CARE CRISIS
WE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT PAT BUT
TARGET SENIOR WITH MANY PEOPLE
HAVE ALREADY MENTIONED THAT
AFFECTS OF LIMITING THE MEDI
CAL EIGHT BLINDED FABLED INCOME
LEVEL EXPANSION ALSO OPPOSED
THREE. IF YOU WERE. WILL BE AT
RECOVERY PRO WHICH IS THE- FOR
TO COVERAGE. LA PREVIOUS
SPEAKERS WE ALSO OPPOSE AT THE
END THAT THAT HE AND THE BASS.
AND WILL ALSO WAS MENTIONED
ABOUT THE BLACK INTENT HEALTH
PROGRAM THAT. BUT THE MEDIC COW
OPTIONAL BENEFIT IS ESPECIALLY
PAINFUL AT THE- BELL LONG TERM
RAN. THE SERVICES ONE BY ONE.
AND THEY ARE VITAL SERVICES
EVER ALSO VERY CONCERNED ABOUT
METAL NEEDS WHICH WE KNOW WILL
BE INCREASE DURING THE QUITE
THE AND- SERVICES NEED TO BE
SUPPORT LASTLY BUT- GOOD BUT-
THAT. BROUGHT THE NEAR BUT- RON
IS BYRON IS IN. NOT AND GO ON
EMIGRATE STATUS AND AT THAT
SOMETHING THAT PUTS OUR
COMMUNITY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
GONZALEZ OPERATOR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. LINE ONE THREE FIVE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME JOANNE AND
THE COMMAND BILL IN TWO MORE
MANAGER AT THAT HERMAN COLORS
BASED OAKLAND CA. AND ALSO PUT
IT AND EPIDEMIC COALITION AND
TRY WON'T WORK A LOT THAT MY
COLLEAGUES AND OVER REALLY GLAD
BUT MAY REVISE MANGE LEVEL. FOR
INCLUDING STRANGE ACCESS
PROGRAMS IN THIS MOMENT BECAUSE
OF THEIR UNIQUE CALL TO SERVE
AT RISK AND HARD TO REACH
CALIFORNIANS A SMALL INVESTMENT
OF THREE MILLION DOLLARS IT
URGENTLY NEEDED TO ENSURE AT
THE BEING CERTAIN SERVICE
PROGRAMS CAN CAN CONTINUE
PROVIDING THEIR ESSENTIAL PART
REPRESENTS A HUNDRED PERCENT OF
THE MONEY WOULD GO. TO
PREVENTION AS WELL IN FACT THE
ONLY WELCOME THERE OFTEN THE
ONLY WELCOMING POINT OF CONTACT
FOR PEOPLE WHO USE DRUGS TO
HELP. PRINT HEALTHCARE RELEASE.
NUMBER JUST BE ROOMS AND COMING
SAFE. PANDEMIC I'VE BEEN IN
TOUCH WITH. OF PROGRAMS THE
STATE. AND THEY THINK ALL DAY
THE ONES HELLO AND HOW PARK IF
YOU WHAT COOL BUT IS. GIVING
UPDATES TO WHO DON'T HAVE
INTERNET ENABLED DEVICES AND
ASSURING ME ENSURING THEY HAVE
HYGIENE EQUIPMENT AND
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT. WE KNOW
WE KNOW. CAN OPEN EARLY IN THE
H. HAVE AN FTP. WE ALSO KNEW TO
ENSURE USE DISORDER TREATMENT
IS MAINTAINED OUR RAMPED UP AT
THIS TIME AT TEN OF ISOLATION
AND ECONOMIC DESPAIR DRUG USE
DOES NOT DISAPPEAR BUT
INCREASES TO ARGUE TO MAINTAIN
THAT CANNOT OUR INVESTMENT FOR
THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PILOT
PROGRAM THAT FUND SUBSTANCE USE
THAT THERE'S AN EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENT. OF THE REDUCTION
FROM TWENTY MILLION THAT WAS A
IN THE JANUARY BUDGET AND LET'S
CUT BUT BY MAINTAINING A TEN
MILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT BUT
TWO HUNDRED HOSPITALS WHO'VE
ALREADY APPLIED AND ARE THE
FROM THE SPA. WILL BE A LOT
HIGHER TO A AND INTO A WORLD OF
SUBSTANCE USE NEVER. THIS IS
THE SIX PILOT PROJECT THAT WE
ENDED OUR LOW THRESHOLD NETWORK
OF. IN CALIFORNIA WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THERE ENTRY POINT FOR
P. INJURED. AND TAKE CARE FOR
EACH A. B. FOR. H. TV AN FQDN
COMMUNITY BASED LOCATION IN A
HOSPITAL. AND WE'RE URGING YOU
TO MAINTAIN THAT IN THE FINAL
BUDGET IN JUNE THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU MISTER O'NEILL
OPERATOR OUR NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
LINE ONE SIXTY ONE GO AHEAD
PLEASE. SHE THANK YOU- MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THIS IS RANDALL ACRE
FOR THE CALIFORNIA PSYCHIATRIC
ASSOCIATION- I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR HAVING THIS HEARING- I
WANT TO THANK ALL THE PEOPLE
WHO'VE APPLICATIVE FOR HEALTH
ISSUES- THIS IS AN
EXTRAORDINARY TIME AND WE'RE
GONNA BE FACING EXTRAORDINARY
CHALLENGES. JUST ONE OF THE
FOCUS YOU ON ONE ISSUE IN
PARTICULAR AND I WANTED TO
THANK KELLY BOMB SO BEFORE-
FROM MY EARLY OPENING THE DOOR
UP HERE. BOB SIXTY THREE LONG
CANCER SCARE TO BE LET. AND I
HAVE- SOME FIGURES HERE. THAT
THAT TELL ME THAT THEY HAVE
BEEN EXTRAORDINARILY IMPORTANT
TO COMMUNITIES AS AS PHYSICIANS
WHO ARE RECIPIENTS OF THOSE
BONDS. HAVE GOTTEN OUT IN THE
FIRST CHO CHO QUIRK LAST YEAR.
DIETERS NOT GETTING HELP YOU
OUT IT IS A- IT HURTS TO HEAR
ON THIS. MR HAGER YOUR INTERNAL
ORGANS WANT TO LOSE HER LIFE
OUR SCHEDULE MILLION THE
NATION- AS MISTER WHAT-
COMMENTED- THERE'S NOT A PARTS
HERE- THIS IS A FLAT OUT
ELIMINATION AS WE SPEAK FIFTY
NINE. AT ARE ACTUALLY. HOLDING
PATTERN THE READY I AM THAT
MATCH TO. SENATE AND THERE ARE
GOING TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE A
SERVICE TO. COMMUNITIES AROUND
THE STATE THIS PROGRAM. YEAH
THAT'S ABOUT IT. FOR BUT HE.
BUT I THINK SHE US. YOUR
EDUCATION THIS ISSUE AND THE
SITE. WILL FOR YOU TO REJECT.
THANK YOU MR HAGAR AND I WOULD
ENCOURAGE TO HAVE YOU FOLLOW UP
WITH WRITTEN COMMENTS ON THAT-
FOR THE PEOPLE WHO ARE CALLING
IN I WOULD JUST REMIND YOU OR
ENCOURAGE YOU TO MUTE YOUR
DEVICE. AS IT MAY HELP TO
ELIMINATE SOME OF THE ECHO THAT
WE ARE HEARING WITH THAT
OPERATOR CAN WE MOVE ON TO OUR
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NINE ONE
SEVENTY FOUR GO AHEAD PLEASE.
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES MA'AM.
DOCTOR ARAMBULA AND MEMBERS OF
THE SUBCOMMITTEE MY NAME IS
WENDY **** AND I WORK FOR
HAPPILY SYCAMORE. A NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION BASED IN LOS
ANGELES CALIFORNIA. TRACK YOUR
AGENCY WE PROVIDE CRITICAL
MENTAL HEALTH CARE CHILD
WELFARE PROGRAMS SCHOOL BASED
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES AND
HOUSING SUPPORT AND IMPACT THE
LIVES OF APPROXIMATELY FOURTEEN
THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS ANNUALLY.
THE BROADER IMPACTS OF KEVIN
NINETEEN AS OTHERS HAVE ALREADY
STATED ON THE MENTAL HEALTH.
AND WHILE BEING A CALIFORNIA'S
IS SIMPLY UNPARALLELED WE
CERTAINLY RECOGNIZE THE
LEADERSHIP OF THE GOVERNOR AND
THE LEGISLATURE IN NAVIGATING.
IMMENSELY CHALLENGING BUDGET
SITUATION. THE URGENCY TO
SECURE SIGNIFICANT ADDITIONAL
FEDERAL FUNDS IS CLEAR
THROUGHOUT THE MAY REVISED AS
WELL AS- THROUGH THE REMARK BY
THE GOVERNOR WHICH WE STRONGLY
ENDORSE AND WILL CONTINUE TO
CHAMPION FOR THESE FUNDS WITH
CONGRESSIONAL LEADERS. ON
CURRENTLY CALIFORNIA MUST BE
CLEAR AND OUR STATE COMMITMENT
TO PROTECT. A BIG ROLE HEALTH
SAFETY NET THAT EXTREME REST
YOU TO THE STATE ECONOMIC
RECESSION. AND BECAUSE OF WHAT
WE ARE SEEING AS A DRAMATIC
RISE IN THE NEED FOR MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES. WITH THE
PROJECTED DECLINE IN OUR
REVENUE SOURCES THAT BIND OUR
SYSTEM CARE. IN NINETEEN NINETY
ONE REALIGNMENT. TWO THOUSAND
AND ELEVEN REALIGNMENT AND MAKE
IT SAY HAPPILY SYCAMORES AND
OTHER COMMUNITY MENTAL HEALTH
ORGANIZATIONS. THAT ARE THE
ESSENTIAL SAFETY NET. FOR
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES. HAVE TO
FACE DIFFICULT DECISIONS LIKE
REDUCING CRITICAL STAFFING ARE
LAYING OFF STAFF. IF THERE IS
NO BACK BILL TO BE REVENUE
SOURCES. TO HELP THE STATE AND
LOCAL COUNTIES PRESERVES THE
LOCAL SAFETY NET PROGRAMS. AT
THE TIME THAT OTHER HAVE
ALREADY ON BUT WE ARE
ANTICIPATING THE OVERWHELMING
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH NEEDS THAT WE-
ALL THREE COMING. MORE WE URGE
THE LEGISLATURE TO WIN BACK
BENDING THE STATE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC BEHAVIOR HEALTH SYSTEM
THANK YOU FOR HOLDING THESE
COMMITTEE HEARINGS AND
LISTENING TO THE CONCERNS AND
FEEDBACK FROM STAKEHOLDERS.
THANK YOU MA'AM. OPERATOR CAN
WE HAVE THE NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
IT WILL BE LINE ONE FORTY NINE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS BENEFITING ON BEHALF OF
BEEN A FAMILY PARTNERSHIP OF
THE COMMENTED YESTERDAY AND
WITH THAT WOULD BE HUMAN
SERVICES. BUT AND ABOUT THE
WHOLE PROPOSAL BUT ONE IN
NEIGHBORHOOD. IN PARTICULAR
WOULD BE CUT IN FUNDING THE
BLACK AND HEALTH PROGRAM THE
CUTTING OF FUNDING AND THE
POLICY ON THE TUNNEL MENTAL
HEALTH WHICH WE'VE GOTTEN
PASSED LAST YEAR. AND THEN WE
WOULD ALL HER COMMENT WITH OUR
PUBLIC HEALTH COLLEAGUES ANY OF
HER INVESTMENT IN THE STATE
PUBLIC INFRASTRUCTURE. I THINK
ONE OF OVER GAMES OF THIS
HEARING HAS BEEN NOT FITTING IN
PLACES WHERE THERE ARE ACTUALLY
SEVERAL NOTCHES ON THE- THAT.
WE HAVE BEEN ASKED. THANK WAYS
THE- THAT CAN RIGHT. AND EVERY
AT THE BY THIS AND KILLER THE
MOST. WE DON'T AS MANY CONTACT
POINT THAT BY AT AND SOCIAL
ISOLATION AS WE JUST HAPPENED.
THAT'S WHAT. YEAH SAM HERSHEY
THE OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT IN
THE HEARING AND YOU HAVE A SEAT
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISS COULD
HE NOT. I NEXT CALL PLEASE.
PINE ONE SEVENTY SO GO AHEAD
PLEASE. HELLO THANK YOU THE
OPPORTUNITY TO THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TODAY MY NAME IS JOHN
BLUE AN EXACT DIRECTOR HEALTH
CENTER AROUND THE DEL MARK CARE
GIVER RESOURCE. THEN THE SENATE
COULD THEN MODERATE
MULTIPURPOSE SENIOR SERVICES
PROGRAM. I DO WANT TO APPLAUD
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS WITH.
RECOGNIZE THAT DISMANTLING THE
PROGRAM TO KEEP PEOPLE SAFE AT
HOME KEEP THEM FOR MORE BOND
WILL BE NEAR THE DISABLED SAFE
AT HOME. ARE NOT PROGRAMS THAT
NEED TO BE CUT DURING THE COLD
BUT NINETEEN CRISIS. THE CARE
GIVER RESOURCE CENTERS SUPPORT
FAMILIES TO KEEP THEIR WORK
WITH. AT THAT HOME DURING A
TIME WHEN THERE. LACKEY
RESOURCES WHEN IN FACILITY CAN
RESULT IN DEATH. IN NOT THE WAY
YOU WANT TO BE TREATING OUR
MOST VULNERABLE I APPLAUD YOU
FOR RECOGNIZING THAT I HEARD
THAT BUT HE DIED. I'LL LOOK
DIDN'T CALL THE SAY THAT PLEASE
SUPPORT THE PROGRAM TO KEEP
PEOPLE AT HOME. PLEASE SUPPORT
CONTINUE SERVICES PROGRAM
FEEDBACK ESPECIALLY THE CARE
GIVER RESOURCE CENTER. IT WILL
SUPPORT THE MOST VULNERABLE
RETAINING THE ONE NOT ONLY.
CLEARLY THAT SUPPORT THE
HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE THAT IS
DOING THE VITAL WORK IF WE WERE
TO MAKE THE CUT THAT WERE ON
THE TABLE NOW BUT THE KEY
DEBATE PROGRAM. BOB THE WORKERS
WERE EXPERT KEEPING PEOPLE AT
HOME WOULD NO LONGER BE
EMPLOYED. IN WE DID MANAGE TO
GET FROM THAT WE SO DESPERATELY
NEED TODAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SIR AND- OPERATOR AS WE MOVE ON
TO THE NEXT CALLER I WOULD JUST
REMIND PEOPLE WE HAVE ROUGHLY
FIFTY PEOPLE REMAINING IN Q.
AND ABOUT A HUNDRED MINUTES
LEFT HERE. AND SO WE JUST ASK
THAT WE KEEP OUR COMMENTS AS
BRIEF AS POSSIBLE. OPERATOR
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. LINE EIGHTY
FIVE GO AHEAD PLEASE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS LINE
CENTER ON BEHALF OF BOTH THE
CALIFORNIA PUT AFTER MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION AND AMERICAN
COLEGE OF OBGYN STRYCHNINE
PERSONAL BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION THE P. MAY
BE QUESTION WE GET THE GOVERNOR
SUPPORT TO LIMIT THREE ASSN OPS
BENEFIT THE MAP SYSTEM SELECT
UP TEARS REINSTATE THE HAPPENED
JUST LAST YEAR THE COMPANY TO.
THE LANGUAGE OPPOSE THAT PART
HEALTH CARE SIR. THEIR NEW
COMPLETELY FROM STATUTES
PROVISION THAT OFF RIGHT TO THE
OPTION BENEFIT. THANK YOU
DOCTOR WOULD AND DR RANDALL
THREE COMMENTS BY HITTING THE
PAUSE BUTTON STRAIGHT
ELIMINATION SOMETHING I HOPE AT
THE VERY LEAST TO BE
CONSIDERED. ALSO THANK YOU DOT
WOULD BE STRONG STATEMENT
REGARDING BEFORE AND PURPOSE
COULD YOU AFTER. WHICH I'M NOT
ELABORATE TO FINALLY THING AT
THE TO GET THE GOVERNOR
PROPOSAL TO REDIRECT ONE POINT
TWO BILLION DOLLARS IMPROPER
PICNIC FUNDING. FOR ALL THE
REASONS MENTIONED BY MY CALL
FROM THE TWENTY MEDICAL.
ASSOCIATION FOR MORE ABOUT HALF
OF THE- OBG IS JUST NINETY
THANK YOU. THAT YOU. THE
REDIRECT PROPERTY SIX BUT TOP
OF THAT. CONDITIONALLY HALF THE
REJECT GOVERNMENT OF. TO LEARN
BOTH IN THE BY AND IN. THE
EXTENSIVE MAY BEEN STRUCK ONE
YEAR FOR POST PARTUM. DIE
WITHIN. MOTHER HELP DISORDER.
WHILE WE UNDERSTAND DOUBLE
DECISIONS WILL NEED TO BE MADE
TO ADDRESS THE STATE FISCAL
CHALLENGES. LIVING THAT BENEFIT
PARTICULARLY DURING THE MIDDLE
OF A PANDEMIC. EXTREMELY
PROBABLY AS A PROBLEM THE-
BILL. HEALTH ISSUES IS GROWING
WITH THE ADDED STRESS AND
ANXIETY DURING THE PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISIS. WITH EVEN MORE
TROUBLING IF THE COMPANY TRAVEL
BILL. COMPLETELY DELETE THE
AUTHORIZATION OF THE MEDI CAL
MITCHELL HELP. TO CATCH IT.
COMPLETELY JERRY. EVEN THOUGH
MATURE OF THE HEALTH. STUDENT
CAME LAW AND TWO NINETEEN L.
WOMEN NEVER. IT'S BEEN AT THE
PARCHMENT CONTINUES WITH THE
LATEST. IMPLEMENTATION DESPITE
FUNDING MADE A- TO THE BUDGET
TWENTY. ECARD WORK AT THE
PARTNERS TO EXPECTED LIMITATION
OF THE EXTENSION HOWEVER YOU
CAN EASILY TOLD COULD BE
DELAYED UNTIL JULY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY. NOW THE DEPARTMENT. IS
SUGGESTING THAT THE AUTHORS
EIGHT AUTHORIZATION BE REMOVED
FROM STATUTES HIGHLY. EVEN
THOUGH HEALTH GILSTRAP
ILLUSTRATED BY THE OWN PREVIOUS
ACTION. IF NOT DIRECTLY CAN
JUMP BUDGETARY FUNDING. FOR THE
WOMEN'S BASED IN MENTAL HEALTH
CHOOSE. ECARD STRONGLY OPPOSE
THE REDUCTION. POLICY AGE THANK
YOU AND THAN YOU TO ALL THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE WITH
AWFUL. AND CONSIDERATIONS. I
BROUGHT SOME PATAKI. THANK YOU.
MISS TURNED I WILL TO STAB MY
TO SEE I UP SAW YESTERDAY ON
WHO AND AN OF A LAY WHO HAD A
TO BORN DURING THE SPANISH FLU
AND I THINK IT'S AWFULLY
IMPORTANT FOR US DURING THIS
QUARANTINE TO BE FOCUSED ON
POST PARTUM MENTAL HEALTH AS
WELL AND SO DO AGREE WITH YOUR
COMMENTS OPERATE IF WE CAN MOVE
ON TO THE- CALLER PLEASE. I IN
SEVENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON THE FUTURE
MEMBERS CONNIE DELGADO- BEHALF
OF THE DISTRICT HOSPITAL
LEADERSHIP FORUM REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA THIRTY FIVE DISTRICT
THE MYTHICAL PUBLIC HOSPITAL IN
OPPOSITION TO THE PROPOSED A
PROPOSAL CONTAINED IN THE MAY
REVISE THAT REQUIRES ADJUSTMENT
FOR THE MEDI CAL MANAGED CARE
RIGHT. THE TECHNICAL HOSPITALS
ARE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
RESPONSIBLE FOR BY THE HEALTH
CARE TO THEIR COMMUNITY TWO
THIRDS OF THE CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT IF A HOSPITAL ARE
RURAL AND TWENTY HAVE CRITICAL
ACCENT DESIGNATION. BOB OUR
OPPOSE TO BOTH THE SHORT TERM
AND TERM OUTLINED IN THE MAY BE
FIVE LONG TERM PROPOSAL WILL
IMPOSE A MAXIMUM BE SCHEDULED
FOR MANAGED CARE CLAMORING
PERSON FOR INPATIENT HOSPITAL
SERVICES AT THE FOR SERVICE
EQUIVALENT IMPOSING ACTUALLY
FOR HOSPITAL DOES NOT ALLOW FOR
MANAGED CARE PLANS TO GO SHE
ATE WITH PROVIDERS TO ENSURE
THEY HAVE ADEQUATE NETWORK IN
PLACE. NETWORKS INCLUDE LITTLE
HOSPITAL JERRY CAN YOUR
HOSPITAL THE PROVIDE SPECIFIC
SPECIALTY BUT WITH THE- CAN.
DISTRICT MUNICIPAL HA STOOD
WITH. AND FOR AND PROVIDING
CARE TO PATIENTS DURING THE
CURRENT PRESIDENT HI. BASS
THIRDS CAPACITY TO PREPARE FOR
COMBAT. NINETEEN PATIENTS BY
THE DIRECT DEVASTATING IMPACT
ON THE BOTTOM LINE. RECOVERING
FROM THE TIME DEMOCRATIC
SIGNIFICANT TIME. AND REQUIRE
REPORTS OF TO INSURE THAT THESE
HOSPITALS ARE ABLE TO PROVIDE
SERVICES. WE ASK. THAT NOW IT'S
NOT BEEN HAVING TO REDUCE RATES
TO CALIFORNIA THE TRICK AND THE
HOSPITAL AND HE REJECTED
BECAUSE- THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MA'AM OPERATOR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. ONE SIXTY SEVEN
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS DOCTOR
A TINY I'M A PEDIATRIC DENTIST
AS WELL AS THE DENTAL
ANESTHESIOLOGIST OPERATIVE
DENTAL OFFICE THAT HAS ROUGHLY
TEN THOUSAND MEDICARE
BENEFICIARY QUIT MAJORITY OF
THEM ARE SPECIAL NEEDS.
CHILDREN AND ADULTS. OUR OFFICE
HAS APPROXIMATELY FIFTEEN
DENTAL AND DENTAL SPECIALISTS
OVER SEVENTEEN EMPLOYEES. IF
I'M NOT THE ONLY OFFICE
PROBABLY ONE OF THE VERY FEW
OFFICES WITH THIS MANY
SPECIALIST AND TALENTS UNDER
THE SAME ROOF. WORKING
EFFICIENTLY TO MANAGE DENTAL
NEEDS OF THIS POPULATION.
TRANSITION THIS POPULATION INTO
DANTICAT FEE FOR SERVICE IS A
MASSIVE MISTAKE- DANTICAT HAS
NEVER BEEN A PROGRAM THAT CAN
DELIVER AND HAS THE SAME ISSUES
WITH THE LIMITED ACCESS TO
PEDIATRIC AND GENERAL DENTAL
CARE. FOR EVER AND EXCHANGES
WITH A FROG WASTE AND ABUSE NOT
INCLUDING THEIR POOL
REIMBURSEMENT THEM AND I'M JUST
THE DENYING THE CLAIM FOR THE
WORK THAT HAS ALREADY BEEN
PERFORMED. MY TEAM AND I WILL
CLOSE OPERATION IF GMC PROGRAM
IS ELIMINATED WHICH WOULD LEAVE
THIS UNDER TO THEIR POPULATION
TO CREATE ELSE. WHICH MEANS
EVEN MORE LIMITED ACCESS TO
DENTAL CARE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. THANK YOU DOCTOR.
OPERATE NEXT CALLER PLEASE. BY
THE FOUR EIGHT GO AHEAD PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
MICHELLE GIVEN BUT THE COUNTY
HEALTH EXECUTIVE WITH THE
VISION OF CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTING LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS THROUGHOUT OUR
STATE I THINK YOU CHAIR MEMBER
RANDY LEFT FOR YOUR QUESTION
REGARDING INVESTMENT IN PUBLIC
HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE IN
RESPONSE I JUST WANT TO
UNDERSCORE THE DIRE IMPACT BUT
THE DECLINE IN NINETEEN NINETY
ONE A LINE THAT THEIR
PROGRAMMATIC CUTS HAVE ON OUR
HEALTH DEPARTMENT. WELL THE
NINETEEN AT A PUBLIC HEALTH
PANDEMIC IN OUR LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENT THEY'RE CARRYING OUT
ARE MANDATED RESPONSIBILITY TO
PROTECT OUR COMMUNITY WE URGE
THE LEGISLATURE TO BACK WELL A
LOT OF HEALTH REALIGNMENT
FUNDING AND THEN SHOW ONE
HUNDRED AND THREE MILLION TO.
BACK UP BY. YEAH IT. WELL HE
NINETY ONE BUT IT ESTIMATED TO
BE A HIGH AND FIFTY AT THREE IN
LAST FIFTY SLASH YEAR WHAT PART
THEIR JURISDICTIONS REDUCE
PROGRAMS AND STAFFING A TIME
WHERE THE WE ARE THE MONEY THIS
INCLUDES THE THIRD THAT HAVE
BEEN FROM VARIOUS THROUGHOUT
THE- TO RESPOND TO COMPANY. WE
ALIGN ONE OF THE FLEXIBLE
FUNDING THE ENTITLED A WIDE
ARRAY OF HER. AND IS USED TO
LEVERAGES BUT FUNDS AS WELL AS-
AT. AT THAT DAD DRAWDOWN AB
ADDITIONAL FEDERAL DOLLARS OF
THE MATCHING FUNDS AT THAT. IT
MAKES THE IMPACT TO OUR OUR
NINETEEN NINETY ONE REELECTED
THAT I EVEN GREATER BEYOND THE
ESTIMATED AT DECLINE FROM OUR
BASE IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE
THAT LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENT
ALREADY RECEIVED A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY MILLION LATIN
REALIGNMENT. LAST YEAR THAN WE
RECEIVED IN TWO THOUSAND AND
SIX OUR REVENUES NEVER RECOVER
AND THEN ADDED ON TOP OF THAT
WITH THE DECLINE IN STATE AND
FEDERAL FUNDING THE- PRIZE THAT
OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE AND WORKFORCE
HAS SIGNIFICANT ME. THE PROGRAM
AT THAT AT RISK IN OUR FOOD.
DISEASE PROGRAMS THAT BENEFIT
EVERY HOUSE. IT ALL KIND OF
BELIEVE PROGRAM THAT HEALTH
EQUITY PROGRAMS THAT ARE AIMED
AT ADDRESSING THE BERRY
INEQUITIES THAT CALL THAT
NINETY. MAGNIFY IT OKAY EARLY
IN DEVELOPMENT BUT WHAT ABOUT
HE SAID ENVIRONMENT HEALTH GREG.
PROGRAM THE IN REVENUE THREATEN
BY THE OF PUBLIC HEALTH LAB.
AND TO DATE ONLY TWENTY NINE
REMAIN THERE BEEN A LACK OF
CLOSURE THE LATE NIGHT. OF
HAPPENED LAST YEAR SOME TO THE
HEALTH ALIGNMENT FROM PRIOR
YEARS. WELL I. TO ALTER THE
POLL THAT WILL FURTHER WITH.
HEALTH PROGRAM INCLUDING THE
HEALTH PROGRAM AND FUNDING
WE'RE- BACK OF HER. AND LOCAL
ORACLE. THAT MAY BE CAUSED BY
ANY AND THE ATTACK ON ON
BEATING. THE VICE OF OUR
ECONOMY AND CAN WITH THEIR
DEPEND ON THE WORK OF A LOCAL
HEALTH. WE RESPECTFULLY URGE
PLEDGE THE LEGISLATURE TEMPLE
AND- RESOURCES SO THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE AND IF CANCER OF THE
TO PROTECT THEM APPROVED THE
HEALTH OF CALIFORNIANS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MA'AM. OPERATOR
CAN WE HAVE THE NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. LINE SEVENTY FOUR GO
AHEAD PLEASE. AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS KEVIN GARBER CENTER BALL
HEALTH THANK YOU FOR HOLDING
THE STOP PLATFORM WE OPERATE
SCHOOL BASED EARLY SMALL
PROGRAMS SACRAMENTO COUNTY. IN
NINETEEN AND TWENTY NINETEEN WE
ENCOUNTERED OVER TWENTY SIX
HUNDRED. ELEMENTARY STUDENTS
WITH ORAL EXAMS. APPLE
QUALIFICATIONS SUCCESSFULLY
NAVIGATING 60% OF THE COUNTERS
TO BAIL PLAN OF WHICH 40%
RECEIVED MUCH NEEDED DENTAL
SERVICES. THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSAL TO CUT THE DNC PROGRAM
O'DONNELL ELIMINATE THE EARLY
FILES PROGRAM BUT IT WOULD STOP
THE SAVINGS THE PROGRAM HAS
SHOWN TO THE COUNTY IN THE
STATE HEALTH CARE SYSTEM AS
WELL AS THE HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS OF REVENUE
SCHOOL DISTRICT WHICH SHE- I
REDUCING BURKE. WELL HELLO IS
ANNUALLY. WHICH OPPOSE THE
BUDGET PROPOSAL ONE ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT TO REJECT. THANKS
FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU SIR
OPERATOR WE HAVE THE NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. LINE ONE SEVENTY
EIGHT GO AHEAD PLEASE. HI THERE
THIS IS DANNY OFFER THE
NATIONAL ALLIANCE ON MENTAL
ILLNESS OF THE NINE IS NOT A
CALIFORNIA- THREE RETHINK THE
STRESS UNDER THAN AND UNDER A
MINUTE- JUST WANTED TO
HIGHLIGHT THE ESSENTIAL
FUNCTIONS THAT FAMILY MEMBERS
PROVIDE. FOR THOSE LIVING WITH
A MENTAL ILLNESS. YOU OFFER
HERE THAT'S REFERRED TO
CONSUMERS THAT OUR LOVED ONES
AND JUST PUT A FINER POINT ON
THAT- THAT AS THEIR OUR LOVED
ONE WE MAKE. A PRIORITY. EVEN
DURING A PANDEMIC WHERE MANY
PRIORITIES CAN SHIPPED. WE'LL
CONTINUE TO STRETCH OURSELVES
MAKE SURE THEIR NEEDS ARE MET
SO. IN THAT LIGHT WE HOPE THAT
OUR PROGRAMS CONTINUE TO BE
SUPPORTED. NUMBER TWO ALTHOUGH
THE STATE SUPPORT OF PEER
SUPPORT SERVICES- ESPECIALLY
MIDDLE THIS PANDEMIC IS THE
CENTRAL IT'S COST EFFICIENT AND
PEERS PROVIDE GUIDANCE AND-
MOST IMPORTANTLY. UNDERSTANDING
I WHICH IS OFTEN THE KEY
COMPONENT AND DETERMINING HOW
WELL A CLIENT DOES WITH THEIR
PATH WELL. I HAVE A REMINDER
THAT STAKEHOLDER IS NOT BE A
PART. OF THE DECISION MAKING
PROCESS. RYAN FAMILY PROVIDERS
MUST BE HEARD SO THAT WE DON'T
DROWNED BY THE WAVES OF THIS
THROUGH THE ARMY THANKS VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU
SIR OPERATOR CAN WE HAVE THE
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. BLIND
SEVENTY NINE GO AHEAD PLEASE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE BILL
BRYANT REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF THEIR
MEDICAL SERVICES. VIA MILITANT
THE HELICOPTER AN AIRPLANE
AMBULANCE SERVICES ACROSS THE
STATE. AB OFFICE PLAY KEY ROLE
IN THE STATE Y. DISASTER
RESPONSE AN EMS SYSTEM
PARTICULARLY IN RURAL AREAS
WHERE WE TRANSPORT THEM THE
MOST CRITICAL PATIENTS TO URBAN
TRAUMA CENTERS CARDIAC CENTERS.
STROKES CENTERS IN CHILDREN'S
NEONATAL CENTERS. WE HAVE
SUBMITTED A PROPOSAL TO THE
COMMITTEE TO EXTEND THE CURRENT
SUPPLEMENTAL FUNDING SOURCE
ACCOMPLISHED THROUGH THE SAME
FOUR DOLLAR PENALTY ON MOVING
VIOLATIONS. BUT HAS BEEN IN
PLACE FOR THE PAST TEN YEARS.
WITHOUT ACTION ARE FUNDING
STREAM WILL BE ELIMINATED ON
JULY FIRST THAT SHOULD SIX
SHORT WEEKS AWAY. AND ARE FEE
FOR SERVICE MEDICARE FUNDING
WILL BE REDUCED BY MORE THAN
50% THIS WILL PLACE MANY
EMERGENCY HELICOPTER BATES IS
AT RISK OF CLOSING. MOST AT
RISK WILL BE EMERGENCY AIRCRAFT
TO PROVIDE SERVICES TO
CHILDREN'S HOSPITALS AS THEIR
FEE FOR SERVICE MEDICARE
UTILIZATION IS MUCH HIGHER THAN
THE GENERAL POPULATION. SOME
SPECIFICALLY- PROPOSAL IS TO
SIMPLY EXTEND THE EXISTING
PROGRAM CALLED IMADA FOR TWO
YEARS. THIS WILL NOT IMPACT THE
GENERAL FUND AND IS ACTUALLY
BUDGET POSITIVE. BECAUSE 80% OF
THE PENALTIES- THAT ARE
COLLECTED. ARE MATCHED WITH
FEDERAL FUNDS IN THERE AND ARE
DISTRIBUTED TO PROVIDERS
INDIA'S A SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENT.
THE OTHER 20% OF THE MONEY
COLLECTED GO STOPS AT THE
BASELINE GENERAL FUND
EXPENDITURES. SO WE HAVE TO YOU
EXTEND THIS IMPORTANT PROGRAM
TO ENSURE THAT THE- LIFESAVING
ACCESS TO EMERGENCY AMBULANCES
REMAN AVAILABLE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER BRYANT
OPERATOR CAN WE HAVE THE NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. I AM THIRTY
EIGHT GO AHEAD PLEASE. GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO COMMENT MY NAME IS DAVE
MEADOWS ON SENIOR VICE
PRESIDENT OF GOVERNMENT
PROGRAMS WITH LIBERTY DENTAL
WHICH IS ONE OF THE CONTRACTED
MANAGED CARE PLANS I WANTED TO
BRIEFLY COMMENT ON THE-
TRANSITION OF DENTAL MANAGED TO
PEOPLE SERVICE. JUST GOT
PROPOSAL DOES INDICATE THAT THE
DOW MANAGED CARE TO PEOPLE
SERVICE PROPOSAL IS A COST
NEUTRAL PROPOSAL HOWEVER IN THE
LA WHEN ALEX IS ON PAGE HI- THE
SAVINGS OF EIGHT POINT NINE
MILLION THAT IS IDENTIFIED AS
THE- THIS. GENERAL SERVICE
WHICH BY THE WAY DON'T A PAIN
TINY DIFFERENT NOT IS A REALLY
I DON'T REALLY CONSIDER TO WILL
FADING BUT HE DETERMINE A OF
THE POINT NINE MILLION IN THE
BUDGET THAT AT THE TYPICALLY
INDICATE THAT INCLUDES PROPERTY
SIX BECAUSE IT ALSO IS GOING TO
INCLUDE THE ADULT DENTAL COSTS-BOTH OF WHICH ARE TARGETED FOR
ELIMINATION IN THE BUDGET AND
BOTH THE PROPERTY SIX NEEDLE
DENTAL DOLLARS THAT WERE BACK
AGAIN THAT EIGHT POINT NINE
MILLION DOLLAR CALCULUS CAN
HAVE. TAKEN IN ON THAT OCCASION
THERE. POINT IN THE FIRST PLACE
IN THE NEAR NOW IS ACCURATE IF
THE PRICE SAY NIDO DENTAL ARE
ELIMINATED THE EIGHT POINT NINE
MILLION PAYMENT TO BRANCH IS
THE IS WAY OVER STATE ALSO JUST
TO POINT OUT I THINK THAT THAT
MUCH AS IS THE CASE WITH THE
MANAGED CARE ON THE MEDICAL
SIDE YOU THINK THE DENTAL
MANAGE YOUR PROVIDES A MUCH
COST EFFECTIVE METHOD TO
PROVIDE A CAL. I DON'T. JUST
FOR MEDI CAL ABILITY. ALSO
DISAGREE MENTION WE THINK THAT
NOT ONLY IS DENTAL MANAGED CARE
MORE COST EFFECTIVE METHOD. BUT
WE ALSO THINK IT PROVIDES
NUMEROUS QUALITY CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS THAT ARE FAR
GREATER THAN PAPER SERVICE OR
NOT EVEN PART OF THE FOR
SERVICE PROGRAM. WE DO HAVE
NUMEROUS QUALITY MEASURES THAT
REQUIRED A DENTAL MANAGED CARE
PLANS THAT ARE NOT REQUIRED TO.
OF PEOPLE SERVICE PLANS AND WE
ALSO HAVE LOTS OF PATIENT
CENTER PROTECTIONS THEY'RE
BUILT YOUR GRANT THINGS LIKE
GUARANTEED NETWORK ACCESS
QUALITY GRIEVANCE APPEAL.
CULTURAL LINGUISTIC COMPETENCY
EDUCATION OUTREACH NAVIGATION
PRO TRACKING PROVIDERS
FINANCIAL SOLVENCY. THINGS THAT
THANK YOU THAT. WE DO THINK
THAT THE PROPOSED ADDITION WILL
NOT BE THAT THAT. WE THINK
ELIMINATE MANY THE CONSUMER
PROTECTION BUILT INTO DENTAL
MANAGED CARE WE THINK IT CREATE
SIGNIFICANT DISRUPTION TO
BENEFICIARIES WE THINK IT WILL
BE USED ACCESS PARTICULAR GET
SPECIALIST MANY OF WHICH ONLY
PARTICIPATE WITH DENTAL MANAGED
CARE DUE TO OUR- PAYMENT.
ABILITY IN OUR MINISTRY
PROCESSES THEREFORE WE OPPOSE
THE PROPOSED TRANSITION OF
DENTAL MANAGED COMPUTER SERVICE
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION AND THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT. THANK
YOU MISTER MEADOWS. OPERATOR
CAN YOU HAVE THE NEXT CALLER
PLACE. LINE THIRTY GO AHEAD
PLEASE. JUST ONE QUICK. CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES SIR. YES OKAY THANK
YOU MY NAME IS ROBERT BUTLER
BASKETS IN ON PRESIDENT AND CEO
OF SOUTHERN CARE GIVER RESOURCE
CENTER WHERE A MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA CARE GIVER RESOURCE
CENTERS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA YEAH AND I WANT TO
FIRST OF ALL THANK THE CHAIRMAN
AND THE COMMITTEE FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO CHECK A FEW
WORDS ON BEHALF OF. THE OVER
FIVE MILLION FAMILY CARE GIVERS
THAT WE REPRESENT ABOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. WE ARE AND
MANY OF MY COLLEAGUES ON THE
CALL HERE TODAY- ONE EXPRESS
THAT WE REJECT THE CUTS
PROPOSED BY PROPOSED TO THE
CARE GIVER RESOURCE CENTERS-
THROUGH THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET-
OF THE- EFFORT WEAR HEARING
TODAY. YOU KNOW IN 200-082-0008
DURING THE RECESSION. THE CARE
GIVER RESOURCE CENTERS TO
CANADIAN PERCENT CUT. AND OVER
A DECADE LATER WE ARE IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN. DELUDE TO BE
ADVOCACY WORK OF THE CARE GIVER
RESOURCE CENTERS AND AGAIN THE
FIVE MILLION AND GROWING FAMILY
CAREGIVERS ACROSS THE STATE.
THE BUDGET WAS AUGMENTED IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN TO GET US
BACK ON TRACK TO HELP. INCREASE
THE NUMBER OF FAMILIES WE COULD
SERVE WITH OUR CRITICAL
ESSENTIAL SERVICES THAT WE
PROVIDE TWO THOUSANDS OF
FAMILIES. THROUGHOUT THE STATE
EN MASSE OUR AGAIN- DURING COLD
BID NINETEEN PANDEMIC WHICH
AGAIN IS A DEVASTATING AN
UNPRECEDENTED. CRISIS THAT WERE
UNDER THE BUDGET. TO OUR MOST
VULNERABLE AS MANY OF THE TOP.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS HAVE
COMMENTED IS AGAIN RIDING ON
THE BACKS OF OUR ELDERS AND
MOST DISABLED FAMILY MEMBERS IN
OUR STATE CALIFORNIA. FAMILIES
DEPEND ON US. VERY MUCH
ESPECIALLY DURING THIS TIME THE
MAJORITY OF OVER 75% OF FAMILY
CARE GIVERS THAT WE SERVE OUR
CARING FOR A LOVED ONE AT HOME
WITH ELEVEN TO FIFTEEN OUT
PROBLEMS WITH ACTIVITIES OF
DAILY LIVING IN OVER HALF OVER
56% OF OUR FAMILY CARE GIVERS
ARE PROVIDING MEDICAL CARE TO
THEIR LOVED ONES THAT WITHOUT
THEIR HELP WOULD BE AND SKILLED
NURSING. FACILITY THOSE ARE
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
THAT WE ARE SAVING THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA BY PROVIDING FAMILY
MEMBERS WITH RESOURCES THE
EMOTIONAL SUPPORT THE TRAINING
THE COACHING THE RESPITE HOURS
OF SERVICE THAT THEY NEED TO
GET A BREAK THAT THEY NEED TO
BE ABLE TO MANAGE THE CARE OF
THEIR LOVED ONES- IN OUR IN OUR
CITY CALIFORNIA. THIS IS NOT A
TIME TO MAKE CUT TO THE CARE
GIVER RESOURCE CENTERS
ESPECIALLY DURING THE CALL THE
NINETEEN CRISIS WHAT WE NEED IS
THE STABILITY WHAT FAMILIES
NEED IS MORE SERVICES FOR- TO
HELP THEM AT HOME I HAVE A
FAMILY FOR AND- WHO JUST LOST
HER MOM IN A NURSING HOME. TO
CALL THAT NINETEEN AND OUR
SERVICES HELP KEEP PEOPLE OUT
OF NURSING HOMES SO AGAIN I
WANNA. STRETCH THE IMPORTANCE
OF THE CARE GIVER RESOURCE
CENTERS AND I WANT TO- STATE
THAT WE REJECT. I REJECT PARK
FIVE MILLION FAMILY CARE GIVERS
REJECT. THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
RIGHT NOW THAT CUT THE CARE
GIVER RESOURCE CENTERS AND IF
YOU WANT TO FIND OUT WHICH CARE
GIVER RESOURCE CENTER SERVES IN
YOUR AREA GO TO OUR CARE GIVER
CALIFORNIA DOT ORG WEBSITE. AND
FIND OUT WHICH ONES WHICH ONE
CUP COVERS IN YOUR TERRITORY AS
WE COVER THE ENTIRE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WITH BASICALLY VERY
LITTLE FUNDS PER CAPITA. BOB ON
THE NET COMPARED TO THE NUMBER
OF FAMILY CARE GIVERS IN OUR
STATE AND AGAIN THAT CONTINUING
TO GROW AND IS EVEN PART OF.
THE GOVERNOR'S- AGING PLAN ON
AGING SO I WANT TO AGAIN SAY
THAT WE REJECTED AND THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU SIR. OPERATOR CAN WE HAVE
THE NEXT CALLER PLEASE. ONE
SIXTY THREE GO AHEAD PLEASE.
YES GOOD MORNING MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- WE APPRECIATE THE
EFFORTS OF THIS COMMITTEE TO
ADDRESS THE CHALLENGES FACED BY
THE COLBERT NINETEEN UP
PANDEMIC MY NAME IS ALBERT BUT
WE PAUL AND I REPRESENT THAT
CALIFORNIA COVERAGE AND HELP
INITIATIVES HAVE THIRTY THREE
EIGHT BETTER CORRECT GOING ON
THE FRONTLINE- DEALING. WITH
INVOLVEMENT ISSUES INVOLVED.
FOR AND YOU WILL SAVE SERVICES
THAT WE FEEL FIVE FILES AND
ROMAN SPEECH. WE ARE. THAT
NUMBER IS FIVE THREE ALL THE
AND WE ARE AT THIS POINT
DEALING WITH AT LEAST A 40%
INCREASE IN MEDI CAL AND COVERS
ALL ONE AND ROME SUPPORT
REQUEST JUST DURING THE LAST
MONTH WE RECOGNIZED THAT WE
HONOR AND SPORT THE GOVERNOR'S
EFFORTS THE EFFORTS OF BARK ON
THE FILE CARE SERVICES.
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH AND
THE DIRECTOR DOLLY IN FACING UP
TO BECOME A BIT NINETEEN
CRISIS- BUT WE RESPECT THE
STRENGTH OF THE COMMITTEE. TO
DEAL WITH THIS CRISIS AND WE
ARE WHAT WHAT ONE COULD NOT-
COUPLE OF POINTS FIRST. MANY OF
THE TOP POINT IN THE- MAY READ
WE DIDN'T OUR INPUT. CONCERNED
ABOUT THE TARGETING OF THE
ELDERLY IN THE MAY REVISED. AND
BROADLY SUPPORT THE
RECOMMENDATION PLACE THE
PROGRAM COME. ON PAUL NOT
TERMINATION- AFTER DEATH BY-
BUT ASSEMBLYMAN WHAT AT WHICH
ALSO STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
COMMENTS MADE IN PARTICULAR BY
THE REPRESENTATIVES OF STATE
MAY HELP BACK THAT. THE PCA AND
THE WESTERN CENTER FOR LAW AND
POVERTY- FURTHER- GTA CHINA'S
CONCERNED- ABOUT THE PROPOSED
CUTS. OFF THE NAVIGATOR THOUGHT
UP PROJECT IN THE BUDGET FOR
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. I WOULD BUY MORE THE
NEED FOR A NAVIGATOR SERVICES
THAT ARE DESPERATELY NEED.
APPROXIMATELY TEN MILLION
DOLLARS IN CAP FOR THE MAVS AT
THE NAVIGATOR PROGRAM ARE
CONTEMPLATED AND WE HOPE. THAT
THAT CAN BE REVERSED. AS OF
JULY ONE. ABOUT TWENTY. ALL WE
ARE. T. H. I. X. SUBSTANTIAL
INCREASE IN MY CAL HOW WOULD
YOU. AT SOME PLACE TO OTHER
STATES MILLION OTHER SAY FORM.
OVER THE THREE TO FOUR MONTHS
WITH THE MASSIVE INCREASE IN
UNEMPLOYMENT OCCASIONED BY THE
PANDEMIC- OVER THE NEXT-
SEVERAL MONTHS. WE BELIEVE THAT
THE SUPPORT FOR THE NAVIGATOR
AGENCIES IT'S CRITICAL
NECESSARY TO HANDLE THE MASSIVE
INCREASE DEMAND FOR MEDI CAL IS
COVERED CALIFORNIA COVERAGE DUE
TO THE COLD THAT NINETEEN
PANDEMIC- WE THANK- THAT IS
VERY IMPORTANT TO STRENGTHEN
THE ABILITY OF NAVIGATORS
HANDLE ELDERLY MEDI BUT HE'S SO
MUCH OF THE RAVAGES OF THIS
CRISIS ENHANCE THE ABILITY OF
CALIFORNIA TO MAXIMIZE FEDERAL
MATCHING SO THAT WE DON'T LEAVE
BLOCKS FEDERAL DOLLARS ON THE
TABLE THROUGH THE APP- THE
SHORT RUN PROGRAM CUTS. AND
THEREBY WOULD HELP POLICE
FRAZIER ON STATE AND. COUNTY
BUDGET. WE ALSO BELIEVE THAT
THE STRAIGHT THE A ROLL IN OUR
BY WILL HELP. BUT COUNTY OP
THIS AND FQHC. ON THE TOP ONES
BUT APPROPRIATE AND SPEEDY
COVERAGE- FOR THEIR PATIENTS
AND- OPTIMAL COVERAGE AT
APPROPRIATE TIMES- FOR MEDI CAL
AND COVER CALIFORNIA PATIENTS.
THAT WOULD REDUCE THE INCIDENCE
OF SERIOUS AILMENTS DISABILITY
AND EARLY DEATH. OF
CALIFORNIA'S MOST VULNERABLE
AND CURRENTLY EXPANDING OUR
POPULATIONS- BLOODWORK CUTTING
TEN MILLION DOLLARS IN A-
NAVIGATOR PROJECT. WOULD COST
US BETWEEN TEN TO FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS IN STEP MAP
FARMS AND F. MAP FUNDS THAT CAN
BE USED BACK FELT- THE GENERAL
FUND CROSSING ACOSTA AND WITH.
OTHERWISE I'M- AND COUNTIES TO
INCREASE MORE FACTORS SO. WE
ARE THAT THAT THE SUCH THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SIR. WE HAVE
FORTY FIVE PEOPLE IN Q. AND SO-
OPERATORS YOU QUEUE UP THE NEXT
PERSON I WOULD JUST ASK THAT WE
KEEP OUR COMMENTS AS BRIEF AS
POSSIBLE. LINE ONE SEVENTY CO
HEAD PLEASE. AND IS OPEN GO
AHEAD. CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
MA'AM. OH OKAY- CAN REALLY MAKE.
HI MY NAME IS ALEX HOW HERO.
AND I WORK FOR HELP PROJECT
MANAGEMENT. THAT BONTA BURKE HE
DEL MAR CARE GIVER RESOURCE
CENTER AS WELL AS THE MULTI
PURPOSE IN YOUR SERVICE GRAHAM
WE PROVIDE ESSENTIAL SERVICES
IN A CRUISE MONTEREY AND SAN
BENITO COUNTY. I'M CALLING
TODAY BECAUSE I AM STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSAL TO REVERSE THE
AUTHENTICATION NOW IS THE WORK
TRYING TO CUT SERVICES THE
FAMILY CARE GIVER YO ARE
HAVING A MORE DIFFICULT TIME
THAN EVER BRING THE CURRENT
QUITE. WE SHOULD BE STRENGTH.
AND SUPPORT FAMILY MEMBER AND
THE ELDERLY DURING THIS TIME
NOT CUT. MY ROLE AT MY COMPANY
IS A PROGRAM THROUGH YET AND I
AM OFTEN THE FIRST POINT OF
CONTACT WITH OUR CLIENTS AND
POTENTIAL CLIENTS. I AND THE
DIFFICULTY OF MANY OF OUR
CLIENTS ARE HAVING AN AMAZING
SERVICE THE PROGRAM PROVIDES
NINE MEMBERS OF MY COMMUNITY
FOR CARING FOR LOVED ONES WITH
COGNITIVE DISORDERS. THIS
PROGRAM IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
SUPPORT FOR FAMILY CAREGIVERS
WHO ARE GOING THROUGH A VERY
DIFFICULT TIME. NOT ONLY DO I
DEPEND ON FUNDING FOR THE
DUMBER CARE GIVER RESOURCE
CENTER AND THE AND THE FIFTY
FOR MY OWN LIVELIHOOD BUT OUR
CLIENTS DEPEND ON OUR RESOURCES
AND THE RESPITE CARE GRANT TO
HELP THEM MAINTAIN. A BALANCED
LIFE. MANY OF OUR CLIENTS WILL
NOT KNOW WHERE TO TURN FOR
INFORMATION AND ASSISTANCE IF
WE ARE NO LONGER ABLE TO
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE SERVICES
THAT OUR CURRENT LEVEL OF
OPERATION. I REQUEST YOU TAKE
THIS INTO ACCOUNT WHEN YOU ARE
MAKING YOUR DECISION ON THE
BUDGET PROPOSAL. THE LONG TERM
COST CUTTING THE SERVICES
PROVIDED BY THE PROGRAM AS WELL
AS AND THAT THAT HE GREATLY
OUTWEIGHS ANY TEMPORARY
BENEFITS AND STATE BUDGET.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME
ALL YOUR HARD WORK AND YOUR
POSITIVE COMMENTARY ON THE
ISSUE. THANK YOU MA'AM.
OPERATOR NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
FIND ONE EIGHTY THREE GO AHEAD
PLEASE. GOOD AFTERNOON DOCTOR
AB ARM BE ALLOWED THE HONORABLE
COMMITTEE MEMBER MY NAME IS
HOPE KAYMER AND I'M A POLICY
ANALYST AT SENECA FAMILY OF
AGENCIES SENECA PROVIDES
CRITICAL MENTAL HEALTH AND
PERMANENCY SERVICES ACROSS THE
CONTINUUM OF SCHOOL THEY-
CRISIS RESPONSE TO RESIDENTIAL
AND COMMUNITY BASED SETTINGS TO
THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS OF
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. THE IMPACT OF THIS
GLOBAL CRISIS. ON THE RD MULTI
TRACKED FAMILIES IN SENECA
PROGRAMS A PROFOUND AN ON
GOING. OUR SERVICES ARE
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT TO KEEP
CHILDREN AND FAMILY SAFE AND TO
DE ESCALATE FRIGHTENING MENTAL
HEALTH CRISES MADE MARKET BY
THIS PANDEMIC. THE STATE WIDE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SYSTEM NEEDS
TO BE PROTECTED TO SERVICES
LIKE ARTS CAN CONTINUE.
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO ADVOCATE
FOR FEDERAL FUNDS TO SUPPORT
THE PUBLIC SAFETY NET SYSTEM
THE FEAR THIS IS FAR FROM
ENOUGH. TODAY WE ARE TO THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE LEADERSHIP
OF THE POTENTIAL BUDGET
COMMITTEE CAN BEST FUNDING TO
TAKE CARE CALIFORNIA'S
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH WITH THEM. SO
THEY ARE NOT IRREVERSIBLE
DAMAGE TO THE PUBLIC SAFETY NET
ALONGSIDE THE QUICKLY GROWING
PUBLIC NEED FOR ACCEPTABLE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES. PLEASE
DO NOT LET THIS PUBLIC HEALTH
CRISIS BECOME A FAMILY MENTAL
HEALTH CRISIS AS WELL. THANK
YOU SO MUCH THREE LEADERSHIP
DURING THIS TIME AND FOR
PRACTICING SUCH TRANSPARENT
GOVERNANCE. THANKS SO MUCH
THANK YOU MA'AM OPERATOR WE
HAVE THE NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
TEN FIFTY TWO GO AHEAD PLEASE.
HELLO MY NAME IS MERRY
SHERIDAN- I HAVE BEEN A FAMILY
CARE GIVER AND ALSO A
PROFESSIONAL WORKING IN THE
FIELD I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR YOUR VERY
THOUGHTFUL COMMENTS ON THE
PROPOSED BUDGET CUTS IN THE MAY
REVISE. AND MANY HAVE SAID NOW
IS NOT THE TIME TO MAKE CUTS TO
PROGRAMS THAT SUPPORT
CALIFORNIA'S MOST VULNERABLE.
FAMILY CARE GIVER KEEP
DEPENDENT SENIORS ANOTHER
ADULT. SEVERE IMPAIRMENTS AT
HOME AND OUT OF NURSING
FACILITIES THEY NEED MORE NOT
LESS SUPPORT OF THE KIND THEY
CURRENTLY GET FROM THE CARE
GIVER RESOURCE CENTERS. AND THE
CARE GIVER RESOURCE CENTER SIR
THE ENTIRE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
OVER AND ABOVE THE TOLL TAKEN
BY CO THAT NINETEEN. THERE IS
AN AVERAGE ANNUAL INCREASE OF A
HUNDRED AND SIXTY FIVE THOUSAND
UNPAID CAREGIVERS. IN
CALIFORNIA AND THAT'S A HUNDRED
AND SIXTY FIVE THOUSAND EACH
YEAR. NG US AT THIS POINT TO
APPROXIMATELY FIVE AND A HALF
MILLION I'M KATE UNPAID FAIR
FAMILY CARE GIVERS IN THE STATE
PROVIDING BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
WORTH OF UNPAID. CARE AND THESE
CARE GIVERS TO PROVIDE THE
BACKBONE OF THE LONG TERM CARE
SYSTEM IN CALIFORNIA. WITHOUT
THE KIND OF SUPPORT THAT THE C.
R. C.'S PROVIDE. MANY OF THOSE
CARED FOR BY FAMILY AND FRIENDS
WOULD GO TO SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES AND- BECOME AN
EXPENSE ON AN ALREADY BURDENED
MEDI CAL PROGRAM. SYSTEMS
SUPPORTING THOSE CARE GIVING
FAMILIES NEED TO BE
STRENGTHENED NOT WEAKENED. THE
TWENTY NINETEEN AUGMENTATION
THAT THE MAY REVISED PROPOSES
TO REPAIRS WITH IMPLEMENTED
PRECISELY TO STRENGTHEN THE
SYSTEM. THAT OVERWHELMINGLY
PROVIDES. CARE GIVER SUPPORT IN
CALIFORNIA. CARE GIVERS ARE
EXPERIENCING INCREASED
ISOLATION AT AN UNPRECEDENTED
LEVELS AND THE MENTAL HELTH
CHALLENGES THAT WILL COME AS A
RESULT OF THAT TO CARE GIVERS
IS JUST IT'S JUST RISING
EXPONENTIALLY. BECAUSE OF THE
AUGMENTATION THE CARE GIVER
RESOURCE CENTERS PROHIBITED IN
REAL TIME TO PROVIDE SERVICES
TO FAMILY CARE GIVERS AS ONE
EXAMPLE ALONE. CARE GIVERS
SPECIFIC INFORMATION ON COVER
NINETEEN WAS DISTRIBUTED TO
OVER A HUNDRED THOUSAND PEOPLE
BETWEEN THE FIRST STAND PLACE
ORDERS AND THE END OF APRIL.
THE CODE THE DEATH RATE OF
SENIORS AND OTHER ADULTS WITH
SUBSTANTIAL DISABILITIES CARED
FOR BY FAMILIES WHO RECEIVE
SERVICES FROM THE C. R. C.'S IS
SUBSTANTIALLY LOWER. THAN THE
STATEWIDE AVERAGE AND-
EXPONENTIALLY LOWER THAN FOR
SENIORS SINCE IN NURSING
FACILITIES. IN LINE WITH THE
WITH THE MIX BEST BY MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE- PLEASE DO NOT
REVERSE THE AUGMENTATION OF THE
C. R. C.'S OR ELIMINATE THE SEA
BASS PROGRAMS- AND THE MSF
PEOPLE. PROGRAMS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU MA'AM. OPERATOR
CAN WE HAVE THE NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. FIND ONE EIGHTY TWO.
THE MORE YOU WILL HAVE TO
ACTUALLY HAPPEN WITHOUT I THINK
YOU AT MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'M GRAN
JONES I'M A DIRECTOR FOR THE
MULTIPLE LISTING SERVICE
PROGRAM NOTED THAT HE AND I
CARE BEEN LAKE IN THE COUNTY
WHICH IS ONE OF THIRTY EIGHT
FIVE PAPA THE STATE. ALL WE ARE
NOT PROVISIONS OF THE ACT LIKE
MULTIPLE CONTINUES SERVICES
PROGRAM AND OTHER PROGRAMS THAT
BENEFIT OVER TO OUT ALREADY.
CORD THREE. YOU KNOW THEY- YEAH
ARE MOSTLY WILL WOULD MEDICAL
SERVICES AT IN MANY AREAS WHERE
INVOLVED IN THAT IN THAT THAT
HE THOUGHT. ALL OF THE WORKING
FIFTY POWER OUT OF THE JUST
LAST FALL. IT WOULD NEVER
PEOPLE WORKERS NURSES. HOMES OF
OUR- BUT HAND OUT EXTRA BLANK
AND SLASH DEPARTMENT OVER DON'T.
THINK IT'S IN THE DARK. NO IN
THE PROVIDES EVERY THAT IN THE
SENSE HE DOES TO LOGIN PAUL.
OLDER ADULTS RECEIVING LETTERS
AND MEDI CAL AND AT THE MOMENT
WE'RE- WHEN THERE'S TO HOLD NOT
DEPEND WHAT. I WILL BE ABLE ALL
OF YOU GET. WE DON'T GET THAT
WOULD YOU STOP DO. WHEN YOU'RE
YOUR EFFORT PARKING AND ON
BEHALF OF OUR OLDER ADULTS.
WHEN RESOURCES HAVE YOU PLAYED
TO TURN. YOU MUST ALLOW THE
AMONG THE OF AND THAT'S ST. IT
IS NOT JUST A FIVE MORE. MA'AM.
OPERATOR CAN WE HAVE THE NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. I THE ONE FIFTY
ONE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS A
KELLY MAC MILLAN- WITH- AT
CALIFORNIA DENTAL ASSOCIATION
I'M GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRS AND
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR THE
TIME TO OPPORTUNITY TO GIVE
OUR- OUR VOICE- WHAT THE
CALIFORNIA DON'T CESSATION
CLEARLY UNDERSTANDS THE STATE'S
BUDGET DILEMMA. THE
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSAL TO
REDIRECT THE PROPOSITION FIFTY
SIX FUNDING IN ITS ENTIRETY
GOES AGAINST THE LAW OF THE
INITIATIVE AND THE WILL OF THE
VOTERS. THE RATE CUT WILL
DECIMATE DENTAL CARE HAVE A
DENTAL PROVIDER NETWORK WHICH
IS ALREADY SUFFERING DUE TO THE
MONTHS OF SHATTERED PRACTICES.
AND NEW COSTS FROM INCREASED
INFECTION CONTROL. I MEDI CAL
PROGRAM WITHOUT PROVIDERS IS AN
EMPTY PROMISE FOR THE MILLIONS
OF CALIFORNIANS WHO RELY ON
THIS PROGRAM TO KEEP THEM
HEALTHY. ADDITIONAL CALIFORNIA
ALSO STATION IS REQUESTING THAT
THE LEGISLATURE REJECT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL TO
TRANSITION ALL MEDI CAL BATTLE
SERVICES TO THE FEE FOR SERVICE
DELIVERY SYSTEM. AND INSTEAD
AUTHORIZED A THREE YEAR
EXTENSION OF THE EXISTING
DENTAL MANAGED CARE CONTRACTS
CDA HAD PREVIOUSLY SUPPORTED
THIS TRANSITION BUT OUT OF
KNOWLEDGE THE TREMENDOUS
CHANGES TO COVER NINETEEN AND
WE BELIEVE AN EXTENSION IS
WARRANTED AT THIS TIME. ALSO
REP THE READ CARE BRIGHT WHICH
IS THE UPPER FOR THAT THE CAN
BE AND WE WERE. TO SPEAK TO THE
FACT THAT PROPERTY FIFTY FUND
IS A- FOR MEDIA CARE FOR. WHO
ARE HIGH PERCENT MEDI CAL. WE
LINED HEALTH COM AND ASK YOU
OPPOSE THIS. THANK YOU CAN THE
HEARING. THANK YOU MA'AM.
OPERATOR CAN WE HAVE THE NEXT
CALLER PLAY. LINE ONE FOR FOUR
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS MY NAME IS TERRA
ANALYTIC AND I AM ACROSS SCHOOL
NURSE WITH LONG IN A SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN BACK FROM COUNTY.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK TO YOU TO. I WERE WITH
SPECIAL NEEDS AND SEVERELY
DISABLED STUDENTS WHO DEPEND ON
THE DENTAL MANAGED CARE
PROGRAM. TO RECEIVE CRITICAL
DENTAL CARE. THESE STUDENTS GET
UNIQUE DENTAL NEEDS AND THE
PROPOSAL IN THE NATION OF THE
DENTAL MANAGED CARE PROGRAM TO
BE FOR SERVICE. WOULD BE
DESTRUCTIVE TO THESE PATIENTS
AS WELL AS PROVIDERS AND
EMPLOYEES. SCHOOL NURSES
REALIZE THAT THE ELIMINATION OF
THIS PROGRAM WITH THESE. SCHOOL
BASED PROGRAMS SUCH AS EARLY
SMILED PROGRAM. WHICH AND WOOD-
IMPACT SCREENINGS THAT CAN
CATCH POTENTIAL ISSUES BEFORE
THEY BECOME MORE PROBLEMATIC
AND EXPENSIVE. THESE PROGRAMS
ARE COST EFFECTIVE AND I
EMPHATICALLY BELIEVE THAT NOW
IS NOT THE TIME. TO LOSE
PERSONALLY SEEN THE RESULTS. OF
HAVE A DANCE PRO. AT POSITIVELY
IMPACT THESE. AND CHANGE THEIR
LIVES I STRONGLY OPPOSE THESE
CUTS WHICH WILL HAVE A
PROFOUND. IMPACT ON OUR MOST
VULNERABLE. AND OFTEN FORGOTTEN
MEMBERS OF OUR POPULATION AND
FINALLY AS THE GOVERNOR STATED
SO ELOQUENTLY. BEHIND THE
NUMBER IS A PERSON SO I WANT TO
THINK COMMITTEE FOR THE TIMES.
THANK YOU MA'AM. OPERATOR CAN
WE HAVE THE NET CALLER. LINE
ONE TWENTY GO AHEAD PLEASE. HI
MY NAME IS MICHELLE AND THE MOM
AND- I ONE MOMENT AN OPTICAL
CHARACTER CALIFORNIA KID HERE I
TO SEE IF SH AND THE SENATE FOR
THE LEADERSHIP IN AB. FIVE
NINETY EIGHT UNANIMOUS CONSENT
SH WE ARE BROKE THAT THE
GOVERNOR COULD. HEARING AID
PROGRAM FOR CHILDREN NAY BE BY
THE ONE WEEK AGO AND ALL TO
EIGHTY NINETY EIGHT THAT WITH
EVERY MEMBERS SH A GOVERNOR NEW
SHOULD GREEN THE TEN HE
PROPOSED HE TAKES. IT IS
JANUARY BUT OR SIGN THOUGH THE
LAW IT IS POSSIBLE ASSEMBLY
SPEECH SPEAKER. FOR THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED PROGRAM IN
JANUARY BUT THE TWO TO THREE
MILLION DEFILE ACOSTA FIND THE
BILL BUT IT'S POSSIBLE YOU CAN.
THOUSANDS WHICH WHO ARE DEAF
AND HARD TO HEAR BLACK ACCESS
TO HEARING IT. ONLY ONE IN TEN
PRIVATE INSURANCE PLANS COME
THE COST TO HEARING AIDS
RELATED SERVICES SHOULD A
PROBLEM THAT BACK TO BACK. SH
HEY MANY FAMILIES OF STATE WITH
THE COST CHOICE BETWEEN RENT
AND PUTTING ON THE TABLE SHE-
SIX THOUSAND ONE AID NO HOW BY.
SIMPLY NOT AN OPTION. CREDIT
LINES OF. OUT DOCTOR DO CHANCE
SPOKE ABOUT HOW IS AN-
EMERGENCY UNDER DEVELOP OF
EMERGENCY THE FIRST WITH THE.
IN A CHILD'S BRAIN. AND IT
BECOMES A MORE PERMANENT
PROBLEMS THAT IMPACT THEIR
LEARNING AND IT'S NOT LIKE WE
CAN GO BACK AND FIX THAT SHE IS
NOT THE DEVASTATING TO THE NEW
ONE THREE THREE EIGHT EIGHT BY
SIX MONTHS DEVELOPED. IN RATED
THEIR HEARING. TYLER WHO NEEDS
TO HEAR THEIR PARENTS. READ
BEING LAID THE FOUNDATION FOR
GREAT DEALS DEVELOPMENT.
UNETHICAL H. TABLET MY
DAUGHTER. WHO NEED THEIR
HEARING AIDS. TO HEAR THEIR
TEACHERS AND CLASSMATES ONLINE
WE WOULD BE ABLE TO ATTEND
SCHOOL. WITHOUT HEARING AIDS
THIS WON'T HAPPEN AND PUT THEIR
JEOPARDY IN FUTURE. THIS IS THE
TERRIFYING A DIFFICULT TIME FOR
ALL CHILDREN. BUT FOR CHILDREN
BEING WITHOUT HEARING AIDS YOU
MARCH MATTER CANNOT BE STATING.
TWO SIDED TENTS ARE ALREADY
SIGNIFICANTLY. HIGHER AMONG THE-
YOUR PEERS EVEN AT YOUNG. WE
FEAR THAT WILL AMPLIFY THE
FEELING HOPELESS. BUT THE WORLD
IS NOW. IT WE KNOW HE'S ON CUTS.
WE RECOGNIZE ALL. THAT CODE IS
EVERY IT DOESN'T GO FAR. SHE
BUT WE NEED YOU TO CAN TO WITH.
SHE IS THE GOVERNOR. THE
GOVERNOR DOESN'T TO PAY IT BACK
UP DOESN'T WHY TO PAY FOR IT
YOU THE STATE'S DEATH THEN MAKE
THE HELL PLAN WHAT. BY
PERMITTING COVERAGE BUT THAT IS
NOT THE BUDGET BUT EVERY YEAR.
I OF PUSHING ALSO MAKE COST.
THE HEALTH EDUCATION SYSTEM OF
THE IT DOWN FISCAL POLICY AT
THE RIGHT THING TO DO BUT
CALVET IF YOU'RE THANK YOU SO
MUCH. MA'AM YOU'VE BEEN HEARD-LOUD AND CLEAR AND I APPRECIATE
YOUR TESTIMONY. OPERATOR IF WE
CAN HAVE THE NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
I IN ONE TO GO AHEAD PLACE.
HELLO ON A ENDEAVOR TEXEIRA AND
I'M A SOCIAL WORKER AT THE IN
THE SINCE HE AND SANTA CRUZ
COUNTY. SINCE I WORK AT THE
HEALTH PROJECTS CENTER I SEE
FIRSTHAND THE INVALUABLE FOR.
THE DANTE CARE GIVERS RECEIVED
FROM THE DEL MAR CARE GIVER
RESOURCE CENTER. AT STATE. AS
THEY CARE FOR THEIR OLDER.
RELATIVES WERE BRIGHT WHO HAVE
BRAIN IMPAIRMENTS INCLUDING
ALZHEIMER'S STROKE AND
TRAUMATIC BRAIN INJURIES. ABOUT
EIGHT YEARS AGO MY EIGHTY FOUR
YEAR OLD MOTHER CELL DURING THE
NIGHT AND ENCOURAGES SUBDURAL
HEMATOMA REQUIRING A KEY
CRANIOTOMY THAT AT HER AGE WITH
LIFE THREATENING. MY MOM
MIRACULOUSLY SURVIVED THE
SURGERY BUT WAS LEFT WITH A
SIGNIFICANT COGNITIVE
IMPAIRMENT. WHICH CHANGED HER
FROM BEING A FORMIDABLE WOMAN
IN CHARGE TO SOMEONE WHO COULD
NOT TRACK BEING WHO EXPERIENCE
COGNITIVE AND EMOTIONAL
COMPONENT WE DID NOT UNDERSTAND.
I TOOK A MONTH OFF FOR FAMILY
LEAVE WITH MY MOM RETURN CALL
TO HELP BOTH MIKE TRAUMATIZED
ELDER PERISCOPE AND TO RE
ESTABLISH THEIR LONG TERM LIFE.
IN THEIR HOME TOGETHER AND TO
SUPPORT MY MOM AND HER
CONTINUING NEED FOR THEIR ANY.
AND AFTER THAT MONTH WAS OVER I
RETURNED EVERY WEEKEND TO HELP
MY PARENTS AND TO MONITOR THEIR
NEEDS AFTER WORKING FULL TIME
AT THE END OF THE HE- AT THE
CARE MANAGER OF FIFTY ELDER
DISABLED CLIENTS CONCERNED. AT
THIS TIME I BECAME A CLIENT OF
THE C. R. C. AND WAS GRATEFUL
TO BENEFIT FROM THE COURT THEY
PROVIDED MEET AT THE CARE
GIVER. MANAGING MY MOM'S
RECUPERATION AS WE STRUGGLE TO
KEEP HER AT HOME WITH MY
GREETING A TRAUMATIZED DAD. AND
TO HELP THEM BY RIPPING THEIR
DAILY LIVES IN THEIR CARE. AT
THE CLIENT I RECEIVED A
SUBSIDIZED REFERRAL FOR ELDER
LAW ATTORNEY- TO ASSIST MY
PARENTS. WITH THEIR LEGAL
CONCERNS AND THEN ONGOING
COUNSELLING SUPPORT FOR MY OWN
NEEDS AS I TRY TO UNDERSTAND.
MY MOTHER'S MEDICAL AND
PSYCHOLOGICAL NEEDS AND TO COPE
WITH THEM. THE C. R. C. PROVIDE
SUPPORT TO UNPAID FAMILY CARE
GIVERS THE ELDERS OF BRAIN
IMPAIRMENTS. WHICH IS A HIGHLY
COST EFFECTIVE STRATEGY TO KEEP
FOLKS IN THEIR HOMES WITH THEIR
FAMILIES AND THEIR COMMUNITIES.
TO AVOID EXPENSIVE
INSTITUTIONALIZATION FAT CAUSE
DISORIENTATION AT THE OLDER
ADULT. I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND CONSIDERATION TO BE
SUPPORT. THESE IMPORTANT
CONCERN. THANK YOU MA'AM AND
OPERATOR IF WE CAN HAVE THE
NEXT CALL AND WE HAVE ONE OUR
REMAINING OF PUBLIC TESTIMONY.
LINE TWO ZERO ONE GO AHEAD
PLEASE. THANK YOU CLICK HERE
FIRST IN BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA OPTOMETRIC
ASSOCIATION I WANT TO THANK THE
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR YOUR REMARKS
EARLIER IN THE HEARING ABOUT
THE MEDI CAL OPTIONAL. WE LOST
YOU THERE MR BURKE ARE YOU ON
MUTE. OPERATOR I MAY HAVE US
MOVE ON TO THE NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. OPERATOR ARE YOU THERE.
DEFINITELY NOT ONE INCLUDE YEAH.
IN THE MOVIE. THAT RIGHT. YEAH.
THE DROP WILL PROBABLY. FOR
THOSE OF YOU WHO MAY BE
WATCHING AT HOME- OUR
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT EIGHTEEN
ANTI PHONE CALL HAS DROPPED AND
WE ARE ATTEMPTING TO GET THEM
BACK ON TO THE LINE I WOULD
JUST URGE PATIENCE AS WE WORK
THROUGH THESE TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTIES. NOW. FOR THAT ONE.
RIGHT RIGHT. UHHUH. WELL YEAH A
BUNCH OF THEM THE PLAN. THEY'RE
GOING ON THAT. ONE NOW I. BEGAN
HAS TURNED MEMBER THE
EXPLANATION FOR WHY THE
GOVERNOR DIDN'T WANT TO DO A
COMMERCIAL PLAN BENEFITS
MANDATE AND I CAN'T REMEMBER IF
THERE WAS AN EXPLANATION BUT A
LOT OF DIFFERENT BY SOMETHING
THE FRENCH FRIES PROBABLY DON'T
TWENTY TIMES WHAT OUR POLICY AS
A POLICY THAT. NUMBER NUMBER ON.
WE'RE PROBABLY LIVE. I THINK I
THINK WERE BEING HEARD IN A
LIVE STREAM TO SAY. YEAH I
THINK THAT THOSE ARE CONCERNS
THAT THE LETTER. YEAH YEAH.
HELLO BUT- OKAY. HI OKAY. IF
YOU CAN GET A LOT BUT. HI ALL.
YEAH. YEAH. OKAY.
YEAH RIGHT.
ALL RIGHT AT ALL NUMBER YEAH
THE TECHNICAL NAME ONLY WHEN
SOMEONE. YEAH. THE BEST THAT.
ONE YEAH. RIGHT.
REALLY MY
WANNA AND NOW ONCE AGAIN THAT
WERE WORKING ON. JUST FOR THOSE
WHO ARE WATCHING WE ARE
CONTINUING TO. TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTIES AND ARE ATTEMPTING
TO TRY TO WORK THROUGH THEM
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
ALL RIGHT THEN AND THERE
AUTHORED ON YEAH. AND THEN I
GOT. ALL OF. OKAY THEY.
ONE OF
THE BAD WILL FEEL. THE. YEAH
YEAH I HAVE. YEAH IF I.
SURE
YEAH. YEAH YEAH. ALL. PERFECT
YEAH.
FORTY THREE. BUT YEAH.
CERTAINLY. YEAH BUT IT IS. I
MEAN CAN YOU. RIGHT.
YEAH WELL.
YEAH. OKAY OKAY OKAY EVERYBODY.
THAT RIGHT. IF YEAH CURRENTLY
THE MICROPHONE YEAH.
HAVING AN
ISSUE WITH ANYTHING FOR THE FOR
TRAILER ATTEMPTING TO REACH
OKAY.
DOCTOR RAMBLING MIGHT
WANNA REMIND FOLKS ABOUT
WRITTEN COMMENT. SUBMISSION OF.
FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO ARE STILL
LISTENING I DID WANT TO REMIND
YOU THAT YOU ARE ABLE TO
SUBMIT- WRITTEN COMMENT AND
WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU TO USE THE
BUDGET SUB ONE. EMAIL ADDRESS
AT BUDGET SUB ONE AD ASM DOT CA
DOT GOV WE ARE IN THE PROCESS
OF ATTEMPTING TO RECONNECT WITH
EIGHTEEN T. AND WOOD AND
BRANCH- YOUR CHANCE AGAIN.
THANK YOU EVERYONE FOR STICKING
WITH US DURING THESE TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTIES. RIGHT.
I. I. SO
OKAY.
I BY WHERE WHERE CAN WE
CONNECTED THE ASSEMBLY ROOM.
OKAY. HELLO THERE IS THIS THE
OPERATOR FOR EIGHTEEN ANTI.
TODAY TEN T. WE HAVE YOU BACK
ON THE MAIN CONFERENCE. THANK
YOU SIR I BELIEVE OUR LAST
CALLER WAS MISTER BURKE AND I'M
WONDERING IF YOU CAN- RESTART
WITH THEM OR IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO MOVE ON TO THE NEXT CALLER.
I BELIEVE WE'RE AYE RIGHT NOW
ONLINE ONE SIXTY EIGHT. YEAH
YOU MAY GO AHEAD. THE ALL STAR
OVER. IN THE ABSENCE OF TIME
I'M GOING TO BE VERY VERY FREE-
MY NAME IS NANCY POWERS DOWN
AND I AM THE DIRECTOR OF
REDWOOD CARE GIVER RESOURCE
CENTER SERVING SEVEN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA COUNTIES THEM BEING
CINEMA SOLANO NAPA LAKE
MENDOCINO HUMBLED AND DOWN NOR
WE ARE PART OF THE CALIFORNIA
EVER RESOURCE CENTER WHICH- MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE ALREADY SHARED
HERE KID DAY. I AM ALSO A
WORKING FAMILY CAREGIVER FOR MY
NINETY YEAR OLD IN LAWS WHO ARE
SHELTERING AT HOME IN CINEMA
COUNTY AT THIS TIME AND WHO
WOULD BOTH BE IN A SKILLED
NURSING FACILITY WITH THE CARE
AND SUPPORT OF MYSELF AND MY
HUSBAND. ON BEHALF OF THE
ESTIMATED FIVE MILLION PLUS
UNPAID FAMILY CARE GIVERS IN
CALIFORNIA I AM ASKING THAT YOU
REJECTED THE GOVERNOR'S MAY
REVISED PROPOSAL. TO REVERSE
THE CARE GIVER RESOURCE CENTER
AUGMENTATION. SO THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE TO OFFER EAST CENTRAL
SERVICES TO SOME OF THE MOST
VULNERABLE CALIFORNIANS AND
THEIR CAREGIVERS. NOW MORE THAN
EVER IF THE TIME TO SUPPORT
FAMILIES BUT OTHERS ESTATE
COURAGEOUSLY. TIRELESSLY AND
WILLINGLY DO THE WORK TO KEEP
THEIR- FAMILY MEMBERS. MANY
WITH COMPLICATED CHRONIC HEALTH
CONDITIONS IN EUROPE COGNITIVE
IMPAIRMENT STATE HOME. I WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY AND I WANT TO
SPECIALLY THANK TALK WOULD.
TOUCH THE- RESULTS ARE ONLY IN
CALIFORNIA. YOU DO NOT CUT
FUNDS THE CARE REACHED CENTER
SYSTEM MSRP OR SEE THANK YOU
THANK YOU MA'AM HI NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. Q. OUR NEXT CALLER
THAT'LL COME FROM ONE OF TWO TO
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS PART I SEE F. THE OWNER
OF SEVEN INTERMEDIATE CARE
FACILITIES CARING FOR SEVERITY
DEVELOPMENT DISABLED ADULTS AND
WHAT THE CALIFORNIA. I URGE YOU
TO READ THAT THE CUT AND PROP
FIFTY SIX FUNDS FOR ICF HOME.
OUR RESIDENTS WILL LOSE THEIR
HOME THE FUNDS. AND SO WHAT
WELL I HEARD STAFF AND WILL BE
WITH THEIR JOBS ADEQUATE
FUNDING IF NECESSARY TO KEEP
ICF OPEN THE ALTERNATIVE IS TO
SEND OUR RESIDENTS BACK TO THE
HOSPITAL JUST MORE COSTLY FOR
THE STATE AND PROVIDES
FLEXIBILITY. AS FAR RIGHT TO
LIVE THEIR LIVES. PLEASE LEAVE
YOUR JACK THE PROPOSAL. YOU
NEED TO CUT PROPERTIES THAT AND
HELP PREVENT THE EEP AT HOME
THANK YOU VERY. THANK YOU MA'AM
AND OPERATOR AS WE'RE MOVING TO
THE NEXT CALLER I MAY JUST-
REMIND US AND APOLOGIZE FOR THE
DELAY THAT WE HAD DUE TO
TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES. WE
STILL DO HAVE THIRTY CALLERS
REMAINING AND IN THIRTY FIVE
MINUTES WE HAVE A HARD TO STOP
SO I WOULD JUST IMPLORE- THOSE
ARE CALLING IN AND BEEN PATIENT
ENOUGH ON THE LINES TO ATTEMPT
TO BE AS BRIEF AS POSSIBLE.
THANK YOU AND WITH THAT
OPERATOR CAN WE HAVE THE NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. YES OUR NEXT
CALLER BECAUSE ONE OF TWO SIX
ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MICHAEL DATE ELECTRICAL POLICY
WITH CHILDREN NOW NONPARTISAN
RESEARCH AND POLICY
ORGANIZATION FOCUSED ON
TRANSFORM CHILDREN'S ADVOCACY.
WELL WHAT ABOUT THE BOAT. OKAY
SERVICEMEN ACT OF THE PROVIDER.
OF THE TO BE PERFECT OPPOSITION
FIFTEEN FUND AND I PUT THEM
AWAY FOR MEDI CAL BUT THE BY
TWELVE CHECK A CENTER AND
SCREENING BLOOM AND TO ENSURE
ACT TO PREVENTIVE CARE AFTER
YEARS OF SIGNIFICANT UNDER
UTILIZATION OF PREVENTIVE
SERVICES AN ISSUE WHICH IS ONLY
BEEN EXACERBATED DUE TO THE CAN
BACK IT IS ESTIMATED THAT
SEVENTY OR 80% OF KIDS WE ARE
NOT SINGLE PEDIATRICIAN AND NOW
THE TIME TO ACT HEALTHCARE FOR
CHILDREN. SHOULD BE MADE TO
SHORE UP THEY WANT TO THINK
THAT WHAT THE HALTHCARE
PROVIDER MIGHT OF PUBLIC TO
QUITE GET IT BACK THEY SHOULD
BE WIDELY INVESTING CHILDREN'S
HEALTH AND WELL BEING LIKE
IMPORTANT MENTAL HEALTH
SUPPORTS THE COMMUNITY HEALTH
WORKERS. A TAURUS. IT WAS.
AFTER TRAINING FOR SCHOOL YOU
MENTAL HEALTH FIRST AID WHICH
WOULD MAKE IT DIDN'T BECAUSE
AND LOOK TO WHATWITH YOU TO
PUT HEALTHCARE COACH IN THE
BUDGET AND HEALTH AN MENTAL
NEED OF CHILDREN YOUTH ON THAT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO.
OPERATOR NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
YES THEIR NECK PAYMENT GOING TO
COME FROM LA OF TO SAY EIGHT.
TWO SEVEN EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBERS WANTED TO HEAR WHAT THE
CALIFORNIA AND I THINK HEALTH
NETWORK- WE JUST WANT TO HEAR
SOME COMMENTS ABOUT THE DEEP
CONCERN- CUTS RELATED TO
PROGRAM THAT WOULD HARM
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE LARGELY
UNDER SERVED- WE'D LIKE TO
EXPRESS THEIR DISAPPOINTMENT IN
THE WITHDRAWAL WILL FOR THE
HEALTH FOR ALL SENIORS. A
PROPOSED THAT WOULD HELP
ANSWERED THE NEEDS OF
UNDOCUMENTED CALIFORNIANS WHO
ARE AT HIGHER RISK OF
CONTRACTING COAL BED- AND WOULD
NOT HAVE ACCESS TO YOUR PRIMARY
CARE AND OTHER TYPES OF
TREATMENT- WE ALL ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT- THE REDUCTION OF DENTAL
BENEFITS- BUT WE ALL. KNOW WE
ARE GRATEFUL THAT IT'S NOT A
COMPLETE ELIMINATION. I'M
ACTION DOES NOT HI. YOUR CAN
BUT- THROUGH WHY HAVE BEEN BY
REST OF THE AND SPOKE
PREVIOUSLY ON DO NOT HAVE A- TO
PARTIAL BAN AND SOME EVEN BY
MOVING THUNDER. DEATH HAVE
DURING MET ONE ONLY FOR
DENTURES WERE AVAILABLE WE
DON'T WANT TO GO BACKWARDS AND
PUT PEOPLE IN A POSITION.
ADDITIONALLY WERE CONCERNED
ABOUT THE WITHDRAWAL OF FUNDS
FOR NAVIGATOR HEALTHCARE
INVOLVEMENT NAVIGATORS ARE
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT RIGHT NOW
AS PEOPLE HAVE EXPERIENCE IN
MANY JOBS LOST. AN INABILITY TO
GET INTO CARE OR UNDERSTAND
WHAT THEIR OPTIONS ARE.
COMMUNITY WORKERS WILL HAVE
TRUST. IN THE- AND CAN PROVIDE
A LANGUAGE OF THE END AND OTHER
CALL UP. SERVICES YOUR
DISAPPOINTED TO SEE THAT THE
PROPOSAL HAS ELIMINATED THE
BLACK INFANT HEALTH PROJECT-
THIS PROGRAM HAS HAD GREAT
SUCCESS IN REDUCE MORTALITY
FOR. RENTS AN IMPROVING HEALTH
OF MOTHERS AS WELL- WOULD LIKE
TO SEE THAT COMPLETELY AGREE
AND DAD- WE ALSO ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT THE LOW INCOME AGED BLIND
AND DISABLED MEDI CAL
EXPANSION- BEING ELIMINATED
THESE ARE SOME OF THE MOST
VULNERABLE CALIFORNIANS AND GOT
SOME OF THE HIGHER COMPLICATION
BIRTH FACTORS- CIRCLE BUT
NINETEEN. ARE WE ARE ALSO
CONCERNED ABOUT FOR THE MENTAL
HEALTH BEING REDUCE AND
ELIMINATE IT- SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES FOR MENTAL HEALTH ARE
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT ESPECIALLY
DURING THE QUARANTINE- AND HAVE
CREDIBLE IMPACT- DEPICTING
HELPED IT. A LOT WE REJECT THAT.
YOU THE SCREENING BRIEF EVENT
IN THE FALL TO TREATMENT. AS
KNOW THAT OVER TO OVERDOSE THAT
ARE ON THE BY ARE WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH ALLEGE.
AND THE LEADERSHIP DURING THE
CRITICAL TIME TO ME
CALIFORNIANS WHERE THEY'RE AT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MA'AM
OPERATOR OUR NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
YES SIR NEXT DAVID GONNA COME
TO LINE OF TWO EIGHT SIX.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HEAR ME YES
MA'AM. OKAY GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS JESSICA MATT AND I'M A
SOCIAL WORKER FOR THE DEL MAR
KICK OF RESEARCH CENTER ONE OF
ELEVEN SUCH CENTERS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THE BUDGET CUTS TOWARD
OUR CARE GIVER RESOURCE CENTER.
CARE GIVING FOR SOMEONE WITH A
PROGRESSIVE DISEASE OF
COGNITIVE AND OFTEN PHYSICAL
IMPAIRMENT IS ONE OF THE
TOUGHEST CHALLENGES ONE FACES
WITH INTERPERSONAL
RELATIONSHIPS. I WORK WITH MANY
CLIENTS HAVE LOST THEIR FAMILY
MEMBERS TO DIFFERENT
TRAJECTORIES OF THE MANY
DIFFERENT TYPES OF DEMENTIA AND
DISEASES THAT AFFECT COGNITION
PERSONALITY TEMPERAMENT AND
ABILITY TO TAKE CARE OF THEIR
DAILY PERSONAL LIVES. THEY ARE
IN PAIN AND IN NEED OF SUPPORT
OUR PROGRAM DISEASE CARE GIVERS
AND OUTLETS THAT TEAM AND A
GLIMMER OF HOPE. WE AROUND THEM
WITH AND GEN AND YOU. OR
EMPATHY AND RESPITE GRANT. I
THOUGHT CLIENTS TELL ME THEY
CRIED WITH RELIEF WHEN THEY
RECEIVED THE GRANT BUT IT WAS A
BLESSING A GODSEND THANK YOU
FOR PROFANITY. THIS ALLOWED
THEM TO CONTINUE TO PROVIDE THE
OVER SIXTY BILLION OF DOLLARS
OF UNPAID LABOR EACH YEAR TO
KEEP THEIR LOVED ONE AT HOME.
WHILE GIVING THEM A MUCH NEEDED
BREAK FOR THEIR EMOTIONAL AND
MENTAL HEALTH. I UNDERSTAND THE
BUDGET CTS NEED TO HAPPEN. I
AM SO PROUD OF OUR STATE BUT
THE PRO ACTIVE IN EARLY MEASURE
THAT TOOK THE BASIS THAT THE
PANDEMIC. HOWEVER IT WILL BE
DOING A DISSERVICE TO SOME OF
THE MOST VULNERABLE MEMBERS OF
OUR STATE. DOES THAT WOULD BE A
HARD HIT BY CC NINETEEN THE
PROBABLY SUCH IMPORTANT FUND
FOR THEM AT THE TIME. THE
NATION OF THE THREE A CUTS ARE
YOU TRUST THAT. A TWO THIRDS
BUDGET CUTS TO SEE OUR SPEECH
PLEASE. PLEASE RECONSIDER
LIMITING AND THAT HE AND PLEASE
RECONSIDER REVERSING THE
THERAPY BUDGET AUGMENTATION
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU MA'AM. OPERATOR CAN
WE HAVE THE NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
YES NEXT DAVIS GONNA COME FROM
LINED UP TO NINE EIGHT. ONE
MOMENT. PLEASE GO AHEAD THE
HELLO. YEAH RIGHT WOOD MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. I'M DOWN ABANDONED
THE DIRECTOR OF THE LOS ANGELES
CARE GIVER RESOURCE CENTER
HOUSED AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA LETTER
DATED SCHOOL OF GERONTOLOGY.
HEARD FROM MANY OF THE- ELEVEN
CARE GIVER RESOURCE CENTERS AND
I JUST WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT
ARE AMONG OUR CARE GIVING
FAMILIES WHO ARE. OLDER ADULTS
MANY KINDS WE FORGET THAT OLDER
ADULTS IN THE COMMUNITY. HAVE A
FAMILY MEMBER BEHIND THEM AND
THAT MEMBER WHO REALLY NEED OUR
SUPPORT AND HELP SO THAT THEY
CAN CONTINUE DOING WHAT THEY
HAVE CHOSEN TO DO AND SOMETIMES
ARE REQUIRED TO DO BY HEALTH
CONDITIONS FOR THEIR FAMILY
MEMBERS RIGHT NOW- THE CUTS
THAT ARE BEING PROPOSED FOR
FAMILIES AND OLDER ADULTS I
CANNOT BE A JUSTIFICATION. WE
ALSO KNOW THAT FOR THE FAMILY
MEMBERS- MEDICAL ARE YOUNGER
FAMILY MEMBERS AGES AND IF WE
CAN BE TO CUT SERVICES LIKE
IMITATES P. THE BASS THE CARE
RESOURCE. MANY OF THESE PEOPLE
WILL HAVE TO MAKE A CHOICE
BETWEEN WORKING AND CARING FOR
THEIR FAMILY MEMBER. SO I URGE
YOU TO FIND ALTERNATIVES TO THE
PATH TO THESE SERVICES OF THE
CALIFORNIA REALLY CAN BE THERE
FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS. AND
CALIFORNIANS AND SO THAT WE CAN
ALSO CONTINUE WITH OUR MASTER
PLAN ON AGING IN MAKING
CALIFORNIA PLACE THE PEOPLE
WANT TO. STAY AND GO. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU MA'AM.
OPERATOR CAN WE HAVE THE NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. YES THE NEXT DAY
IT WAS GOING TO COME THROUGH A
LINE OF TWO THREE ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS AUDREY EDU.
A HOT WITH LOS THAT CALL THE
NEXT COME FROM OF THREE ZERO
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. POLITICS
AFFECT CALLERS DROPPED ALSO OF
THE TRY LINE TWO NINE ZERO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES MA'AM. I MY NAME'S
ARIANNA APOSTOL FOR THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA WE JUST WANTED TO
URGE THE SUBCOMMITTEE TO ASK
BANK ROUTING A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS FROM PROP FIFTY SIX IN
THE BUDGET FOR PROVIDER RATE
INCREASES THE FAMILY PLANNING
AND REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE
SERVICE PROVIDER I THANK AND
CAL GRANT. FUNDED PROGRAM TO
ENSURE HIGH QUALITY CARE IS
ACCEPTABLE TO ALL CALIFORNIANS
REGARDLESS OF INCOME LEVEL I'M
PETER WRITING RATE INCREASES
ARE ALSO CRUCIAL TO SENDING THE
TIDE OF HEALTH CENTER CLOSER
BUT FURTHER EXACERBATE EXISTING
GEOGRAPHIC DISPARITIES IN
ACCESS TO HEALTHCARE. STATE
INVESTMENT IN FAMILY PLANNING
JOG DOWN AND NINE TO ONE
FEDERAL MATCH. CUTTING RE
INCREASE. AND FEDERAL NOW
BEHIND THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MA'AM. OPERATOR OUR NEXT CALL
PLEASE. YES SIR NEXT COMMERCE
GOING TO COME TO LINE UP TO ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SURE HI GOOD
AFTERNOON THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY MY NAME IS BRENDA
BIRD WELL AND I'M A FAMILY
CONSULTANT FOR THE CULT CARE
GIVER WE ARE CENTER. MY
COLLEAGUE FROM THE OTHER CARE
GIVERS. HAVE ELOQUENTLY
ARTICULATED THE IMPORTANCE OF
THE CARE GIVER RESOURCE CENTER
PROGRAM. I JUST WANT TO TAKE A
MOMENT TO TALK ABOUT TOO MUCH
PLANS ARE. I'M HERE OFF THE
REST BUT THE DAUGHTER WHO QUIT
HER JOB. TO TAKE CARE OF HER
MOTHER FOR KIND WHO HAS A LS.
LEAVING ON ABOUT THERE'S
CALPERS NJ BUT ARE OWN BED FOR
OVER FORM. I'M HERE TO PROVIDE
COUNSELING. FOR THE CLIENT
GIVES A FUN HER MOTHER HAD
ALZHEIMER'S AND HER GRANDMOTHER
DIED FROM ALZHEIMER'S. WE'VE
REVAMPS OUR CARE GIVERS LOCAL
PARK RIDGE THEM MEETING. AND
THE BIG TOPIC FOR THE ME THANK
ARE NOT ONE. WHO ARE NOT ABLE
TO TAKE OUT OF THIS THAT THEIR
LOVED ONES AND FACILITIES.
THEY'RE DIFFICULT TO WAIT BUT
THEN TO THE WENT. AND THE LEFT
ONE DOESN'T UNDERSTAND WHY THEY
CAN'T THE THOUGHT AND HAD A
DAUGHTER. PLEASE ALLOW US TO
CONTINUE TO THINK. ON THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MA'AM
OPERATOR CAN WE HAVE THE NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. YES SIR NEXT
COMMENT WILL COME FROM ONE OF
TWO NINE SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRTH
THEIR BIRTH ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
HEALTHCARE DISTRICT FOR THE
SAKE OF TIME I WILL BE BRIEF MY
COMMENTS AND WILL BE FOLLOWING
UP WITH A ETTER TO THE
COMMITTEE TO PROVIDE FURTHER
DETAILS. HEALTHCARE DISTRICT
HOSPITAL CLINICS BILL NURSING
FACILITIES AND COMMUNITY
SUPPORT SERVICES I'VE BEEN AT
THE FOREFRONT OF CARING FOR
CALIFORNIANS DURING THE CRISIS.
THE HEALTHCARE DELIVERY SYSTEM
IS EXTREMELY FRAGILE AND WE ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE BUDGET CUTS
AT THE FERTILITY WE ECHO THAT
TURNS REGARDING THE CUT TO
PROVIDERS AND CARE WORK FUNDING
INCLUDING THE NEIGHBORING
INCLUDE IN. YOUR SUPPORTIVE OF
THE CALIFORNIA POPULOUS.
PROPOSAL FOR IT NOW FUNDING FOR
HOSPITALS NOT INCLUDED IN THE
REVISED AS WELL AS I UNDERSTAND
THE NEED FOR THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT THAT. ADDITIONAL
WITHIN A- FINANCE POSITION.
REFLECTED IN ABOUT WE AND
ALLEGE. HE THOUGHT ABOUT
REGULATE CHANGES. IN THE EIGHT
OR LEAVE. SOME OF THE BURDEN
TALK BUT AND OTHER PROVIDERS.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO. YOU CONVERT
BUT THE LEGISLATURE AND
ADMINISTRATION AND ARE
COMMITTED TO REMAINING A
REPORT. AND A QUARTER ON THE
TOPIC THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MA'AM. OPERATOR CAN WE HAVE THE
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. YES THE
NEXT COMMON IS GOING TO COME
FROM THE LINE OF THREE TO SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. CAPITALIST
MEMBERS THERE GET A FROM BEHALF
MARKET ON FIRST LET ME START BY
THANKING THE CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR YOUR
COMMENTS QUESTIONING THAT WITH
THEM AB ELIMINATING. BIRTH THE
ASSEMBLY PART IN THE
ELIMINATION OF BY TO PROGRAMS
MARKET I'M SUPPOSED THAT THE
PROPOSED CUTS IN THE MAYBE
ABOUT THE MEDI CAL AND THE
DEPARTMENT PUBLIC HEALTH CARE
ON. TOP WRAPPED. WITH THAT.
ABOUT THE LIMóN THE FUNDING
FOR MEDI CAL BOTH BURDEN
CHARACTER- WOMEN DIAGNOSED WITH
WITHIN. HEALTH CONDITION THE.
WORLD WILL. A READ THAT BIT.
GOOD PART OF PUBLIC HEALTH I
DON'T BELIEVE AND- HEALTH
PROGRAMS. ALTHOUGH WE WORK NOT
ATTRACTIVE RIGHT THE AFTER GET
THE GOVERNOR IF THEY ACCEPTABLE
ADDRESS PANDEMIC SO KEEP THAT
THING AT THE HOME ORDER MAY BUT
I THEM WOMEN ALREADY ALONE WITH
REACH BUT- PREVENTING THE- FROM
FROM. THE BY THE WE URGE LET'S
RIDGE THE TO REJECT PROPOSED
AND IT. IN THE PHOTO DATED
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR. OPERATOR WE HAVE
THE NEXT COLOR. YES THE NEXT
COMMERCE CONNECT LINE OF ONE
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AFTERNOON THAT THE ADDRESS AND
THE GAL FROM PLANNED PARENTHOOD
BELIEVE FOR CALIFORNIA I JUST
WANT TO THANK EVERYONE WHO
RAISED CONCERNS ABOUT THE
CONSEQUENCES OF REMOVING OF
BILLIONS OF FEDERAL HEALTHCARE
DOLLARS FROM OUR STATE I'M
CALLING SPECIFICALLY HIGHLIGHT
BUT THE REVISED. TO SHIP
PROVIDER RATE FUNDED BY THE SIX
INCLUDED THE ONE HUNDRED
MILLION FOR WOMEN'S HEALTH
SERVICES AND FAMILY PLANNING
THIS IS A STRIKING EXAMPLE OF
THE CONCERN ABOUT FEDERAL
FUNDING BECAUSE- MASS HAS
APPROVED A NINE TO ONE MATCH.
NOT TO ONE MATCH THE VAST
MAJORITY OF THE STATE
ALLOCATION THROUGH THE END OF
NEXT YEAR FIFTEEN FROM THE
RIVER CONTROL TAKE ROCK ONE
BILLION DOLLARS IN COMBINED
FEDERAL AND STATE AWAIT. AND
ARE IN NEED OF REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTHCARE FAMILY PACK. AND
MEDI CAL. FOR THE GOING BACK TO
HELP PREVENT CLING YOUR THE
TWENTY. AFTER YEAR THE DRAGON
AND REDUCE. AND WITHOUT THE
THOUGHT CAME HELP ON WILL BE
WITH ON THING. REIMBURSEMENT
RATES THAT HAVE NOT BEEN
INCREASE FOR AT LEAST A DECADE.
ALMOST 90% OF PLANNED
PARENTHOOD PATIENTS RELY ON
PUBLIC PROGRAMS SUCH AS
MEDICARE. SO WE ARE ALSO
ACUTELY AWARE AT LEAST TWO
MILLION NEW MEDI CAL AND ROLLED
HIS ARE EXPECTED. DUE TO THE
THREE FASHION BUT THAT IS
EXACTLY BY REMOVING FUNDING
FROM SAFETY NET PROVIDERS WOULD
BE DETRIMENTAL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MA'AM OPERATOR CAN WE HAVE
THE NEXT CALLER PLEASE. LV LINE
THREE TWENTY TO GO AHEAD. SO
ALL CAN AVAILABLE YES MA'AM.
THANK YOU HI THANK YOU BYE AND
I'M CALLING TODAY AS A FAMILY
MEMBER HAD TO PROJECTS TO
GRANDPARENTS. FEEDBACK THE BILL
THEY HEALTHCARE MY FAMILY LIVES
IN THE WORLD CALIFORNIA WHERE
WE'VE BEEN VERY AFFECTED BY
WILDFIRES. DURING ONE OF THE
PAST WILD FIVE ONE OF MY
GRANDPARENTS. TO HELP PRICES
TRIGGERED BY THE FLOW. AFTER
THE HOUSE. SHE MIGHT HAVE HAD
TO GO INTO THE GOVERNOR
FACILITY FACILITY BUT INSTEAD
SHE WAS ABLE TO ATTEND THE
ABOUT THE BUILDING HEALTHCARE.
AS SHE AND MY GRANDFATHER WAS
THANK YOU FOR THE PROGRAM A
WHOLE FAMILY BATES STRONGER AND
HEALTHIER BECAUSE OF THE PAST.
LAST YEAR THE CAMPFIRE
COURTYARD AND A NEARLY THIRTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE PRESIDENT DI
LOCATED ON PUBLIC CHECK OUT.
BECAUSE OF THE RETIREMENT SHE
DON'T HAVE BEEN IMPACT THEIR
NUMBER OF OLDER. ADULTS YEARS
OF LOS SO MUCH NEED OUR SUPPORT.
PARTICULARLY NOW WHEN OLD
ADULTS ARE THE MOST BALL.
BECAUSE IT YOU. I THINK I'LL BE
HEALTHCARE HAS BEEN THE SUPPORT
THEY ONE OF THE OF MY OKAY.
PROVIDING JACK OKAY FOR THE
GOING BACK TO THERAPY MAIL THAT
ACTIVITY BECAUSE OF IF THE POOR
SUCH. LEFT BEHIND ENTIRELY
THINK ABOUT THE WORLD. THANK
YOU MA'AM OPERATOR CAN WE HAVE
THE NEXT CALLER PLEASE. OKAY
LINE THREE THIRTY ONE GO AHEAD.
HEY CAN YOU HEAR ME YES MA'AM.
WONDERFUL GOOD AFTERNOON THIS
IS MARRYING REPRESENTING EARLY
SMALL CIRCLING A PROGRAM WHERE
YOU CAN SACRAMENTO IS THE
SCHOOL BEACH PROGRAM THAT
PROVIDES PREVENTIVE DENTAL
SERVICES BLOCK GRANTS COUNTY.
WELL PROVIDE ORAL HEALTH THAT.
THAT THE SCREENING FLUORIDE
VARNISH TREATMENT AND TURN
COORDINATION TO DENTAL CARE FOR
MOST VULNERABLE POPULATION OUR
CHILDREN. DENTAL MANAGED CARE
CAN ACTIVE DENTAL CAN HELP OF
CALIFORNIA AND LIBERTY DENTAL
CAMPUS FUND AND SUPPORT EARLY
FALL BACK ON THE PROGRAM. PMC
PATENTS HOPEFULLY SNAPBACK
COMMANDO BY HELPING NOT THE
CHILDREN TO DENTAL HOME MAKING
APPOINTMENTS AND PROVIDING
TRANSLATION AND TRANSPORTATION
IF NEEDED. TO GIVE YOU AN
EXAMPLE THREE ONE OF OUR DENTAL
SCREENINGS I HAVE ENCOUNTERED A
CHILD THAT WAS ABLE TO CHIU
WITH ONE SIDE OF HER MOUTH DUE
TO SEVERE DENTAL DECAY. OUR
STAFF IN A BODY THAT HELPS AND
CAN WORK WITH DENTAL CAN'T TO
MAKE AN EMERGENCY DENTAL
APPOINTMENT WE WERE ABLE TO GET
THE CHILD OUT OF PAIN AND TREAT
IT WITHIN FORTY EIGHT HOURS.
UNFORTUNATELY THERE ARE CAN
PREVENT SUFFERING FROM DENTAL
PAIN AND OUR SCHOOLS. LAST YEAR
LET ME PROVIDE SERVICES OVER.
TWENTY SIX BOB. OKAY I OF TWO
SEVEN HOW FIFTY FOR KIDDOS WORK
AND PAIN OR HAVE AN ACTOR
ACCESS WHICH WE AND EMERGENCY
DENTAL. WE WORK VERY CLOSELY
WITH SCHOOL NURSES TO SCHEDULE
SERVICES AND SCHOOL NURSES RELY
ON DENTAL NEEDS OF THEIR
STUDENTS. WITHOUT THE NC PLANS
WE WILL NOT BE IF THE PROVIDER
SERVICES THEREFORE I APPROVED
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO
ELIMINATE THE DENTAL MANAGED
CARE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR- THANK
YOU MA'AM OPERATOR CAN WE HAVE
THE NEXT CALLER PLEASE. LINE
THREE THIRTY EIGHT GO AHEAD
PLEASE. I MEAN IT'S DIFFICULT
AND THE PRESIDENT AND CEO OF
CHOICE IN AGING AND NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION WHERE WE PROVIDE
BOTH THE MULTI PARTICULAR
SERVICES PROGRAMS AND COMMUNITY
BASED ABOUT SERVICES. WE
PROVIDE THOSE SERVICES AND
CONTRA COSTA NOW BUT IN THE
LINE OF COUNTY AND WE'RE THE
ONLY PROVIDERS NEMESIS PIANO
COUNTY AND I. WANT TO JUST
FIRST EXPRESS MY MOST SINCERE
GRATITUDE. FOR THE WAY THAT
THIS. COMMITTEE CAME OUT THIS
MORNING SAYING VERY LOUD AND
VERY CLEARLY AT THE ON SET BUT
THIS IS UNACCEPTABLE. FIFTY
THOUSAND OF CALIFORNIA'S MOST
FRAIL OLDER ADULTS WILL HAVE
THE ONLY SERVICES THAT KEEP
THEM FROM LIVING IN
INSTITUTIONS REMOVED WHEN WE'RE
IN A TIME WHERE THE VAST
MAJORITY OF CALLED THE DEATH
STAR HAPPENING IN SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES THEIR ONLY
OTHER OPTION TO LET YOU CAN
LOOK AT THE FINANCES OF THAT
AND HOW MUCH MORE COST TO HELP
PEOPLE IN. NURSING FACILITIES
BUT I'M ASKING YOU TO LOOK AT
THE DEATH SENTENCE THAT WE ARE
ASSIGNING TO PEOPLE- NO FAULT
OF THEIR OWN WHO PAVED THE WAY
FOR I. AM ASKING YOU TO PLEASE
STEP INTO YOUR POWER AND AVOID
THESE ELIMINATION FROM
HAPPENING THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU MA'AM. I DO WANT TO
REMIND PEOPLE WE HAVE
APPROXIMATELY TWENTY FIVE
PEOPLE ALL AND I APOLOGIZE ONLY
FIFTEEN MINUTES REMAINING WE
GET THROUGH AS MANY AS AN AND
WITHOUT OP WILL TAKE NEXT. LINE
FORTY TWO I HAD PLACED. HI GAS
ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTS
TEACHERS AFFAIR COUNCIL WE'RE
HERE TO URGE YOU TO REJECT A
PROPOSAL TO ELIMINATE THAT
DENTAL CAL CARE MANAGED- CARE
PROGRAM- OUR TEACHER MEMBERS
HELP SERVICES PROGRAM IT'S
CRITICAL TO PROVIDING
PREVENTATIVE DENTAL CARE FOR
THE NEEDIEST CALIFORNIANS- WE
BELIEVE PROPOSAL COULD ACTUALLY
COST MONEY RATHER THAN SAVE
MONEY DUE TO- UNDER UTILIZATION
OF PREVENTIVE SERVICES AND OVER
UTILIZATION OF COSTLY
PROCEDURES- DISPOSAL AS BOB FOR.
THE PARTICIPANTS IN THE DENTAL
CAL PROGRAM AND JEOPARDIZES
GOOD UNION JOBS SO PLEASE
REJECT THIS WEEK THANK YOU SIR.
OPERATOR COMING OVER THE NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. LINE FORTY THREE
GO AHEAD PLEASE. GOOD
AFTERNOON- BUT ARAMBULA MEMBERS
OF THE MAYBE I THANK YOU FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY MY NAME IS OUT
AND UP THAT'LL BE ADVOCATE FOR
THE ELDERLY BUT- DISTRICT. THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL ELIMINATE
THEN OKAY MATCH CARE LIKE THE
EARLY I'LL THE LAND ELIMINATE
OF THIS FOR WILL MAKE A HUGE
IMPACT IN THE WE NEED FOR THE
EXTERNALNEED BEFORE THE BIG
BOX. THAT ARE NOT ALL
VULNERABLE. I DON'T WANT YOU TO
PRACTICE THE- IN ADDITION TO
THAT. AND PIECE BETTER SNAPPING
PERMITTED TO. BE DENTAL
TREATMENT FOR THAT'D STARTED.
TO THE GAP BAND ALONG WITH
FRANKLY SHOULD HAPPEN THE
PICTURE SERVICE THE TO HAVE AN
APPOINTMENT. BUT THE- THAT.
RIGHT THE PROGRAM IS REGION
THANK YOU THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. IN LINE THREE
FORTY. GO AHEAD PLEASE. MY NAME
THE AT THE FRIDAY AND I ALONE
AT NIGHT YEAH HE DN IMPAIRED I
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU KNOW
PARADISE BUT DEVASTATED BY
CAMPFIRE I LOST MY HOME. MY ICS
PROVIDES AN IN JUNE OF TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN ABOUT MY
RESIDENT BACK MANY HAVE BEEN IN
MY CARE FOR OVER TWENTY FIVE
YEARS AND WITH THE HOME.
CAMPFIRE BUT HERE PAUL PLANTS
THE CUT THE PROPOSITION FIFTY
SIX I THE FTV BE EQUALLY
DEVASTATING AND DIFFERENT WAY.
AT A TIME WHEN THE. ORAL ARE
THE MOST FROM. THANK WE NEED TO
RALLY A THEIR BEST THAT IN BUT
THE POINT THEM. SPENT THOUSANDS
OF FOR P. TO PROTECT OUR STAFF
AND RATHER THAN. AND I'VE BEEN
KERN MANY OF EXPENSES TRYING TO
KEEP THEM SAFE WE CANNOT DO
THIS ON THE PROGRAM.
200-082-0009 BATES ALONE. I
CLOSER IF THIS FIFTY SIX AND
THEIR CAT. ANY OTHER OPTIONS
FOR PLACEMENT- WILL COST MORE.
RESIDENTS OF FULL TIME AND
REJECT THE PROPOSAL TO CUT OFF
OF THE SIX FIFTY SIX BUT THE
IDEA THE BEES I KNOW WHAT IT'S
LIKE TO LOSE MY HOME. EMPLOYEE
THAT RESIDENTS SAY THEY THEY
DON'T HAVE TO LOSE THEIR THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. LINE THREE FORTY
NINE GO AHEAD PLACE. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON IN YEAH MY NAME IS
BARBARA CRITICAL TRY WITH THE-
NOT TOO LONG AGO HEY DO OUR FOR
MY MOTHER- AND THEN MY MOTHER
IN LAW AND MY GRANDMOTHER OR-
BOTH IN HOME AND IN A NURSING
HOME SITUATION- BY BECAME AWARE
I'M AWARE OF HE WORKED AT.
TICKET TO A RESOURCE CENTERS
ARE DOING AND I WISH THAT THERE
I HAD GOOD FOR RICHEST
CELEBRITIES WHEN I WAS VERY BIG
RECORD DURING IT CAN GET VERY
UNFORTUNATE BUT THERE. THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSING TO.
ELIMINATE THE AUGMENTATION FOR
THE- THE FUNDING AND I URGE
THAT CARE THE FRIENDLY UP NOT
MAKE THE CORRECT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. LINE THREE FIFTY ONE GO
AHEAD PLEASE. HELLO MY NAME IS
GLORY YEAH AND I'M CALLING FROM
THAT GOT MY CARE GIVER RESOURCE
CENTER AND I AM WE ARE ONE OF
THE ELEVEN AND THE CARE GIVER
WHICH ARE SENATE THAN THE STATE
CALIFORNIA WE SERVICE THE
MODERATE TENTACLES AND SEVENTY
DON'T COUNTY. AND I'M GONNA
THINK TIME AND SAY THAT WE ECHO
WHAT MY COLLEAGUES HAVE ALREADY
SHARED REGARDING WHITE QUIEN
IMPERATIVE THAT WE KEEP THAT
AND THAT'S THE KEY INCORRECTLY
SERVICE THAT NOT ONLY DURING
THIS TIME BECAUSE OF THE COPY
NINETEEN OUR MOST VULNERABLE
THE ELDERLY SUSCEPTIBLE TO A
LOT O THINGS BY STATE THEY ARE
VERY VULNERABLE EVERY DAY. AND
SO IT'S VERY IMPORTANT THAT I
ASK YOU TO REJECT THE FEELING
WEAK AND AM AT THAT ELIMINATION
THANK YOU. CHAIR RAMBLING
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU MA'AM.
NEXT CALLER. LINE THREE TO FOUR
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS. IN
THAT WORLD. AND I AM CALLING.
GET BURKE IT THE CENTER. AND I
WANTED TO EVERY HELP THE ABOUT
THE RIGHT ONE. THAT MANY OF THE
GIVE ARE CLEANER THAN ALL OF
THE LAPTOP. SO IT IS OFF. OUR
OLD TRYING TO GET ALL THANK YOU
ALL. AND THE BUT THE PLAN SO I
THINK THIS. ALL OF THAT WILL BE
OUR EIGHT TO BE DOCTOR HAD BEEN
FOR A LONG ON. HOW BIG A YOU
HAVE CHANGE PETER OFFERING ALL
OF OUR- HELLO ALL THE BILLING
AND ACT JOHN BUT- WITH THE
POCKET. SO AGAIN WE MAKE OUR
YOUR OFF THE INTO THE BILL THE-
THAT BOTHERED ME THAT. WOULD BE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS MY NAME IS
TONY LAMBERT I AM AN RN AND
CREDENTIALED SCHOOL NUMBERS
WITH SACRAMENTO CITY UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT. I AM CALLING
TO OPPOSE THE PROPOSAL TO
ELIMINATE DENTAL MANAGED CARE
IN SACRAMENTO COUNTY WHICH
INCLUDES THE EARLY SMILE
SACRAMENTO PROGRAM. AT THE
SCHOOL I SPEAK FOR MYSELF AND
MANY OTHERS. ARE THAT UTILIZES.
IT'S A SENSUAL IT PROVIDES
GENERAL EDUCATION SCREENING AND
FOLLOW UP FOR STUDENTS AND ALSO
PROVIDES TIMELY VITAL LINKS
DENTAL CARE PRIOR TO PROGRAM
FAN WHERE WE MONTHS OR LONG.
FOR PROPER DENTAL CARE. I'M I
STRONGLY BELIEVE THAT NOW IS
NOT THE TIME TO LOSE ACCORDING
CARE CONSUMER FOR. AND PROVIDER.
THAT THE DENTAL CARE COKE
PROVIDES THINK SO MUCH THANK
YOU MA'AM. LINE THREE SICK GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME IS TERRY
WAR HI REPRESENTS THE O. A
COMMUNITY LIVING OPTIONS. OWNER
AND OPERATOR ICO DD IN
VERSATILITY LOOK IN BUT IN ANY
EL CENTRO AND DANA POINT CAL.
THE STATE SERVER DEVELOPMENT
DISABLED POPULATE. I RISK URGE
YOU TO READ THE CUTS IN THE
PROPER FIFTY SIT FUN. LIKE SHE
ET HOMES PLEASE RESTORE THIS IS
FUNDING OUR MEDI CAL RE. RATES
HAVE BEEN PRO SINCE THOUSAND
NINE FOR THE RECENT STOP WHAT
PAIN PROVIDE UNDER PROFITS
PROPOSITION SIX. ADDITIONALLY
I'M INCURRING IN COSTS FOR NOW
TO MY CAN HOMES. OF THE- GIVEN
ONE HOW PERCENT FOR ICF HOW
COMES FROM MEDICARE. WHEN THAT
FUNDING IS CUT THE IN HALF IS
IF WE LOSE PROPOSITION SIX
FUNDS IT WILL FORCE THE CLOTHES
OF ALL OUR STILL. PLEASE
MAINTAIN THIS PROP FIFTY SIX
FUNDING THE ARE CAN STAY. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SIR NEXT PLEASE.
LINE THREE TWENTY SO QUOTE. MY
NAME IS VERY FROM PROVIDENCE
ANGELS OF HOW A MASK FOR YOUR
RECONSIDER OF THE RIVER OF THE
ON. TO THE GIVER READ THAT. AS
A HOW SYSTEM WE'RE THE BEEN
PAID LEAVE OUR HOSP NAY THEY
HAVE MORE AND MORE CALM THE
THAT OFTEN CALLED ON FAMILY MAN
TWO K. OUT. THERE IS ALREADY A
LIMB SAVED NET TO THE CARE. TO
PROPOSE BUDGET IMPACTING TO
YOUR SEATS PASADENA OF P. WILL
DISARRAY THIS THING NET THE
RESULTS OF THE CUTS LIKELY MORE.
BOTH CARE GIVERS ARE
OVERSTRESSED AND CARE RISKY.
GIVERS ARE LEFT AVAILABLE TO
CARE FOR THEM. IT WILL LEAD TO
MORE HOME. OF OVER ONE CARE
GIVERS FEEL THAT THEY HAVE NO
CHOICE BUT TO AND TO. SO LOVE
FOR. THE CARE GIVER IS CENTER
ARE CALLED COST EFFECTIVE MARCH
PROBE. THAT DESERVES IT FULL
FOR FROM THE STATE THANK YOU
FOR MUCH. THANK YOU SIR. NEXT
CALLER PLAY. LINE THREE THREE
QUOTE PLEASE. THANK YOU FOR THE
TOP I'M MEYER PROGRAMS YOLO
DON'T THEY HELPED IN WITH
CALIFORNIA R. C. BACK PROGRAM
BUILT BY JUST COMMUNITY THIRTY
SIX YEARS AGO AND LIKE TWO
HUNDRED SIXTY OTHER SEA BASS
PROGRAMS WE PROVIDE COMPLEX
CARE SERVICES TO OUR COUNTY
FRAILES WHO MEET ELIGIBILITY
REQUIREMENTS FOR NURSING HOME
CARE AT ONE QUARTER THE COST OF
NURSING HOME CARE C. BASS
PROVIDES CHOICE. THE CHOICE IS
THAT THAT IS CLEARLY OUTLINED
AS LEGALLY REQUIRED DUE TO THE
EIGHTEEN NINETY NINE OLMSTEAD
DECISION FOR THE TO BRING COURT
HELD PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES
HAVE QUALIFY RIGHT TO RECEIVE
STATE SOME AND SERVICES THE
COMMUNITY RATHER THAN IN
INSTITUTIONS IT WOULD BE ON THE
DECISION THAT PREVENTED THE
STATE FROM ELIMINATING FEEDBACK
TEN YEARS AGO AFTER THE STATE
INVESTED ALMOST FORTY MILLION
DEFEND THE ELIMINATION. SO WITH
ALL DUE RESPECT I ASK YOU WHAT
HAD THAT WOULD BE ALL STATE.
ASIAN AGAIN. TO DEFY GIVE
IDENTIFY AS A CORE SO OF THE
MASTER OF EIGHT AND YOU EFFECTS
AND OUR CALL SAVING TO THIS THE
BASS IS TO THE FEW SYSTEM LONG
TERM CARE FOR. SO COMING BACK
FROM THE LIMITATION WILL BACK
OF IN. THAT WILL BE. CA IN
LIGHT OF THE ALL STATE THIS.
AND THE MASTER PLAN FOR. THE
LET'S JUST HAS THE CHOICE TO DO
WHAT IS RIGHT BY FOR OKAY. AND
AVOID CON HARM. THANK YOU SOME.
THANK YOU MA'AM I WOULD JUST
ASK AGAIN WE OF FIFTEEN PEOPLE
AND ABOUT FIVE MINUTES LEFT SO
LET'S TRY AND KEEP OUR COMMENTS
AS SHORT AS POSSIBLE NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. OKAY FOR HUNDRED
CLASS PLACE. HI UP MONEY BOBBY
SUITOR I'M A FAN CAN FLOW WITH
DEL MARK GIVER CENTER IN FOR
THE SAKE OF BREVARD BREVITY I'M
GOING TO READ OF COURSE OF A
LET THAT ONE OF MY CLIENTS TO
THE COMMITTEE. QUOTE PLEASE CUT
FUNDING TO THE CARE GIVER
RESOURCE CENTER LAST YEAR MY
HUSBAND HAD A MASSIVE STROKE
CALL WE WERE WORKING OUT AT
CROSSFIT IT WAS ONLY SIXTY
EIGHT AND IN FANTASTIC. YOU
KNOW PARALYZED ON ONE SIDE AND
BEDRIDDEN I TAKE CARE OF IN
TWENTY FOUR SEVEN THIS IS THE
HARDEST JOB BY EVERY HAD HE'S
SIX FOOT OR HAVE LIFT ON AND
OFF THE TOILET DAY I HAVE TO
GET UP ALL NIGHT TO PROVIDE
CARE I AM A- IT EVERY WAY. WE
HAVE TO PAY FOR ALL OF HER HELP
OUT OF OUR OWN. WE'RE USING OUR
STATE TO PAY FOR IT CARE BUT DE
KNOW HOW LONG THAT WILL. THE OF
THE REST FOR GRANTS RECEIVE
FROM DELL SO YOUR C. OF BEEN A
LYFT. TO STRENGTH AND SAN FROM.
THERE'S NO WAY I CARE THE VERY
TO SAY MAN ALL ON MY OWN. I
KNOW THAT YOU HAVE BEEN VERY TO
SEE TO MAKE EGARDING TO CUT.
FOR PLEASE. PLEASE KEEP THE
GIVE A ROUGH. GOING CAN CHEN TO
FULL FUND THE CARE. REACHED
CENTER. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MA'AM. NEXT CALLER. FIND. FOUR
ZERO EIGHT. NINE FOUR ZERO
EIGHT TWO LINE IS OPEN. WILL
MOVE ON TO LINE ONE EIGHTY FOUR.
DOCTOR RAMBLING COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THIS IS JULIE SNYDER
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS DIRECTOR FOR
THE INSTITUTE STEINBERG
INSTITUTE- BIRTH KUDOS FOR
SETTING UP THREE FIVE HOURS OF
HEARING- SECOND I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
EXPRESS OUR CONCERN THAT THAT
MAY REVISED OVERLOOKS THE
EMERGENCE OF A SECONDARY. CO
OCCURRING PANDEMIC OF MENTAL
HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE ABUSE
ISSUES AND TO SHARE OUR HOPE
THAT THE LEGISLATURE WILL
CORRECT THIS OVERSIGHT AS NOTED
DAILY IN THE PRESS THIS CRISIS
IS PUT MANY OF US UNDER SEVERE
EMOTIONAL SOCIAL AND ECONOMIC
STRUCTURE. EONS AS THE
FINANCIAL IMPACT OF RISING
UNEMPLOYMENT ARE MORE DEEPLY
FELT CALIFORNIA WILL BE MORE
DEATHS OF DESPAIR. MR GRAMM
UPWARDS OF TWENTY ONE THOUSAND
ADDITIONAL SUICIDE AND DRUG
OVERDOSES AT THE CURRENT LEVEL
OF UNEMPLOYMENT IN LIGHT OF
THESE INCREASING BUT
PREVENTABLE MENTAL HEALTH AND
SUBSTANCE USE TRAGEDIES WE ASK
THIS COMMITTEE CONSIDER THREE
RELATIVELY MODEST PROPOSALS.
THE FIRST IS THE CREATION OF.
WITH LIVED EXPERIENCE TO
SUPPORT ENTRY PEOPLE SEVERE
ILLNESS AND SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDERS. SENATOR BILL SB A OH
THREE WHAT WILL THE PROGRAM.
FOR FIVE MILLION DOLLARS THE
STATE CAN JOIN FOR EIGHT OTHERS.
IN THE V. EIGHT IN UTILIZING TO
EXPAND THE MENTAL HEALTH WORK
FOR AND PRO CALL IF SUPPORT.
OUR SECOND PER REAL TO AN- WE
REQUESTED THE IT. GRAY TO HELP
FOR. TO CAL AND SPENDING NHL
FUN TO MAKE. KOBE RELATED
MENTAL NEEDS. LASTLY WE URGE
YOU TO OFFER MOTT SUPPORT TO
BOARD CARE HOW THE PROVIDING
AFFORDABLE PLACE TO. MEDICAID
IF THE- AND OTHER CARE
CALIFORNIANS WITH SEVERE MAY
ILLNESS. EVEN BEFORE CO THAT HE-
THIS VITAL OF CAL. HOUSING WAS
RAPIDLY BEGINNING. INTO
FRANCISCO A THIRD HAVE CLOSED
SINCE TWELVE IN LOS ANGELES
THIRTY NINE HAVE CLOSE IN THE
PAST FORTY. THE OF COMPLYING
COBIT RELATED DIRECT AND OF.
STAFFING. ENTERTAINING UP IN
THE FALL APART. THANK VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT LOSING THE
CRUCIAL IN CARE OP FOR WITH
SEVERE MENTAL ILLNESS WHO HAVE
A LOW. HI LEGAL PA IS THAT RISK
FOR BE HOMELESS WE THE ADMIN TO
SUBMIT A MAY HOW ELEVEN FIFTEEN
A TO COME PORTS OF FOR AND CARE
TOBIN RELATED AND WOOD WELCOME
THE TO WITH ON AND- THANK YOU
FOR YOUR- FEDERATION. OPERATE
WE HAVE A CALLER PLAY. SIR THAT
WILL BE FROM FOR. APARTMENT
FORCED GO AHEAD PLEASE. GEN
ARAMBULA MEMBER OF THE THANK
YOU FOR NOT TO BUY COMMENT AND
TRACY RAT TRADE FROM PUBLIC AND-
WITHOUT QUESTION LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENT NEED RESOURCE. TO
INCREASE CAPACITY HANDLE THE IN
ME NEEDS OF COKE NINETY CONTROL.
OF EQUAL URGENT OUR MOST
VULNERABLE TO HEALTH AND
ABILITY TO. THIS CRETIN DIVIDE
SOCIAL THE OF HEALTH THE TWO
BLACK ABOUT TO HELP FOOD
UNEMPLOYED UNSTABLE. AND HEALTH
CARE THESE LED TO. WE HIGH RATE
OF HEART DISEASE DIED. AND LOW
AND OF COLOR BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC AND OF RESULTED IN HER
BREAKING AND ASK IN CONTRACTING
AND DIE FROM THANK TODAY. ARE
HEALTH WAS MONTHS IN NEW
FUNDING FOR COMMUNITY
PREVENTION STE. TO HELP
VULNERABLE CALLOUS WHETHER ON A
LOT OF CHRONIC ILLNESS AND
DEATH TO DESPAIR BUT WE KNOW
WHAT WE'RE FROM ON THAT NEEDS
TAXATION OF UNHEALTHY. COULD BE
ONE SOURCE OF REVENUE TO
BOLSTER FIGHT FOR PER. WE DON'T
HAVE TO TREATING THE. ADDRESS
COMMUNITY PREVENTION WHICH WILL
SAVE MORE LAW IN THE RUN WE CAN
AND WE MUST INVOKE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MUCH. NEXT CALL
PLEASE. I'M TWENTY THREE GO
AHEAD PLEASE. THE CURRENT
ESTRADA DIRECTOR OF IN GOVERN
THESE CENTER SERVING. OVER THE
PAST FEW MONTHS NOT BEING ABLE
TO VISIT FAMILY HERE OF BEING
INFECTED OR IN FACT IN OUR
LOVED ONES FEAR OF THE UNKNOWN
NOT BEING ABLE TO DO SOMETHING
AS SIMPLE AS GROCERY SHOPPING.
FAMILY CARE GIVERS HAVE BEEN IN
DOING FOR YEARS AFTER A COUPLE
OF MONTHS BUT FOR YEARS. THE
EMPLOYER TO YOU NOT TO CUT
FUNDING FOR THEM. AS YOU ONLY
AND- THE PRESSURE ARE. EX THE
SADNESS AND THE ISOLATE FEELING
THAT WE ARE ALSO. JUST IMAGINE
THE BEING. AN ON. OVER THE
COURSE THE REMAINDER THE YEARS
THAT CARRYING THEIR LOVED SO
PLEASE NINE THIRTY YOU TO FIND
IN A WAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MA'AM. NEXT CALLER BOGART LINE
FOR. SIX GO AHEAD. HELLO GO
AHEAD PLEASE YES THANK YOU
HELLO LAURIN ANNETTA THE ELK
GROVE UNIFIED SCHOOL I'M A
PROGRAM TO SPEND WITH OUR
SUPPORT CENTER AND I'VE BEEN
SOCIAL WORK DISTRICT FOR OVER
THIRTY YEARS I'M TALKING TODAY
ABOUT BE. AS YOU'VE HEARD FROM
SOME OF MY OTHER COLLEAGUES-
LIBERTY DENTAL EARLY SMILED AT
OUR SCHOOL DISTRICT AS WELL AS
SACRAMENTO CITY UNIFIED WE HAVE
SEEN WHAT IT'S LIKE FOR
FAMILIES TO TRY TO ACCESS HERE
ESPECIALLY FOR YOUNG CHILDREN
CHILDREN WITH SPECIAL NEEDS-
KILLED WITH IMMEDIATE DENTAL
CARE CHILDREN WHO NEED
REFERRALS- AND- TO LIVE. HERE
THAT REQUIRES A GREAT DEAL OF
NAVIGATION THAT OUR AVERAGE.
SPECIALLY THE LANGUAGE BARRIERS
FIND VERY TO OUR IF YOU AROUND
THE OUT PROFESSIONAL WITH.
WHITE BIRCH THE COMMITTEE TAKE
UNDER AND- THAT TREND BACK TO
NANTUCKET AWAY FOR MANAGED CARE
INTO PETER. WILL BE AT THE
CREDIBLE BACK FOR OUR FAMILIES
LIVE LEARNED TO. CHAMPION THE
SYSTEM AND GET THE- ANGEL CARE
FOR OUR CHILDREN THAT THEY NEED
AN INTERNAL ALL BACKGROUND MAY
YEARS OF A POOR AND COMPLETE
FAMILIES BE MORE. FOR THE HELL
CHARACTER KILLED THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND COMPUTER AS MAKE
THEIR DECISIONS IF. THANK YOU
MA'AM NEXT CALLER PLEASE. WILL
MOVE TO LINE FOR TWO FIVE GO
PLEASE. HI MY NAME IS AUDREY
EDWARDS I'M A CREDENTIAL SCHOOL
NURSE WITH SAM ONE UNIFIED
DISTRICT IN SACRAMENTO COUNTY
AND I'M CALLING BECAUSE I'M
CONCERNED POSTS CHANGES FOR
MANAGED CARE DENTAL PROGRAM.
SACRAMENTO CHANGING FIFTY FOR
SERVICE DENTAL. I'M MEDI CAL WE
WERE VERY CLOSELY AS THE SCHOOL
WE TO. THAT WAS TO FROM THE
GEOGRAPHIC MANAGED DENTAL. BUT
IS THAT REALLY SMELL SACRAMENTO
THAT PEOPLE HAVE SPOKE ABOUT
AND THEY RUDY DENTALS COMMUNITY
OUTREACH PROGRAMS. HELP CLOSE
TO MYSELF OTHERS NURSES. THE
HELL WITH LINK TO ATTEND. EVEN
IF THE STUDENT IS AN- WE KNOW
THAT WE CALL THE ANY. FOR
NURSES HAVE BEEN TWELVE FIVE
AND FOUR THOUSAND STUDENTS ON
THEIR KEY. SO WE'RE REALLY
INTERESTED NEED OF THEIR
SUPPORT. JUST AB YEAH HEAD A
SEVEN GRADE STEEL WAS REALLY
NICE HE WAS TALKING. LIST I.
THANK. IN TURN ABOUT DO PAIN
AND THEN THAT PERSON CONTACT
THE SO WORKER THE CUT. ME AND-
THIS WILL SEARCH FOR SOCIAL ALL
MEN THAT THE STUDENT AND HIS
WERE HOME. MAYBE HE A CAR GET
HAD HE TROOPS ABUSE. SO
IMMEDIATELY WITH A TO BE DAD IS
ITSELF SORT OF AMERICA BECAUSE
I THE- DON'T ANSWER THEIR PHONE
I A QUICK OR CHECK GOT MEDI CAL
AN THEN I CALL THE EARLY
SMALLER. I WOULD. HAVE TO BE.
AND NOW THAT. DON'T PUT A YEAR
AGO FOR THE SAME AREA BECAME
WITH BY NOW WITH AT THE URGENT
LEVEL YEAH BREAK TO AMERICA
STATE SO THIS TO WITH GIVEN AT
THE AMERICAN DEL A TO THE NECK
DAY AND I KNEW IT THAT POINT AT
THE TOP BUT BECAUSE SERVICE AND
WOULD BE. WITH THE STUDENT AND
ALSO THE NOW FROM EARLY
SACRAMENTO. KAMALA AND LIBERTY
DEMOS OUTREACH PROGRAMS HELP
WITH SO MUCH WITH CRYPTIC.
TRANSLATION THE GENERAL
PRESENTATIONS ALTHOUGH THINGS
THEY ALSO HELP WITH WITH- SO.
IN DENTISTRY WHICH USUALLY
BECAUSE GOT IT CARE DIDN'T.
OFFER SO AND MOVED TO PASS
ABOUT. FIFTY DENTISTRY THEY'RE
VERY FIGHT AND DO WANT TO CA TO
THIS AND WE REALLY TRY TO DO
WITH. AND I WASN'T SAN HIS
WORKING WITH RELEASED NOW
SACRAMENTO AND THE DEBT OUT WE
REALLY MORE KIDS INTO HAVE A
ROUTINE DENTIST. AND THEN
THEY'VE TALKED IN YEAH ON TO
THE. AND I'M WITH THE AND
LÏNG CARE GIVER REPORT CENTER
TO ADD MY COLLEAGUES HAVE
EXPRESSED- FROM ALL THE OTHER
ELEVEN FEARED THE THAT THAT AND
SUPPORT THAT WE PROVIDE FOR
CAREGIVERS. I LIKE SHARE A-
THAT MY CLAIM HERE WITH ME THIS
MORNING. AND SO SHE IS THE
CHARACTER- WHERE HER HUSBAND
WHO HAS DEMENTIA RELATED
DIAGNOSIS. AND IT. IS THE HOW
THE- EVER RESOURCE CENTER TED
HAS ACTUALLY MADE HER LIFE. SO
SHE MENTIONED THAT SHE DEALS
WITH MANY HEALTH ISSUE AND
BECAUSE HER HUSBAND HAD
DEMENTIA HER HEALTH ISSUES ARE
ON THE BURNER. AND YOU SHOULD
HAVE BEEN HOBBLED BY YOURSELF
ON MULTIPLE. WHILE HER HUSBAND
WHO HAS- THE DEMENTIA DIAGNOSIS
REMAINS THAT THE CLEAN HEALTHY.
AND SHE DOESN'T HAVE ANY BAD
MEMBER OR ANY OF OUR ANY
FRIENDS. OR AT THE SUPPORT. AND
WITHOUT THE- THAT YOU HAVE
PARTICIPATING AND ALONG WOULD
THE OTHER SERVICE WE ARE UNABLE
I. MY THEY'LL- HAS BEEN ABLE TO
GET FOR THE SHE WASN'T BAY
THAT'S NEIGHBOR BOB AND SO THAT
YOU THAT MAKE THE COMMON THAT
WHAT THE SERVICE SHE WOULD NOT
BE TO KEEP HUSBAND WHAT OF HER
ULTIMATE WHAT. AND SO. HE THIS
CLIENT THESE OF THING BUT MANY
OUR OTHER CLIENTS ARE NOT VERY
UNLIKE BUT THEY ARE THEIR OWN
HOW ISSUE ALONG WITH KAREN FOR
SOMEBODY ELSE AND SO I
DEFINITELY DO AT A- WITH.
MANAGING ARE. NOT WHAT A WEEK
TO GET TO PROVIDE THAT WE-
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MA'AM
OPERATOR OUR NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
I INCREASE SIXTY FIVE GO AHEAD
PLEASE. BY MAY LINE THREE SIXTY
FIVE WE SEEM TO OF LOS TO THEIR
IF I CAN HAVE YOU PLEASE RE
QUEUE BY PRESSING ONE THEN ZERO
WILL BRING IN LINE BACK. CAN
YOU HEAR ME YOUR LINE IS OPEN
NOW. YOUR HONOR MONEY DEMAND
THE VOLUNTEER FOR A RP
CALIFORNIA ON BEHALF OF BURKE
THREE POINT THREE MILLION
MEMBERS IN CALIFORNIA. WHAT
WE'RE GRATEFUL THAT THE MASTER
PLAN AGING PROCESS WILL
CONTINUE. WE ARE DEEPLY
TROUBLED ABOUT THE DEATH THE
STATE BUDGET TO VARIETY OF PRO.
THANK YOU FOR CAL THAT PERSON'S
BUT DISABILITIES AND THEIR
HOMES AND COMMUNITIES. NOTABLE
THE ELIMINATION TO REDUCTIONS
WE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT OUR THE
PROPOSAL TO OF WOMEN AT. SEA
BASS AND IN MISSISSIPPI.
SERVICES ARE LIMITATION OF THE
PROPOSAL FOR THE EXPANSION OF
MEDICARE AGE LINES INTO STABLE
INDIVIDUALS 2138% OF POVERTY. A
PHOTO HURDLE TO READ WE DO
CITING FOR VARIOUS
DOCUMENTATIONS THAT WERE
INCLUDED IN THE TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN BUDGET ACTING PUTTING
CARE GIVER REACHED SENT. SENIOR
NUTRITION PROGRAMS. TERM CARE
NUMBER PROGRAM. EIGHT AND
DISABLED RESOURCE. AND TO THE
DENTAL BENEFITS. ELIMINATE MEDI
CAL OPTIONAL BENEFITS. I'M NOT
GOING TO LET THOSE AND FINALLY
THE DIABETES PROGRAM SERVICES
UP OF THE 7% REDUCTION IN THE
NUMBER OF HOURS PROVIDED HSS
THEIR BENEFICIARIES AFFECTED
JANUARY ONE OF TWENTY TWENTY
ONE AND THE MEDIC EIGHT. THREE
INTRODUCTION. OF COURSE THE
CHART AND WE HOPE TO WORK BUT
THE LEGISLATURE AND
ADMINISTRATION THROUGH THE
MASTER PLAN FOR AGING TO
DETERMINE WORKABLE INNOVATIVE
STRATEGIES THAT WILL HELP OLDER
CALIFORNIANS AND PERSONS WITH
DISABILITIES AVOID
INSTITUTIONALIZATION THEM SAFE
WITH A MASTERS IN A NURSING
HOME OR ASSISTED LIVING
FACILITY. AND THAT NOT.
SURVIVING LAUNCH THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MA'AM. NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. FIND FOR THIRTY FIVE
WILL OPEN YOUR LINE UP AHEAD
PLEASE. HI THIS IS JOE THE
POOREST CORPORATE AND I AM AN
ELDER LAW ATTORNEY IN CHICO
CALIFORNIA I USE IT ON THE
STATE- ADVISORY THE FOR
ALZHEIMER'S AND RELATED
DEMENTIAS. AND I'M ALMOST ALL
GO ON MY LOOK- SEA BASS
PROGRAMS BOARD AND I'M CALLING
TO THE KIND OF- JUST ADD TO THE
OTHER COLOR GUARD TO THE
CONCERN OF CUTS THAT. BELIEVE
THAT WHAT THE FOCUS OF THE SEA
BUT- SB. AS THOSE ARE REALLY
THE LAST LINE OF DEFENSE
AGAINST INSTITUTIONALIZATION
FOR OUR MOST VULNERABLE AND
FRAIL ELDERS. IT IS- THAT THAT-
PROPOSED CUTS WOULD GO AGAINST
THE OLMSTEAD AND MANDATE
THROUGH THAT THAT I HAVE WAS
GIVEN BY THE SUPREME COURT- AND
I KNOW THAT CALIFORNIA IS
INNOVATIVE THERE ARE WAYS TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO. AND COME UP
WITH THE SUIT. SHORTFALL THE
SHORT CUTTING THESE PROGRAMS- I
DO COMMEND THE GOVERNOR ON THE
MASTER PLAN ON AGING. BUT THE
PROPOSED CUTS SEEM TO FLY IN
THE FACE OF WHAT WAS INTENDED
THROUGH THAT- COMMISSION SO I
MIGHT JUST HOPING THAT
CALIFORNIA WILL COME UP. WITH
THESE- INNOVATIVE WAYS THAT HAS
IT HAS OVER TIME BEEN THE
SOURCE IN THE COUNTRY TO BE THE
BEACON I HOPE WILL RISE TO THAT
OCCASION AGAIN. OPERATE THESE.
LINE FOR THIRTY TWO GO AHEAD
PLEASE. ADD TO THE HELLO CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES MA'AM. YES HI-
MY NAME IS MONIQUE ALBANY AND I
AM A CARE GIVER TO AN EIGHTY
THREE YEAR OLD WOMAN WHO HAS
DEMENTIA AND I'M CALLING IN
BECAUSE I WANT TO CLOSE THE
AUGMENTATION AND BEYOND THE
BUDGET ARMY. AND BM. P. R. C.
ADVOCARE GARY THE FACT ACT OF
MANY OF THE MEN FOR THE BODY
BEEN EXPRESSED BY WHAT I WOULD
LIKE TO ADD IS THAT- IF I
DIDN'T HAVE THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA CARE VERY START. AT
MY- SORT OF BACK CALL I DON'T
KNOW WHAT I WOULD DO WITH THE
CARE GIVER. ANOTHER THING THAT
THE FIRST STAGES OF BIG
DEMENTIA I KNOW THAT THIS.
DISEASE PROGRESSES THAT IT'S
GOING TO BE A LONG JOURNEY. AND
IF I DID NOT HAVE- THE THREE
THAT ARE AVAILABLE. YOU'D BE
FORGIVEN. EIGHT IF I DIDN'T
HAVE THEIR SERVICES AVAILABLE I
DON'T KNOW WHAT I WOULD DO- LET
ALONE TRYING TO MAINTAIN A JOB
DURING THE SCOLDED. PANDEMIC
TRYING TO MAINTAIN A HOUSEHOLD
I LIVE WITH HER. MOM IF I
DIDN'T HAVE A SERVICES TO HELP
THE- CENTRAL BANK CARING AND
PARTICULAR AND ALSO HAVE THE
SIX FREE COUNSELING SERVICES- I
DON'T EVEN HAVE THE WORDS TO
EXPRESS. B. B. B. QUESTION THEN
BY THE THAT EVERYBODY FEELS BUT
AT THE CARE GIVER. I DIDN'T
HAVE THIS AVAILABLE TO ME- I
WOULD BE IN THE POSITION OF
HAVING TO PUT MY MOTHER IN A
FACILITY WHICH ARE UNSAFE AT
THIS POINT AND I AM AND SHE
CANNOT AFFORD SAU I STRONGLY
OPPOSE- AUGMENTATION AND- I
DISTRICT WRITTEN RESPECTFULLY
ASK THAT YOU GUYS CAN BETTER.
UNDERSTAND TO THE CARE GIVER
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MA'AM.
OPERATOR WANTED TO SEE IF YOU
WERE THERE AND IF WE HAVE
ANOTHER CALLER. I AM HERE IN
DADE WE DO NOT HAVE ANYONE ELSE
INTO IT THIS TIME. WITH THAT I
WOULD LIKE TO JUST TAKE A
MOMENT AND THANK THE ASSEMBLY
BUDGET STAFF THAT REALLY WANTED
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE PUBLIC
HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO
PARTICIPATE TODAY IN EXTENDED
THE TIME THAT WE HAD. SO THAT
ALL OF THE PUBLIC WAS ABLE TO
GIVE COMMENT HERE TODAY. I ALSO
WANTS TO ACKNOWLEDGE AND THANK
THE- BUDGET STAFF WHO IS HERE
TODAY AND ANDREA. MARKEL SAYS
LISTEN THE- THANK. WITH THAT I
WANTED TO THANK EVERYONE WHO
DID PARTICIPATE HERE TODAY AND
I DO HOPE EVERYONE HAS A GOOD
NIGHT- BE WELL AND STAY SAFE
AND THIS ADJOURNS TODAY SOMEONE.